Intro
Voller Monat werden fast Weltkrieg III am Anfang des Jahres des Monats getrennt wegen Iran und wegen Tic Tac.
Wegen Textor. Ja da war ja einen Tick Tock Herren die sich Sorgen machte dass ein Dritter Weltkrieg kommen könnte und dadurch ging das dann viral und schwappte auch zu Twitter über.
Das hab ich gar nicht richtig mitgekriegt. Tick tack.
Wo wir dann auch noch mal drüber irgendwann diskutieren müssen ob Tick doch ein Medium für politisches ist.
Tack tack.
Du hast das einmal bestritten aber mal gucken.
Er kommt jetzt EU-Kasse. Oder so heißt es.
Okay okay wir reden ja über kleinere kürzere Filme und so weiter.
Okay die Berliner diegleiche über kleinere kürzere Demons und Ende des Monats war es dann nachdem der Weltkrieg drei abgeprüft wurde die Coruña Panik als.
Ende des Monats war es dann nachdem der Weltkrieg drei abgefertigt wurde die Coruna Panik als größter Hashtag.
Größter trennten der Hashtag Nachtfahrt.
Umso besser dass wir hier sehr gute Musik haben wir müssen es gut sagen dass Musik von Matthias Musik Matthias und wer genau hingehört hat hat nochmal den kleinen Unterschied zur Nullnummer gehört.
Umso besser dass wir hier hier gehört habe sehr gute Musik habe das Volk sagen dass Musik von Matthias und Matthias da genau hingehört hat hat noch einmal eine kleine Unterschied zur Nullnummer gehört.
Es kommt jetzt noch eine fröhliche Violine am Schluss die den Bass nochmal einfängt den ich mir so sehr gewünscht habe. Der gezupfte Bass.
Es kommt jetzt noch eine fröhliche Violine am Schluss die den Bass noch einmal einfängt den ich mir gewünscht hatte gezupfte Bass Wir sind hier gut aufgestellt um jetzt in die 20er Jahre zu starten denn sie sind jetzt gestartet.
Wir sind hier gut aufgestellt um jetzt in die 20er Jahre zu starten denn sie sind jetzt gestartet und Wolfgang hat die ganzen Texte gelesen.
Und Wolfgang hat die ganzen Texte gelesen.
Aus dem Spiegel und die taz.
Und auch in der FAZ gab es einen Text Das war so ein Thema in den Feuilletons oder auch im Politikteil und man hat Historiker interviewt die sagten Ja Vergleiche sind immer problematisch natürlich alle Vergleiche hinken.
Man muss aber sagen Die Texte waren größtenteils extrem langweilig sehr erwartbar bisschen künstliche Intelligenz.
Fraglich ob der Dax weiter so steigen wird.
Gewisse Unruhe Populisten gab es damals wie heute.
Aber es war nicht sehr ergiebig und für mich eher so ein bisschen die Krise der schreibenden Zunft repräsentiert was ich da erleben konnte aber es war nicht so.
Es schien mir eher so dass man so Nod Aufmacher Es war zwischen den Jahren niemand wollte mehr so richtig was Neues als Thema setzen aber dann hat man die neuen Zwanziger und dann hat man so ein bisschen zusammengeflickt oder man macht ja auch gerne,
wo dann jeder Redakteur mal ein paar Zeilen schreiben darf was er sich so erhofft er aber wirklich viel Interessantes erfahren hat man nicht,
nicht so viel Sorgen haben dass uns jetzt schon so viel vorweggenommen wurde.
Ich glaube die taz hatte ein Bild Aufmacher zumindest gehabt. Das war ja so sehr verspielt.
Auf der einen Seite dieser alte Zwanzigerjahre kantige Stil aber trotzdem so ein bisschen Modernität reingeholt.
Der Spiegel hat es einfach nur übertrieben zu güldene Zeug Zeuch irgendwie hätte man ja irgendwie.
Meine Vermutung war nämlich auch Ich habe die Texte nicht gelesen aber eine Vermutung und du kannst ja vielleicht bestätigen Es gibt ja Texte die liegen in der Luft weil irgendwie der Anlass da ist so wird üblicherweise Radio gemacht und dann überlegt man wer könnte das denn frühstücken.
Und dann sind das immer Notlösungen Weil ist der Experte zu den 20er Jahren.
Dann gibt's natürlich Texte die trägt man als Autor in sich und dann will man sie irgendwann mal publizieren und dann passiert vielleicht an solchen Epochen Grenzen.
Das scheint mir aber nicht in dieser Art der Selbstverwirklichung eines Autoren zu sein sondern tatsächlich eher redaktioneller Wunsch also Texte zu frühstücken.
Und trotzdem glaube ich gibt es einen guten Kontrapunkt denn so wenig wie jetzt inhaltlich über die beiden Texte sprachen von der taz und vom Spiegel Die Zeit hat sich das Thema auch vorgenommen.
Und da ist es allerdings tatsächlich der Autor dem man auch beim Lesen anmerkt Er wollte hier noch mal den großen Rundumschlag in dem Text feiern.
50 Namen alle aus der Zeit damals alle irgendwie eingeordnet und in Kontext gesetzt.
Ich hatte den Text lange liegen. Also ich spreche von Florian Illies der nochmal in der letzten Woche in der Zeit den Fürther Aufmacher zwei Seiten dazu schrieb auch wunderbar gesetzt mit seinem kantigen aber Schwarzweiß gedruckten Bild und so weiter.
Eine ganz wunderbare Sätze drin die ich allerdings nicht in der App markieren konnte sodass ich sie jetzt noch lesen kann.
Das bietet mir dann die fünf Euro 49 App nicht Ich hole allerdings wirklich ein fulminantes Stück.
Bei Florian Illies der Herausgeber des Herausgeberschaft der Zeit irgendwie keine Ahnung sollte ja mal F.A.Z.
Feuilletonchef werden als Schirrmachers Nachfolger hat das dann abgelehnt führt jetzt seit einem Jahr den Rowohlt Verlag und hat jetzt auch angekündigt wieder zu gehen im Herbst.
Und zwar mit der klaren Ansage Ich will mich lieber dem Schreiben widmen. Also ich habe gar keine neue institutionelle Aufgabe.
Ich will mich beschreiben widmen und es ist großartig wenn sozusagen der Subtext solcher Kündigung ist als Verleger von Rowohlt sind mir eure Texte egal Ich kümmere mich um meine eigenen.
Das ist die Botschaft die da drinnen ganz ganz großartig und in dieser Geisteshaltung nochmal drüber zu schweben so ist dieser Text geschrieben und den möchte ich einfach empfehlen.
Das ist wirklich wenn man sich noch mal so hineindenken will Wie muss man jetzt darüber denken wie ernst muss man eine Grenze nehmen und,
wie geht man mit diesem Zeitgeist von damals um dass man auf der einen Seite dieses Babylon Berlin güldene irgendwie alle feiern und auf der anderen Seite schon dieses Geraune.
Aber Achtung was jetzt kommt und Auschwitz Jetzt wissen wir die Geschichte gebracht hat und da war das noch mal wunderbar eingefangen.
Da kann man bei Florian Illies noch einmal ausbessern was man an Zeitverschwendung in anderen Texten drin hatte.
Also wir sind gut eingestimmt mit den Journalisten und so weiter die sich um diese Dinge kümmern und das ist ja auch ziemlich gut.
Aber auch unsere Politiker haben ja das neue Jahrzehnt versucht einzuläuten.
Damit drängte schon zum ersten Tagesordnungspunkt Neujahrsansprache.
Ich möchte mit zwei Hinweisen zum Ich möchte mich entschuldigen dafür dass wir das jetzt machen. Also ist jetzt die Neujahrsansprache angucken.
Ich brauch sie als Kulisse für das Argument was danach kommt sozusagen.
Denn wir müssen uns kurz darüber verständigen dass von Politikern wirklich nichts mehr zu erwarten ist.
Und wir haben jetzt diesen Moment der Neujahrsansprache der ein Politiker kriegt den Arbeitsauftrag Fülle fünf Minuten Fernsehen.
Er kann machen was er will eigentlich die Starre in der uns das gleiche dargeboten wird ist beängstigend.
Es ist wirklich schlimm da es keine Ideen Ausbreitung da ist gar nichts da kommt nichts aber gleich deswegen zweiter Hinweis Für ganz Ungeduldige die das auch nicht in dreifacher Geschwindigkeit Wir haben hier Kapitalmarkt einen Podcast.
Also ich nehme es niemandem übel wenn er die Neujahrsansprache Wir fangen mit Volker Bouffier an den ersten kann man ja noch hören im Sinne von.
Und dann nochmal neu überlegen springe ich jetzt diesen ganzen Teil oder nicht.
Allerdings wie gesagt wir brauchen es auch als Kulisse,
für ein paar Argumente denn danach schwingen wir uns auf diejenigen die Ideen Durchbrüche Christine Lagarde als neue EZB-Chef finden die neue IWF-Chefin Lagarde folgte die Europäische Kommission ist neu besetzt ist also ein sehr politischer Monat gewesen. Unglaublich eigentlich.
Vielleicht von den zehn Jahresanfang die wir jetzt begleiten die nächsten zehn Jahre der politisch überhaupt.
So viel neue ämter jetzt auch alle auf fünf sieben Jahre besetzt.
Da gerade richtig zur Sache. Und deswegen als Kontrast wo es nicht zur Sache geht. Wir steigen mal ganz kalt ein.
Volker Bouffier startet ins neue Jahr.
Liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger ich begrüße Sie alle sehr herzlich an diesem letzten Abend des Jahres bewegen uns die unterschiedlichsten Gedanken und Gefühle. Wir erinnern uns noch einmal an die schönen aber auch schwierige Momente die hinter uns liegen.
Und wir schauen mit all unseren persönlichen Hoffnungen und Wünschen gespannt auf das neue Jahr in Hessen haben wir allen Grund zuversichtlich zu sein. Das zeigt nicht zuletzt auch die jährliche Erhebung zum aktuellen Glücksrad.
Danach sind wir Hessen unter allen Bundesbürgern auf dem zweiten Platz. Das ist wunderbar. Und darüber dürfen wir uns freuen.
Hervorragend. Besser hätte Heinz Schenk kaum sagen können Du bist Du bist ja auch so glücklich du sitzt so froh mir gegenüber.
Ich bin ja Hesse. Ich freue mich jetzt über Platz.
Ich als Rheinland-Pfälzer weiß gar nicht auf welchem Ranking ich da auf welchem Platz ich bin. Bei diesem ominösen Ranking aber ja dieser Atlas das ist auch immer so etwas Tolles.
Müssen wir.
Die meisten Menschen wissen ja gar nicht wie unglücklich sie sind. Die können die Frage auch sehr schwierig beantworten.
So etwas kommt dazu. Ich glaube ich habe nicht jetzt nachrecherchiert Ich fand es nicht für notwendig.
Es gibt allerdings eine Zufriedenheit da hängen auch die Soziologen so ein bisschen drin.
Das ist nicht ganz unbedeutend da kommt ja auch nach her. Denn es gibt durchaus Präsidentschaftskandidaten in Amerika die sagen BIP Bruttoinlandsprodukt und so weiter.
Das sollten wir jetzt nach hundert Jahren wo wir es schon damals blöd finden auf den Müllhaufen der Geschichte. Und genau da gehört nämlich ein Packen Atlas.
Die Post macht eine Studie die Shell macht ja die Jugendstudie die Post macht die Studie wie das halt so kommt.
Da gibt's große Pressekonferenzen mit Renommee und Bundesministern.
Und es ist keine unbedeutende Forschung allerdings für eine Neujahrsansprache.
Ist so eine Wahrheit tatsächlich jetzt der Beginn. Wir stehen jetzt nicht da kann kein Vorwort oder so.
So ging das los liebe Hessen freut euch ihr seid auf Platz zwei.
Da fragt man sich wo Hessen auf Platz eins ist.
Wir sind auf Platz zwei des Glücks Atlas. Okay ich weiß nicht mal ob der Glücks Atlas von dieser Glücks Studie die die Potsdamer macht kommt aber gut das war halt seine Nummer zwei habe ich mir ausgesucht Michael Müller Regierender Bürgermeister von Berlin.
Wir wissen heute Wir sind noch einen Tag vor dem letzten Tag im Monat.
Morgen wenn ihr das alle hört ist es der letzte Tag.
Wir wissen heute Michael Müller will nicht mehr Bürgermeister in Berlin bleiben hat sich jetzt zurückgezogen.
Und jetzt hören wir mal wie er dieses Wir wollen eigentlich ein Aufbruch in ein neues Jahrzehnt wagen aber eigentlich bin ich inhaltlich schon abgemeldet.
Die Entscheidung hat er sie für sich irgendwie schon getroffen.
Wie er dass er so reingeht. In seiner Neujahrsansprache.
Wir können mit Zuversicht nach vorn sehen auch weil wir die Zukunft mit neuen Ideen und Mut angehen.
Schon seit Jahren wachsen unsere Wirtschaft und die Beschäftigung überdurchschnittlich stark. Traditionelle Unternehmen wie Siemens Schindler BMW und Bayer investieren Hunderte Millionen in unsere Stadt neue wie Tesla oder Entity kommen dazu.
Er legten wirtschaftlichen Rechenschaftsbericht für 3,5 Millionen Berliner ab. Irgendwie ein bisschen.
Dabei ist mir eins besonders wichtig vom Erfolg Berlins sollen alle profitieren.
Viele Investitionen auch er ist zuversichtlich wie bei ihr.
Ich möchte eine Zukunft die digital und sozial ist.
Digital und sozial was sonst.
Deshalb schaffen wir gute Arbeit zum neuen Jahr erhöhen wir den Mindestlohn auf 12 50 pro Stunde und mit unserem einzigartigen Pilotprojekt solidarisches Grundeinkommen bieten wir Arbeit statt Sorge vor Hartz IV.
Immerhin.
Mit dem kostenlosen Schulessen und Schülerticket entlasten wir die Berliner Familien von dem 365 Euro Azubi Ticket und dem günstigeren Jobticket profitieren viele die täglich zur Arbeit fahren.
Im Modus finde ich gar nicht so schlecht jetzt aber besser verpacken können Er beginnt nämlich mit den großen Unternehmen und damit den kleinen Schicksalen und versucht da so eine Klammer.
Und wir investieren in die Stadt. Milliarden fließen in mehr Personal und alle Bereiche der Infrastruktur zum Beispiel in den öffentlichen Nahverkehr.
Aber ich muss das auch erst dreimal hören um diesen Modus zu finden. Da hat er sich was bei gedacht.
Damit machen wir Berlin zukunftsfest und schützen unser Klima.
Aber er steht halt einfach nur in seinem Büro vor einem Gemälde das finde ich verwirrend auf die eigenen Augen trifft er.
Und man fragt sich so ein bisschen solidarisches Grundeinkommen war da nicht mal so eine Diskussion dass das gar nicht dem hält was es eigentlich mit dem Namen verspricht sondern sie ist doch nur eine andere jetzt eben nicht mehr Ein-Euro-Jobs sondern fünf Euro sogar deren Sicht ganz merkwürdig.
Und er hat da muss man auch wieder so politisch. Gut man kann als Berliner ist man da vorgebildet mittlerweile ja aber den Deckel hat er noch nochmal extra verpackt das fand ich gar nicht so uninteressant.
Zu einem sicheren Leben gehört ein bezahlbares Zuhause. Wohnungen sind keine Ware.
Bauen Kaufen deckeln Das ist unser Programm um Wohnraum zu sichern und zu schaffen.
Und mit dem Mieten Decke gehen wir einen vollkommen neuen Weg damit sie eine fünfjährige Atempause vor Mieterhöhungen erhalten.
Unterstützen Sie uns auch beim unverzichtbaren Neubau. Lassen Sie uns darüber reden wie wir Wohnungen bauen.
Das sind die guten Argumente aus dem Wahlkampf dazu schon Decke ist nur ein Pfeiler Es geht auch um Neubauern und so weiter und so fort.
Dass er das hier nochmal so heraushält ist natürlich verständlich denn mittlerweile Ich habe heute morgen im Tagesspiegel gelesen im Tagesspiegel lese ich war auf der Webseite über Google News im Tagesspiegel gelesen.
Man erwartet jetzt tatsächlich dass bei manchen Wohnungen sich die Mieten halbieren,
und es dann tatsächlich Vermieter im Sinne von nicht die großen institutionellen sondern eben die kleinen dass denen einfach die Hälfte der bisherigen erwartbaren Einzahlung auf ihre Konten fehlen.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es das Niveau von vor fünf Jahren das heißt das was genommen wird war die Rendite auf die man damals auch nicht hätte hoffen können aber die man sich jetzt gerne erhalten hätte.
Diese Mieten deckeln in Berlin völlig zu Recht noch einmal einzeln herausgestellt und eine Sensation.
Ich finde es auch gut. Er macht es. Es ist furchtbar was die Bildsprache anbelangt Es ist einfach furchtbar gebaut.
Dieses Gemälde Ich weiß gar nicht was irgendwie zur Leipziger Schule oder irgendwas was da im Hintergrund zu sehen ist.
Das ist alles furchtbar. Aber er hat sich wahrscheinlich den Vorwurf häufig anhören müssen dass Politiker nicht konkret über Dinge sprechen die sie erreicht haben.
Und genau das ist ja was bei Bouvier der Fall ist wenn das die Leute so glücklich sind in Hessen,
wahrscheinlich eher noch am schönen Wetter als an Volker Bouffier und wir werden ja auch mit Angela Merkel noch gleich eine Ansprache gänzlich ohne Inhalt erleben und dieses Jahr dann doch etwas wo man sehr konkret Man kann das auch ein bisschen amüsant finden in dieser,
Kleinlichkeit dass man dann auch noch mal,
was die Kosten oder Kosten angeht aber immerhin da kann eine Regierung etwas vorweisen hier kann jemand sagen und das ist jetzt besser geworden für die Bürger Berlins und das ist ja auch schon mal was.
Viele entscheiden sich für tatsächlich einfach so ein Rechenschaftsbericht fast volkswirtschaftlicher Art.
Er macht es zu Recht denn er betont hier Sachen der Berliner Mindestlohn den er da nennt.
Wenn eine Firma Aufträge vom Land Berlin annimmt dann gelten da gewisse Konditionen wie z.B. euro Mindestlohn für die Arbeitenden.
Und das gilt dann gleichzeitig für alle Aufträge die dieses Unternehmen jemals auch privat vergibt.
In Sicht ist das eine ganz klare Grenze und die Berliner Stadt ist nun mal ein großer Auftraggeber. Ob man da einfach verzichten will auf ein paar Aufträge nur um dann kein Mindestlohn zu bezahlen werden sich viele überlegen und sich eine Sensation.
Schade dass er geht. Denn er beginnt hier das Finale nochmal so.
Liebe Berlinerinnen und Berliner Wir gehen an ein neues Jahrzehnt mit vielen Chancen.
Lassen Sie uns diese Chancen nutzen um gemeinsam Berlin zur lebenswertesten Stadt Europas zu machen.
Dass wir und das gemeinsam muss man jetzt herausstreichen. Denn er geht.
Er hat jetzt sein Werk getan umsetzen müssen es andere aber gut da ist ja die SPD ganz gut aufgestellt mit ja auch vorher Ortsbürgermeister und in Berlin waren die das jetzt machen soll.
Naja gut. Einer der ganz optimistisch rangeht obwohl die Ausgangslage eine ganz andere ist. Bodo Ramelow.
Liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger. Das kommende Jahr wird spannend wenn es nach mir geht wird das Jahr 2020 ein Fest für die Demokratie.
Die Grundlage dafür haben sie mit der Wahl zum Thüringer Landtag im Oktober gelegt.
Dann fehlt so eine Klammer. Punkt. Punkt. Danke für drei und zwanzig komma sechs Prozent AfD und die Verhinderung jeder konstruktiven Mehrheit.
Das Wahlergebnis stellt die Thüringer Parteien vor die Aufgabe die vertrauten politischen Phase zu verlassen und neue Wege zu gehen.
Ich nehme diese Herausforderung sehr gerne an. Natürlich das politische Miteinander wird komplizierter wenn es keine festen Mehrheiten mehr gibt.
Bislang war es ja immer so. Die Regierung hatte die Mehrheit im Parlament und musste auf die Einwände und Vorschläge der Opposition wenig Rücksicht nehmen.
Erklärt also den Modus finde ich auch ganz gut es ist halt jetzt eine Regierung wie geplant.
Umgekehrt konnte die Opposition zwar Forderungen stellen und Alternativen vorschlagen die Politik wirklich gestalten konnte sie kaum das wird sich jetzt ändern.
Meine Ausführungen zur geistesgeschichtlichen Lage des Parlamentarismus dort und es ist ganz amüsant dass er das jetzt als große Chance verkauft.
Regierung und Opposition werden sich künftig auf Augenhöhe begegnen und in vielen Fragen einigen müssen.
Ist es ja wahrscheinlich auch.
Man muss das auf jeden Fall. Man kann nicht Opposition ist immer dagegen.
Man muss auf jeden Fall aus der alten Format raus dass man immer den Koalitionsvertrag.
Ich finde das nicht sehen aber sie können.
Ich finde das können jetzt unsere Hörer nicht sehen aber sie könnten es sich noch mal nachschauen das Hemd ist eine Katastrophe. Wenn ich das als kleines.
Nur,
sehr langweilig was sich überhaupt als auffällig.
Man kann nicht eine Neujahrsansprache einem irgendwie graugrün merkwürdigen Hemd halten dann muss man ein weißes Hemd anziehen.
Gerade wenn man rote Krawatte trägt. Das ist eine Katastrophe.
Nagold passt zum dunklen Himmel lässt sich da irgendwann 17 Uhr zum Sonnenuntergang vom Dom abfilmen und erzählt dann nochmal die Geschichte wie es so ist bisher Demokratie mäßig unterwegs gewesen zu sein.
Oppositions Anträge werden immer abgelehnt und die Regierung besteht aus mehreren Parteien die eine Koalition eingehen wo ein großes Narrativ der Gemeinsamkeit mitläuft obwohl es unterschiedliche Parteien sind die auch bis zur Wahl unterschiedlich Wahlkampf gemacht haben.
Da ist tatsächlich einiges in Bewegung.
Die AfD hat da längst gar nicht großer werden. Für ihn ist das eine Herausforderung und Sie wissen ja schon um was es hier geht.
Allerdings schwenkt auch er noch nochmal um in diese Rechenschaftsberichte und diesen ein Punkt den er hier herausgreifen würde ich sagen Das ist auch ein bisschen Fehlgriffe.
Wir belegen bei allen wirtschafts und sozialpolitisch wichtigen Kennziffern die Spitzenplätze unter den ostdeutschen Ländern und müssen den Vergleich mit dem Westen wahrlich nicht scheuen.
Die Arbeitslosenquote im Freistaat ist im November erstmals unter die magische fünf Prozent Schallmauer gefallen.
Eine Entwicklung die noch vor wenigen Jahren unmöglich erschien. Das ist vor allem ihr Verdienst. Sie haben dieses Land nach der Wende fit gemacht Bewundernswertes geleistet und dabei manches aushalten müssen.
Arbeitslosigkeit unter fünf Prozent das ist Rentner Republik bei den Abwanderungen Verhältnissen gehen halt so viele Leute in Rente und kommen so wenig nach dass es ein Naturgesetz ist dass man dann unter die magische Schallgrenze von fünf Prozent fällt.
Ob man das sozusagen in die eigene Leistungsbilanz zum Jahresende rein nehmen kann.
Bin ich mir unsicher. Ein bisschen mutig würde ich sagen da es lange schwebte in der medialen Berichterstattung,
und gerade im Osten nach der Wende ist es natürlich irgendwie gerechtfertigt aber es ist auch inhaltlich nicht gedeckt wenn man da mit zu viel Vorwissen schon raus aus so einer Stimmung Neujahrsansprache.
Dietmar Woidke ist unglaublich du beschreibst gleich das Bild da sowohl die Wahl des Hintergrundbilder als auch grundsätzlich diese Composition Es ist unfassbar.
Die Landesregierung investiert in Infrastruktur Zukunftstechnologien und das in allen Regionen unseres Landes.
Es ist unser Ziel. Brandenburgs Ruf als eine innovative und dynamische Wirtschaftsregion weiter zu festigen.
Eine magisch beleuchtete Brücke sehen wir im Hintergrund die einfach aus Stahl ist.
Magisch angedeuteter sehen wir aber was für eine Folge dieser Dostal alles nicht besonders schön ist.
Besonders schön ist die Güterfernverkehr vermutlich drüber rollen.
Die sehr funktional ist wirklich Güterfernverkehr vermutlich drüber rollen.
Und davor steht dann ein Mann im Anzug immerhin mit einer diplomatisch gestreiften Krawatte für die Aufnahmen vor der Kamera und redet mit heiligem Ernst davon.
Davor steht ein Mann im Anzug immerhin mit weißem Hemd auch vielleicht mit einer etwas problematisch gestreiften Krawatte für die Aufnahme vor der Kamera.
Und redet mit heiligem Ernst.
Man könnte aber auch meinen dass er jetzt einfach diese Brücke einweihen will oder was auch immer das mit Neujahrsansprache.
Man könnte aber auch meinen dass er jetzt einfach diese Brücke einweihen will.
Das hat mit der Neujahrsansprache. Vermutlich war die Idee Brückenbau die Brücke von einem ins andere Jahr.
Vermutlich war die Idee Brücken bauen die Brücke von einem ins andere Ja so war ein Lied kann eine Brücke sein Joy Fleming auch.
Das kann natürlich sein was ein Lied kann eine Brücke sein.
Aber ich vermute sie gar nicht. Aber.
Aber ich vermute Nee,
ich,
sieht entsetzlich aus und wir müssen auch überlegen Wir sind jetzt im Jahr 2020.
Wir waren da 2019.
Man kann jetzt inzwischen mit iPhones großartige Filme drehen die im Kino laufen können.
Und wenn man sich das ansieht sieht das so aus wie offener mal 1994 im Radio Technik.
Stimmt.
Es sieht aus wie Studenten Radio. Als die Technik eigentlich noch nicht so weit war es allen zu ermöglichen vor allem die Brücke die sieht aus wie Baujahr 1830.
Die Brücke die sie aus dem Baujahr 1930 ja nicht mal letztes Jahrhundert.
Das ist nicht mal letztes Jahrhundert so sondern es ist wirklich super wenn man jetzt angenommen diese Neujahrsansprache auf nur ein interessiertes Augenpaar.
Nein das ist wirklich surreal wenn man jetzt angenommen diese Neujahrsansprache hat viele auch nur ein interessiertes Augenpaar.
Man müsste bei Google eingeben Neujahrsansprache Brücke als Recherche Ausgangspunkt man null Anhaltspunkte was das für eine Brücke ist.
Neujahrsansprache Brücke als Ausgangspunkt null Anhaltspunkte was das für eine völlig banal dann eben dieses Rechenschaftsberichten artige.
Also völlig Banane und dann eben dieses dieses Rechenschaftsbericht Artikel ist auch Ja.
Es könnte doch ein Hochwasser Bericht sein. So kenne ich das noch aus dem SWR.
Wenn Hochwasser waren dann standen sie auch mal an so Brücken hier ist der Pegel noch einmal gestiegen eine ganze Nacht tolerieren.
Genau,
da würde man auch tolerieren dass man nur kurz mit der GoPro hinfährt da wäre das Setting ist ganz merkwürdig noch schlimmer.
Ist ganz merkwürdig. Noch schlimmer. Reiner Haseloff Ich.
Reiner Haseloff Ich bin fast vom Stuhl gefallen.
Liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger im zurückliegenden Jahr konnten wir mit dem Baros Jubiläum Gäste aus aller Welt in Sachsen-Anhalt begrüßen. Das unterstreicht Sachsen-Anhalt kann sich international sehen lassen.
Stellt sich neben die Kanzel oder das Rednerpult weil er natürlich keine Predigt halten will und will ein bisschen locker davor stehen und steht vollkommen verkrampft daher besser in das Pult gegangen.
Und er ist dort wo er ist.
Er ist wahrscheinlich im Eingang seiner landest Kanzlei oder des Plenarsaals Wohnbaus oder keine Ahnung.
Es
Es ist wirklich merkwürdig. Der Raum mit dem meisten Hall.
Könnte aber irgendwie auch weg mit dem irgendwie auf dem Weg zur Messe oder so. aufgezeichnet sein.
Zur Frage Wo ist das kann man nochmal. Ich habe extra nochmal gegoogelt hier gab es glaube ich eine Recherche Auftrag wenn er beginnt mit Liebe MitbürgerInnen MitbürgerInnen.
Wir haben das Bauhaus ja gehabt schön und gut. Das zeigt Wir können ja Gäste aus aller Welt in Sachsen-Anhalt begrüßen.
Was wir auf jeden Fall wissen Dieser Ort der Aufnahme ist Halle wenn es im Landtag war sind es 23 Minuten zu Fuß bis zur Synagoge,
bei der es einen Anschlag gab und der mutmaßliche Täter 70 Menschen erschießen wollte Anion Kippur,
eröffnet die Neujahrsansprache so mit Wir sind ein weltoffenes Land vor allem wir hier in Halle wo ich gerade stehe und das finde ich. Das geht dann gar nicht.
Da ist einfach zu viel Nachrichtenlage präsent.
Da will man dann einfach auch ein ehrliches Wort haben und nicht so etwas wie das weitergeht das ist wirklich schlimm.
Er erklärt nochmal so ein bisschen und dann hat er so ein Kameraschwenk Blick dann plötzlich eine andere Kamera und diese Rechenschaft Wertigkeit der Berichterstattung ist wirklich erschreckend.
Pünktlich zum Jubiläum des Mauerfalls wurde der ehemalige Todesstreifen zur Lebenslinie des Grünen Bandes,
das Wirtschaftswachstum in Sachsen-Anhalt ist solide. Es lag 2019 sogar über dem Bundesschnitt.
Die neue Kamera ist schon da. Er schwenkt noch eine Sekunde länger.
Er dreht sich langsam. Man kennt es noch aus Aktenzeichen XY wo auch man etwas verspätet in die neue Kamera guckte aber man hat einen Perspektivwechsel gewagt. Aber es hat mit dem Anschluss nicht ganz funktioniert.
Vor allem äußert sich selten als Schauspieler für dich sind sie Kulisse. Ich habe nichts mehr außer Ihnen.
Ich finde die Haltung die innere Haltung mit der er hier vor uns tritt unabhängig der Worte ist so kurz vor.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich mich heute Abend besaufen mich betrinken oder meine Frau Frage ob sie einen schönen Abend mit mir hat. Das ist fatalistisch.
Diese ganze dann auch inhaltlicher das Wirtschaftswachstum in Sachsen-Anhalt ist solide.
Das ist ein Satz der darf überhaupt nicht fallen in der Neujahrsansprache.
Das ist wirklich gruselig. Einer der sich so ein bisschen erlauben darf finde ich ist Markus Söder.
Und er hat sich hier sagen diese ostdeutschen Ministerpräsidenten haben aus ihrem Herzen und im Rahmen ihrer Möglichkeiten gesprochen.
Markus Söder hat eine Marktforschung vorher gemacht sowohl was Ton und auch Inhalt angeht.
Es ist jedenfalls nicht der flapsige Markus Söder den wir sonst immer kennen sondern er weiß Hier gucken mir die siebzig plus Leute irgendwie zu und so redet er auch. Deswegen hat das einen gewissen Humor.
Guten Abend. Wahrscheinlich geht es Ihnen in diesen Tagen wie mir. Wir sind froh dass wir für ein paar Tage zur Ruhe kommen. Zeit haben für uns unsere Familien und für alles was über das Jahr liegen geblieben ist.
Durchschnaufen Luftholen nachdenken das ist wichtig für uns persönlich aber auch für unseren Freistaat.
Es ist auch für den Freistaat nötig durchschnaufen einsetzen. Das sind vor allem.
Im abgelaufenen Jahr so glaube ich haben wir in Bayern vieles auf den Weg gebracht wir bewahren und Schützt unsere Umwelt für die nächste Generation Wir haben das nachhaltigste Artenschutz Programm in Deutschland beschlossen. Dabei zeigen wir auch Wertschätzung für unsere Landwirtschaft.
Verstärkt extra für diese Ansprache das ist sehr schön.
Sonorer. Es ist langsamer und es ist ein so.
Zudem statten wir ein wirksames Klimaschutzabkommen.
Man könnte sich auch vorstellen dass jetzt gleich noch Carolin Reiber ins Bild kommt und man gemeinsam Marianne und Michael ankündigt.
Aber es ist okay man sieht seine Hände nicht das hat seinen Sinn Man hat gesagt unten festhalten.
Man faltet sie unten zeigt es aber nicht denn wir haben jetzt schon viele Kandidaten erlebt die mit den Händen eher Probleme haben und nicht wussten wohin damit.
Man hat sie bei ihm einfach abgeschnitten und es ist solide wie du sagt. Für die Generation 70 plus sie fühlt sich umsorgt.
Was ich auch mutig finde ist für genau dieses Wir treten nochmal ans Bett heran.
Ich finde es schön wenn der Pfleger mit mir auch morgen sprechen.
Vor der Visite gibts nochmal ein persönliches Wort durchschnaufen hinsetzen das ist auf der einen Seite ein ganz deutlicher Imperativ setzt sich Menschen auf was mir den Kopf jetzt die Treppe hoch und ich weiß wovon im dritten Stock anstrengend,
aber überhaupt in der Neujahrsansprache ein Wort Sätze einzubauen die im Teleprompter auch wirklich in einer Zeile stehen die man dann eben auch wirklich durchschnaufen.
Hinsetzen. Das ist auch wichtig für den Freistaat eigentlich völlig Banane inhaltlich aber irgendwie hat was er bei Markus Söder hab ich da eine gewisse Toleranzgrenze.
Sehr gute Sprüche hier zum Beispiel eine.
Ganz besonders wichtig. Wir investieren nicht nur in Steine und Computer sondern vor allem die Menschen besonders im dieFamilie.
Man kann es nicht besser machen. Besonders in die Familie da vergisst man fast dass er vorher sagte Wir investieren nicht nur in Steine also Original Zitat.
Wir investieren nicht nur in Steine. Keine Ahnung was das bedeutet.
Aber wir investieren nur in Steine. Besonders wichtig ist auch die Familie besonders die Familie.
Man kann es gar nicht nachmachen Es ist einfach ziemlich perfekt.
Was mir besonders gut gefallen hat ist auch dieser Spruch Ich Ich. Man kann glaube ich nicht erklären.
Bayern ist keine Postleitzahl sondern ein freies und frei denkendes Land.
Es ist unser aller Aufgabe dazu beizutragen dass es keine Spaltung zwischen Stadt und Land Alt und Jung oder modern und traditionell gibt.
Bayern ist keine Postleitzahl sondern ein freies Denken.
Hier behauptet dass Bayern eine Postleitzahl ist.
Ich weiß eigentlich wie man das sagt. Es ist irgendwie Marktforschung hat ergeben Dieser Satz macht Sinn unabhängig davon was er sonst so sagt.
Marktforschung hat ergeben dieser Satz sind unabhängig.
Aber es ist auch gesagt für die Leute die noch Briefe schreiben also auch eher 50 plus die 90 plus Generation.
Und für die 90 plus Generation ist das Finale.
Die Neuen werden sagen Bayern ist kein E-Mailadresse aber so richtig Bayern ist kein.
Richtig. Bayern ist kein Hendel Replay Händel Händel.
Kennel.
Wie ist der Name von Bayern.
Wie einst der Name von Bayern. Bayern ist keine Postleitzahl.
Bayern ist keine Postleitzahl also wirklich ein sehr merkwürdiger Satz.
Das ist wirklich ein sehr merkwürdiger Satz dieses Finale jetzt ist einfach grandios.
Dieses Finale ist einfach grandios. Ich gebe Ihnen fünf Sterne sind nicht nur ernstgemeinte Sterne aber es ist einfach wirklich schön.
Ich gebe fünf von fünf Sternen. Es sind nicht nur ernstgemeint Sterne aber es ist einfach wirklich schön.
Was bringt nun das neue Jahr. Keiner kann es vorhersagen. So kann die Staatsregierung nicht. Aber wir sind vorbereitet.
Woher die Winde wehen können wir nicht bestimmen. Aber wie wir die Segel setzen das ist unsere Entscheidung in Bayern so lässt sich gut leben lassen. Für sie und ihre Familie.
Daran wollen wir mit großem Einsatz arbeiten. Wir starten zuversichtlich in die 20er Jahre. Ob sie golden werden wird man erst im Rückblick wissen.
Aber wir dürfen schon Anlass zu Optimismus haben. Natürlich ist nicht alles perfekt aber ein Fiasko ist allemal gerechtfertigt.
Als ihr Ministerpräsident wünsche ich Ihnen Gesundheit Glück dass sie ihre Wünsche erfüllen mögen um Gottes Segen auf ein gutes neues Jahr.
Und Gottes Segen auch wichtig in Bayern das Segel setzen.
Wir wissen nicht wohin die Winde wehen. Ich finde das sollten die sich im Norden im nächsten Jahr einfach klauen und dann noch mal sagen weil es eigentlich schön ist.
Es hat ja eben keine Bayern und mehr wird es schwierig. Die haben ja ein paar sehen.
Aber da kann man nicht drauf segeln glaube ich.
Ja gut ja da kann man drauf segeln aber.
Es ist toll in Hamburg das zu sagen Da passt es ja in Schleswig-Holstein immer.
Da passt es auch weil da ist Segeln einfach. In Schleswig-Holstein und da war Segeln immer das,
richtige arbeiten die Fischer die Grundlast der Wirtschaft in Bayern ist Segeln das was die Elite macht am Wochenende da fährt man zu sehen und segelt ein bisschen rum und will auch gesehen werden.
Die Fischer die Grundlast der Wirtschaft in Bayern ist.
Das was die Elite macht. Am Wochenende zu sehen und segelt ein bisschen rum und will auch gesehen werden.
Aber damit kann man eigentlich nicht eine Masse ansprechen. Es gibt keine Segel DNA in Bayern.
Aber damit kann man eigentlich nicht eine Masse ansprechen. Es gibt keine Segel den Bayern.
Völlig merkwürdig irgendwie das so zu machen hätte irgendwas mit Lokomotive oder ein anderes aber wohin die Winde wehen das klingt fast wie in Zarah Leander Lied das ist auch schön wieder für die älteren.
Völlig merkwürdig irgendwie das so zu machen hätte irgendwas mit Lokomotive oder so gewählt.
So ein anderes ist dieses nautische Ding.
Genau. Es ist sozusagen dockt er an an eine Kultur DNA als an eine tatsächlich gelebte DNA.
Gerade so ist es dort eher an eine Kultur als an eine tatsächlich gelebte so oder so.
Ich versorge meine Familie oder so. Und das finde ich ein bisschen überraschend dass das so macht wie er es dann macht fand ich allerdings großartig. Da muss man einfach.
Das ist nicht überraschend allerdings großartig. Man muss ja auch den Kontext sehen.
Wahrscheinlich kommt danach der Hormes. Und dann geht das gleich so weiter in diesem Ton.
Wahrscheinlich,
ist gute Arbeit Markus. Würde ich sagen Für einen der als noch besonders jung gilt hat er das besonders gut gemacht die alten noch einmal abzuholen.
Einer der ein echter Politiker Arbeiter ist weil er im letzten Jahr einen harten harten harten Wahlkampf für viele gelobt haben gemacht haben ist Michael Kretschmer. Und dieses Setting.
Was er sich hier ausgewählt hat hast du uns gleich beschrieben.
Wir achten während wir das hören mal auf die Inhalte. Was ist hier am wichtigsten als Botschaft und für Sachsen.
Wir feiern in diesem Jahr das Jahr der Industriekultur mit einer großen Landesausstellung in Zwickau und unzähligen weiteren Veranstaltungen.
Damit wollen wir ein Zeichen setzen für die Stärke und die Bedeutung unserer Industrie für die Entwicklung des Landes. Und dabei wird der Bergbau eine wichtige Rolle spielen.
Der Bergbau 2020.
Der Bergbau und man sieht Menschen in historischen Kostümen die Kostüme sind aus dem 19. Jahrhundert würde ich mal sagen oder noch früher.
Was sieht man denn.
Ist auch wieder mehr als ein Jahrhundert.
Zum Teil ist es noch zu lesen scheint mir in einer Kirche oder es ist eine Kapelle die.
Ich würde sagen das ist so eine Kapelle. Aber auf der Hütte eine sehr funktionale.
Mit einer Orgel im Hintergrund. Und man hat hier die bringt die Geschichte trinkt er in seiner Ansprache mit rein indem er dort diese historischen Figuren.
Ich habe erst gedacht es handelt sich um Schaufensterpuppen aber es sind echte Menschen die sich minimal bewegen.
Sie wussten selber nicht wohin. Und stehen deswegen als absolut vermarktbare Kulisse hinten drin was einen gewissen Humor mitbringt.
Allerdings hat Kretschmar hier die Marktforschung richtig gemacht im Sinne von hätte Markus Söder wäre in Schleswig-Holstein Ministerpräsident wurde dort über Segeln und so weiter sprechen würde es passen.
Bayern hat es nicht gepasst dass er hier in Sachsen steht und mit dem Bergbau redet auch diese sakrale fast liturgische.
Ich halte jetzt eine Predigt in so einer wie sagt wahrscheinlich sehr funktionalen Kapelle.
Im Nebenraum hat man sich schon umgezogen und ist dann unter uns unter Tage gefallen.
Passt in der Hinsicht ganz gut allerdings 2020 wenn man einen Aufbruch markieren will dann kann man nicht nochmal auf den Bergbau zurückschauen und ihn retten wollen irgendwie als Themenwahl finde ich sehr skurril.
Gerade für den Fall dass man eben nicht der 80 jährige Sachse ist der immer noch darunter leidet dass,
das eigene Bundesland ein ums andere Mal industrialisiert wurde und man dass manches da von Osten von Deutschland nur der Legende nach ist aber nicht tatsächlich,
in Sicht wenn man einfach so wie ich ein 40-Jähriger Vahl Hesse ist der das guckt dann ist das einfach skurril und passt allerdings in die ganze Drucksituation die jetzt aufgebaut wird.
Wir wollen jetzt dass Kohle Geld auch wirklich haben da ja aber noch viel in Bewegung.
Es soll auch nochmal signalisieren Wir sind immer noch die alten.
Wir haben uns nicht verändert. Wir schauen zwar in die Zukunft aber das ist unsere Tradition aus der wir kommen die steht im Hintergrund ist immer noch präsent und prägt uns.
Und deswegen können wir auch auf die Kohle gar nicht verzichten.
Das ist Teil unserer Identität Identität mäßig formuliert und so schließt.
Identitäts mäßig sehr scharf formuliert auch in der Bildsprache. Und so schließt er dann auch diese Neujahrsansprache.
Wir alle sind Sachsen und wir alle entscheiden gemeinsam wie es mit unserem Heimatland weitergeht.
Auch in den kommenden Jahren werden wir Staatsregierung zu ihnen in ihre Stadt und Landkreise kommen und gemeinsam über die Zukunft sprechen. Nutzen Sie diese Möglichkeit mit uns ins Gespräch zu kommen. Es ist immer besser miteinander als übereinander zu sprechen.
Für das neue Jahr wünsche ich mir dass wir geschlossen und mit Mut auf das zugehen was uns das Leben als überraschung bereithält. Bleiben wir stark.
Hier sind wir nun wieder mal eng beieinander.
Wir sind wir. Wir kümmern uns um uns und das Mittel der Wahl ist das echte Gespräch und nicht das Gespräch übereinander,
als Tratsch unter Abwesenheit derjenigen über die wir eigentlich Adriaan der Ansicht schließt an seinen eigenen Arbeitsmodell sagt Diese Rundreise durch Sachsen dazu machen nicht nur des Wahlkampfs wegen sondern auch grundsätzlich die Sachsen Gespräche dazu führen.
Da bliebe eigentlich der Ansicht schließt an seinen eigenen Arbeitsmodell sagt Diese Rundreise durch Sachsen dazu machen nicht nur des Wahlkampfs mit den Bürgern vor Ort auf Augenhöhe,
Sachsens Gespräche und die Hände dabei kneten während er das sagt ja.
Ja.
Wie bei jeder Stadt ja auch schon.
Hasselhoff hat es auch so gemacht. Armin Laschet ist natürlich nicht zu unterschätzen das muss man auf jeden Fall hören wenn man es schon hört.
Armin Laschet ist natürlich nicht zu unterschätzen.
Denn Armin Laschet ist Ministerpräsident eines Bundeslandes man wüsste gar nicht welches Thema irgendwie weshalb er sich sehr prominent in der ganzen Bundesrepublik.
Armin Laschet ist Ministerpräsident eines Bundeslandes man wüsste gar nicht welches Thema,
weshalb er sich.
Während wir hier manche sehen die nicht so sehr präsent sind.
Sonst aber Laschet ist sehr präsent in den Medien große Interviews in großen Zeitungen hat im Tatort zum Tatort mitgespielt ja Kurzauftritt in diesem Tatort ja als Ministerpräsident.
Als Ministerpräsident oder was.
Es gibt da einen Kriminalfall innerhalb der Polizei und er kommt dann sehr betroffen rein und sagt was jetzt zu tun ist.
Kriminalfall innerhalb der Polizei kommt dann sehr betroffen rein und sagt was.
Also ein kleiner Star immer noch auch wird er gesagt.
Ein kleiner Star immer noch sagt.
Vielleicht könnte er noch Kandidat werden.
Vielleicht könnte er noch irgendwer wird auf Merkel folgen und er ist mit dem Spiel auf der anderen Seite.
Kretschmer kleines Bundesland vier Millionen Einwohner also ein Viertel von NRW.
Trotzdem irgendwie die gleiche Präsenz. 2019 wird sich jetzt sehr abschwächen es 2019.
Armin Laschet ist halt einfach. Also NRW. Das kann man ja auch dieser deutsche Föderalismus wird wenn man ihn wirklich leben und NRW im EU Kontext sehen würden nicht alles überragen.
Selbst österreich so ist da unter ferner liefen.
Und es gibt mehrere Bundesländer die größer sind als österreich Bayern.
Auch Armin Laschet hat sich jedenfalls ein Thema ausgesucht das irgendwie in der Luft lag und das für alle gilt und dass wer bei Kretschmann auch schon gehört haben und dass uns tatsächlich noch lange beschäftigen wird.
Die sozialen Medien bieten die Chance umfassender Informationen,
aber leider auch immer mehr die Gefahr der Zuspitzung des Rückzugs in Filterblase in eine Welt derer die genauso leben und denken wie man selbst.
Deshalb ist das gute alte persönliche Gespräch so wichtig zwischen Alt und Jung zwischen denen die in der Großstadt und denen die im ländlichen Raum leben.
Ein gutes langes Plädoyer hat tatsächlich nur dieses eine Thema.
Echte Gespräche. Und dann geht einfach nur die Unterschiede durch. Jung und Alt Arm und Reich Stadt und Land.
Zwischen denen die zugewandert und geflohen sind und denen deren Familien schon immer hier leben.
Das ist eine merkwürdige Fantasie dass man glaubt dass Kommunikation über ein Medium.
Ein Gespräch mit einem anderen.
Früher war es ganz stark das Telefonieren schlechter ist als das unmittelbare Gespräch wo jemand Auge in Auge gegenübersitzt.
Ich liebe zum Beispiel das Mündliche Gespräch Ich liebe das Telefonat.
Ich würde auch sagen dass ich sehr gute Kommunikation im Internet mit Leuten für die ich noch nie getroffen habe aber auch schon festgestellt dass man die Leute trifft das gar nicht so interessant ist.
Das ist eine eigenartige Vorstellung und,
diese Vorstellung die aber sehr typisch für Hollywood-Filme ist dass man glaubt wenn Menschen in der direkten Begegnung zusammenkommen dann entdecken sie,
jeweils den Menschen im anderen und dann werden alle Brücken alle Gräben werden überwunden und Brücken werden gebaut.
Das glaube ich oft nicht.
Für die Eins zu Eins Kommunikation stimmt das wahrscheinlich.
Es gibt in der Soziologie immer noch eine große Diskussion Was ist eine Interaktion,
muss sie diesen nonverbalen Mehrwert liefern der beim Telefon völlig raus ist weil du hörst tatsächlich nur du siehst hat keine,
Armbewegung die dir irgendwie signalisieren wie auch etwas gemeint sein könnte sondern es muss im Grunde expliziert werden. Nachfragen und so weiter.
Bei Online-Kommunikation schaltet sich ja der Computer noch nochmal als wirklich eigener Akteur dazwischen.
Da reicht es manchmal auch alle fünf Jahre jemanden zu treffen um danach völlig online zu lassen.
Für das was er hier aber auch meint nämlich Kommunikation unter vielen einfach Regeln ein bisschen anders.
Also wenn du jetzt fünf Leute hast die unter einem Facebook-Post kommunizieren dann würde man nicht sagen Sie reden miteinander oder so. Sondern jeder bringt da etwas bei.
Wenn die Leute aber sich im Kreis gegenüberstehen in einer großen Halle dann wäre das anders.
Da gelten einfach andere Regeln Da der Maßgabe finde ich es gar nicht so schlecht darauf hinzuweisen dass dieses große Gespräch dieses politische.
Alle sollen dabei sein um so mehr Inklusion umso besser und am Ende hat jeder eine Stimme.
Dieses wichtige Prinzip da gelten tatsächlich andere Regeln und.
Findet das denn statt findet es statt dass fünf Menschen sich miteinander unterhalten man hat ja bei Occupy Wall Street damals versucht mit,
bestimmten Regelungen dafür zu sorgen dass jeder zu Wort kommt dass es nicht irgendwelche Leute in der ersten Reihe gibt die nur sprechen und die anderen nicken nur ab und das funktioniert aber nicht.
Das dauert unendlich lange und so kann man auch nicht in einer,
Masse diskutieren man kann mit drei Leuten vier fünf oder so noch sprechen aber alles darüber hinaus ist schwierig Das bemerkt jeder deren Geburtstag mit 30 Leuten feiert und am Ende feststellt dass er gar nicht mit allen sprechen konnte.
Das ist mir bei aller Kritik die ich ja auch immer wieder formuliere,
in den neuen Medien und all das muss ich eher sagen dass das Internet doch eine große Möglichkeit bietet Positionen zu hören die ich sonst in meiner Welt überhaupt nicht höre.
Also meine Welt ist eine sehr abgekapselt eigentlich viel abgekapselt hat als wenn ich jetzt bei Twitter bin oder die Tatsache dass der Podcast halb so groß ist und meine Prognosen noch extrem wachsen wird.
Wir sind ja eigentlich erst am Anfang wenn man schaut wie viele Menschen noch nicht Podcast hören.
Dann muss man sagen Wir erleben gerade eine Blütezeit des Zuhörens dass man Menschen Stunde um Stunde zuhört die ich auf meinen Ohren habe die ich jetzt nicht sehen kann.
Aber ich höre permanent Positionen zu denen ich mich als Hörer wieder positioniere auch wenn ich dann nicht gleich mitreden kann sind wir doch eigentlich in einem Zeitalter des Zuhörens.
Genau da sitzt die Frage wie betrachtet man es.
Und was er feststellt ist es wird ganz viel online kommuniziert vor allem über Politik das betrifft einen tagtäglich weshalb sich das auch in der neuesten Sprache niederschlägt.
Und er kann gar nicht anders als in diesem Appell in diesem moralischen Appell dazu auffordern doch auch mal Regeln gelten zu lassen wie man sie aus dem direkten Gespräch kennt.
Und wir müssen Ihnen jetzt sagen Es war ja deine Frage.
Diese Kommunikation gibt's gar nicht unter Anwesenden. Die gibt's tatsächlich nur online während wir in der Eins zu Eins Kommunikation beides haben.
Das Telefonat das Chat Text Gespräch die Sprachnachrichten die zeitverzögert immer auftreten oder die echte Begegnung haben wir die ersten drei Formen auch für diese Massenkommunikation aber das echte Gespräch eben nicht.
Und wenn die jetzt in Berlin da ihre 90 000 Anwesenden in einen politischen Diskurs führt dann werden wir auch feststellen,
Auch wenn 90 000 da sind darf immer nur einer Klade reden weil wenn alle miteinander reden dann müssen sie sich nicht dort treffen.
Olympia-Stadion.
Genau dieses große freilässt vor Futurologen nicht freilässt verfrühter sondern die haben sich wieder distanziert aber,
wir machen mal Petitionen im Olympiastadion die Anwesenheit von 90 000 ist total egal wenn da kein Fußballspiel stattfindet das man einseitig sieht sondern beidseitig kommunizieren möchte.
Und er formuliert hier genau dieses Desiderat Er hat diesen Wunsch können wir nicht diese Eins zu Eins Kommunikation auch in Massenkommunikation machen.
Jetzt wo wir diese Massenkommunikation Online haben wir können hier leider nur sagen Nein es wird dieses Pindar Kommunikation unter Anwesenden für diese Massenkommunikation niemals geben.
Also wird keine Facebook Kommunikation unter Anwesenden gehen. Es wird ein Facebook Chat und die Anwesenden geben.
WhatsApp-Gruppe können sich wirklich treffen sind ja meistens Vereine Klassen oder sonstiges. Da gibt's ein Elternabend hat man die Leute kennen und da weiß man wie man mit den Texten umzugehen hat.
Für die politische Kommunikation ausgeschlossen wird es nicht geben.
Immer wieder überlegung nach 68 auch von Habermas geprägt.
Von Habermas geprägt. Diese ganzen Lasset uns auch die Idee eines herrschaftsfreien Diskurs.
Diese ganzen Ideen auch die Idee eines herrschaftsfreien Diskurses wo sich auch immer sehr schnell herausstellt dass es denen nicht gibt es sich sofort wieder andere Hierarchien etablieren auch wenn man jetzt alle.
Sofort wieder andere Hierarchien etablieren auch wenn man jetzt alle mal auf den Boden setzt und.
Mal auf den Boden setzt und niemanden auf einen Thron setzt niemanden erhebt.
Dann stellt sich das wieder anders sein dann ist gerade der der rhetorisch besonders gewandt ist der der Wortführer wird.
Dann stellt sich das wieder anders gerade der der rhetorisch besonders gewandt ist der Wortführer.
Man könnte fast sagen natürliche Prozesse die.
Der absolut der natürlichste Prozess ist einfach der der Ermüdung.
Das hat Habermas in seinen Güte Kriterien nie aufgenommen. Dass es erstens.
Habermas hier aufgenommen,
Es fällt einfach auch Ermüdung weil jemand wahrhaftig kommunizieren heißt es nicht dass mich das drei Stunden lang interessiert sondern irgendwann kommt Ermüdung und das Einzige was Ermüdung noch ein bisschen hinauszögern kann ist Humor Unterhaltungswert.
Fällt einfach auch Ermüdung rein ja nur weil jemand wahrhaftig kommunizieren heißt es nicht dass mich das drei Stunden lang interessiert im direkten Gespräch sondern irgendwann kommt Ermüdung und das Einzige was Ermüdung noch ein bisschen hinauszögern kann ist Humor also Unterhaltungswert.
Aber auch das findet in dieser theoretischen Auseinandersetzung wie man denn kommunizieren sollte ganz normativ formuliert nie statt.
Aber auch das findet in dieser theoretischen Auseinandersetzung wie man kommunizieren sollte normativ formulieren nie statt.
Wenn man eines nicht behaupten kann das Habermas humorvoller Autor des Humors Pointen frei gelassen und erst recht nicht im Imperativ.
Humor findet in den Texten nicht statt. Und erst recht nicht im Imperativ der da formuliert wird.
Malu Dreyer deine Ministerpräsidentin deine Landesmutter nimmt sich genau das gleiche Thema.
Malu Dreyer Ministerpräsidentin der Landesmutter ja dann nimmt sich genau das gleiche Thema.
Liberale und Felser und Rheinland-Pfälzer. Hinter mir Sehen Sie einen der ältesten Marktplätze unseres Landes auf Märkten wie in Trier wurde früher um Waren und Preise gerungen. Man versammelte sich und tauschte Neuigkeiten aus.
Der Marktplatz war auch der Platz an dem Konflikte ausgetragen.
Sehr schön. Es gibt ja einen Konflikt einen Streit zwischen Mainz und Trier,
und da heißt es Mainz will die älteste Stadt Deutschlands sein und Trier sagt Wir sind aber die älteste Stadt und Trier hat irgendwann einfach verkündet Wir sind die älteste Stadt und haben das auch groß gefeiert.
Und jetzt sagt sie sehr diplomatisch einen der ältesten Marktplätze.
Sie sagt nicht Wir haben den ältestenrat platzieren Trier.
Worms ist die älteste Stadt in Deutschland.
Das sind die Kleinigkeiten mit dem man sich in diesen Ländern herumschlägt. Sie betont den Marktplatz.
Aber,
Marktplatz Idee Agora dort wo jetzt der öffentliche Raum ist.
Hannah Arendt geschult wahrscheinlich Malu Dreyer oder dass sie diese Art des öffentlichen Raums als Idee hat wo politische Positionen zusammenkommen könnte ich mir vorstellen dass sie so sozialisiert ist aber das kennt man nur aus der Geschichte.
Kann sein aber das kennt man nur aus der Geschichte. Denn dieser Marktplatz ist.
Durch kommerzialisiert bis zum geht nicht mehr.
Der ist jetzt hier leergeräumt wahrscheinlich hat man die Menschen die dort sind raus retuschiert oder hat wirklich nachts abgewartet dass man so ein Bild aufnehmen kann.
Aber das ist genau die Hölle die man in ganz vielen sehr schönen Städten erleben kann denn die Innenstadt von Trier ist wirklich herrlich.
Ich habe da ja auch studiert in Trier und das ist aber so eine Stadt die zugleich vollkommen gesichtslos geworden ist dadurch dass es nach dem anderen dort ist und dort Touristengruppen,
hin und her mit großen Tüten und irgendwas gekauft haben was man meistens nicht braucht.
Das würde ich sagen. Historisch kann man immer so einen Marktplatz als das ist der Ort und so weiter.
Historisch kann man immer so ein Marktplatz.
Aber wenn die Leute Netflix zu Hause haben und zum Studieren dort leben und eigentlich nur zur Uni wollen dann ist man nie auf dem Marktplatz außer zum Weihnachtsmarkt.
Studieren dann ist man nie auf dem Marktplatz außer beim Weihnachtsmarkt.
Und beim Weihnachtsmarkt stellt man fest Hier wird gerade nicht irgendeine politische Diskussion geführt die wäre hier auch nicht möglich sondern da stehen alle rum und man hofft dass man noch so ein bisschen durchkommt.
Nein.
Das ist ein Ort wo garantiert keine politische Diskussion stattfindet dann auf diesem Marktplatz.
Malu Dreyer. Gute Idee allerdings verflüchtigt sich sofort ein bisschen Reflexion noch eingeschaltet.
Gute Idee also hier ist der Bürger nur noch Konsument.
So schalten wir doch mal in die Schweiz das fand ich nämlich wirklich interessant.
Wir haben hier eine sehr Format Starre. Man stelle sich vor irgendein Bild das Bild irgendwas aussagekräftig ist das Bundesland liefern und dann gibt man so ein Rechenschaftsbericht.
Entweder man sagt Das Wirtschaftswachstum ist solide. Oder man appelliert irgendwie an den Geist an die kulturelle DNA und erzählt irgendwas von Segel setzen und so eine kleinstmöglichen Nenner und noch mal so einen Punkt zu machen.
In der Schweiz läuft es ein bisschen anders. Simonetta Sumo Ragusa heißt sie die bundesrats die Bundesrat Rättin. Keine Ahnung ob das.
Ich weiß nicht mal ob der Bundesrat dort das Gremium ist dem sie vorsteht oder ob sie einfach Der Bundesrat ist. Aber sie ist Bundesrat.
Sie ist Bundesrat und wir hören jetzt mal Ihr könnt ja selber überlegen wann ab wann höre ich eigentlich wo sie ist.
Aber sie ist nicht im Fernsehstudio sondern sie ist woanders und es wird dann relativ zügig aufgeklärt.
Sie ist ein Bäcker. Sie ist beim Bäcker und sie bezahlt noch schnell sie ist nach der Arbeit.
Wetteramt.
Die Macht die neueste Ansprache nach der Arbeit bezahlt schnell ihr Brot und wendet sich jetzt zur Kamera.
An Neujahr wünschen wir einander auch ich wünsche Ihnen ein gutes neues Jahr. Aber was ist das eigentlich ein gutes Jahr.
Wahnsinn. Sie steht in der Bäckerei. Man hat ihr aber neben der Theke einen Stuhl hingestellt damit sie dort ihre Handtasche mit den Einkäufen abstellen kann und dann dreht sie sich in die Kamera und begrüßt die Eidgenossen.
Und in dem Moment wo sie sich umdreht wo die Kamera umschwenkt ist plötzlich die Verkäuferin nicht mehr an ihrem Platz ist ist ganz Pucci irgendwie in der Schweiz. Aber sie hat eine Frage gestellt.
Wir wünschen uns ein gutes Jahr wie immer. Was ist das eigentlich.
Was ist das eigentlich wenn das Wirtschaftswachstum solide ist oder wenn die Winde richtig wehen.
Oder wenn wir uns einigen. Es ist nicht nur eine Postleitzahl wo wir leben sondern der Freistaat atmet kann.
Und sie beantwortet jetzt mal die Frage und gibt mehrere Antworten.
Eine davon markiert uns mal sie redet hier nicht nur mit 100-Jährigen wie die Deutschen.
Und im Kontrast zu diesen Deutschen was wir eben gehört haben ist es wirklich bemerkenswert.
Wenn uns und unseren liebsten nichts Schlimmes passiert wenn wir gesund sind und glücklich,
haben dann noch ein paar Wünsche darüber hinaus Erfolg im Beruf gute Noten in der Schule und das das Lieblingsprojekt der Bäckerei kurz vor Feierabend noch da ist.
Gute Noten in der Schule sie redet hier auch zu den Kindern.
Und dass das Brot noch da ist ist sehr calvinistisch dass noch gearbeitet wird auch am Abend dass dann noch frisches Brot da ist dass niemand darben muss sie ist beim Bäcker klar.
Na gut sie ist ja beim Bäcker. Sie schlägt also diese Brücken.
Sie schaffte das übrigens alles auch in weniger als drei Minuten ist es doppelt so schnell oder mehr als doppelt so schnell wie die ganzen Deutschen Ansprachen denen sich kurz und knapp allerdings schon mit einem größeren Fokus. Es geht plötzlich auch um die Kinder sie redet auch mit den Kindern.
Und dieses Finale ist immer noch eine Ansprache die Kameras ist immer noch eine Kulisse.
Okay es ist nicht das Fernsehstudio Es ist nicht auf der Arbeit sondern sie ist quasi schon im Feierabend so wie viele andere auch geht sie dann zum Bäcker jetzt öffnet sie aber tatsächlich noch mal den Fokus inhaltlich und macht so ein globales Argument. Das fand ich sehr gelungen.
Meine Bäckerei weiß wie es geht. Ich komme regelmäßig hierher.
Ich kaufe Brot und die feinen hausgemachten Amaretto.
Aber ich bekomme jedes Mal noch viel mehr nur dass es hier so gut riecht.
Die Brote und Kuchen sind liebevoll ausgestellt. Alle Kundinnen und Kunden werden freundlich begrüßt viele mit ihrem Namen.
Manchmal gibt es einen Schwatz meine Bäckerei lebt jeden Tag vor wie man das Leben auch für die anderen gut machen kann.
Man schaut einander in die Augen.
Brot ist ein Grundnahrungsmittel. Viele Menschen haben nicht einmal das.
Ich bin froh dass sich bei uns alle Brot leisten können.
Und ich möchte dass der Preis auch für diejenigen gut ist die das Getreide aussäen und ernten.
Ein Preis wird auch zur Erde und zum Leben auf unserem Planeten Sorge trägt.
Wir möchten ja dass auch unsere Kinder sich noch gutes Neues wünschen können.
Und auch die Kinder auf anderen Kontinenten eigentlich wissen wir dass alle damit es uns wirklich gut gehen kann muss es auch den anderen gut gehen.
Ich wünsche Ihnen von Herzen.
Nein globale Perspektive nimmt sie ein.
Ein klarer Appell globale Perspektiven. Stefan.
Nein wir müssen jetzt auch.
Jetzt auch wenn wir unser Brot essen. Daran denken auch die anderen.
Daran denken ob die anderen.
Ich finde es auch gut. Sicherlich eine Verschleierungen von denen wir heute Brot hergestellt wird.
Die Konzerne dafür sorgen dass eben nicht gesät und geerntet wird.
Konzerne dafür sorgen dass.
Gut dass es jetzt.
Sie ansprechen will kann aber durchaus.
Nimmt sich das Thema Brot im Sinne von ein die Jahrhunderte und Jahrtausende überdauern das Thema werden auch in 3000 Jahren noch Brot essen und dann stellt sie sich dahin macht diesen Appell.
Sehr gut finde ich diesen Rechenschaftsbericht. Die Schweiz hat ihr Volksvermögen entsprechend vermehrt und das Wachstum ist solide sondern sie kommt mit diesem Appell.
Ich will dass es auch anderen auf der Welt gut geht Sie meinen die ganze Welt und schließt das mit dem erstaunlichen Satz Eigentlich wissen wir dass alle,
und das ist nicht nur ein Appell sondern das soll auch noch einmal das schlechte Gewissen ein bisschen einbringen ist ein sehr guter Abschluss Satz für ein Statement und wenn man zum Thema Brot Man kann am Brot tatsächlich so ein mega globales Argument aufhängen.
Constanze Kurz und Frank Rieger haben ja das Buch Arbeitsfrei geschrieben und es handelt ja nur davon wie das Brot auf den Teller kommt.
Wie diese Automatisierung hin von der Standard von dem Standard Samen den man da in den Boden bringt bis hin zu wie man das Mutterkonzern mit so einer Lichtschranke da irgendwie und dann 10000 Tonnen Mehl am Tag und so weiter.
Also wie man sowas auf die Spitze treibt und verschleiert wie sehr die Welt sich wandelt obwohl es immer noch einfach das Brot ist das am Ende des Tages noch in der Bäckerei liegt in deren Sicht ist dieses Brot Thema gar nicht so schlecht,
Man kommt sofort ins Nachdenken und zu so Text verwaisen und so weiter und also ist wirklich gut gemacht.
Und ich möchte etwas sagen sie steht selbstverständlich da Blicks in die Kamera was soll sie auch machen Wo sollen sie hin blicken das ist ja wenn man Monolog hält.
Ich kenne sie ja aus der Film Analyse ist es eben so. Man blickt in eine Kamera und kann sich nicht so tun als würde man sich mit jemanden anders unterhalten.
Aber hier ist sie ganz in ihrer Rolle die eine glaubwürdige Rolle ist während man bei vielen jetzt den Eindruck hatte die mussten heute vor die Kamera und haben es nicht mehr geschafft rechtzeitig zu fliehen.
Bei ihr ist es auch so dass sie das mit einer gewissen Steifheit macht aber nicht dass sie sich unwohl fühlt sondern sie repräsentiert nun immerhin hier die Schweiz.
Und deswegen spricht sie auch in diesem Tone und ich finde das sehr angemessen während Michael Gretschmann niemals in dieser Bergbauer Kapelle steht.
Während Michael Kretschmer niemals in dieser Bergbau Kapelle steht vor so einer Menschen Kulisse und nicht mal Michael Müller so künstlich vor seinem Schreibtisch steht statt dahinter zu sitzen.
Und nicht mal so künstlich vor seinem Schreibtisch sitzen kann man sie wahrscheinlich auch nach der Aufnahme die Anwendung gar nicht schlecht.
Kann man so ein bisschen abkaufen dass sie wahrscheinlich auch am Tag nach der Aufnahme wie er bei diesem Bäcker steht Brot kauft,
die Anbindung an einen gewissen Alltag und Realität ist gar nicht schlecht.
Sie ist hervorragend gekleidet wenn ich das noch sagen darf mit dem Mantel hat sie einen roten roten Schal.
Ein bisschen zurückhaltend auch schwarz. Aber auch.
Zurückhaltend ja aber auch so kann man auch zur Messe gehen Weihnachtsmänner dann der Lippenstift ist genau abgestimmt auf den Schal sehr gut.
Der Lippenstift ist,
da kommen wir gleich darauf zurück wenn wir uns die C.s angucken wie man sowas hinbekommt. Die Technik ist nämlich schon da.
Vander Bellen als Präsident in österreich. Und wenn wir uns jetzt mal so richtig wenn ich euch sage konzentriert euch mal darauf wie er das jetzt macht dann hört man in österreich ist die Apokalypse gerade noch abgewendet.
So muss man es glaube ich sagen sehr feierliche Rahmen in Wien findet man die Gebäude.
Da muss nur Van der Bellen in seinen Hausflur gehen um sich noch einmal vor gülden in dem weiten Teppich belegten und gut ausgeleuchteten Hintergrund abzulichten aber inhaltlich ist das wirklich ein bisschen in den Anfang.
Denn gerade wenn man nicht weiß wie es morgen weitergehen wird ist die Gefahr groß zu reagieren oder aufzugeben und die Dinge einfach geschehen zu lassen.
Aber die Kunst ist nun einmal dort wo manche nur die dunkle Nacht sehen auf die Sterne zu konzentrieren und zu wissen Die sind der Vorbote des nächsten Tages.
Wir sind ja nicht allein. Wir haben einen hellen Fixstern der uns Orientierung und Anleitung gibt.
Das ist unsere Bundesverfassung und wir haben einander wenn wir den Blick für das Positive schärfen.
Ich dachte beim hellen Fixstern jetzt sagt Sebastian Kurz. Ja ja ja aber so geht das.
Dann fällt uns auf dass wir als Land nicht alleine und isoliert auf der Welt sind sondern Teil unserer gemeinsamen Europäischen Union.
Grüner wäre vielleicht. Aber so geht das.
Drei vier Minuten lang wir haben gerade noch die Sterne.
Wahnsinn. Wir haben.
Ja das ist so wenn man sich 100 000 vor Christus als Film oder Soldaten die die Sterne sind zurückgeworfen auf das elementarste er als Bundespräsident bedient.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle erinnern heute am 1..
Ja
geworfen auf das elementarste ja er als Bundespräsident bedient das auch noch mal so.
Ich weiß es ist eine dunkle dunkle Nacht aber die Sterne zeigen uns das Universum ist noch da.
Ich weiß es ist eine dunkle Nacht. Aber die Sterne zeigen uns das Universum ist noch da. Irgendwo ist eine Sonne und sie wird auch irgendwann aufgehen. Ja es ist wirklich da.
Irgendwo ist eine Sonne und sie wird auch irgendwann aufgehen.
Es ist wirklich bedrückend eigentlich.
Das kann man auch sagen Nachdem Pest und Cholera jahrelang gewütet haben und jetzt erhält man so eine Rede. Sorry aber da hilft auch ein bisschen Werner Schmäh nicht mehr.
Zombie Apocalypse.
Das ist ja sowieso ein bisschen so ein bisschen.
Der Wiener Schmäh.
Küss die Hand Ja es ist.
Ja es ist ja eine Atombombe gefallen wäre das Szenario das Leben nur noch hundert Leute hätte man genau diese.
Kann man die Rede auf jeden Fall noch mal rausholen.
Passage ja Angela Merkel fand sie langweilig.
Ich fand es schlimm weil es ist Ideologie verseucht bis zum letzten Wort hat man noch versucht alles irgendwie einzupacken.
Gut den Einstieg kann man noch irgendwie hinnehmen als danach wird es wirklich gruselig.
Liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger. Heute Abend stehen wir nicht nur am Beginn eines neuen Jahres sondern auch eines neuen Jahrzehnts.
Ich bin überzeugt Wir haben gute Gründe zuversichtlich zu sein dass die in wenigen Stunden beginnenden 20er Jahre des 21. Jahrhunderts gute Jahre werden können.
Das ist Olin Rentner Republik. Es würde mich nicht wundern wenn man sich darüber vorher verständigt hat dass man die Ansprache so wählt wohl wissend dass ungefähr 80 Prozent der Zuhörer das Ende dieser 20er Jahre nicht erleben werden.
Meine ich jetzt auch ganz ernst das ist eine ganz steife Ansprache die wir jetzt ein bisschen entfalten die ist wirklich schlimm.
Sie redet ja wirklich nur mit 100-Jährigen und sie beginnt mit diesem digitalen Fortschritt sie muss sich irgendein Thema wählen.
Klimawandel kommt natürlich auch dieses Thema einst. Digitaler Fortschritt und dann ihre als Chef Politikerinnen.
Ihre Haltung dazu wie man dem begegnet ist wirklich gruselig.
Zugleich erleben wir täglich wie sehr der digitale Fortschritt unser Leben in allen Bereichen verändert natürlich auch unser Arbeitsleben.
Darauf müssen wir neue Antworten finden denn wir wollen dass alle Menschen Zugang zu der Bildung haben die sie für diesen Wandel brauchen.
Das Thema Bildung heißt Du bist schuld. Du musst dich selber kümmern. Bildung ist deine Aufgabe Bildung ist absolut ausgereizt in Deutschland.
Also wir haben ein grassierende Rassismus was ausländische Vornamen angeht bei der Bestückung von Schulen.
Wir haben einen Lehrplan der wirklich alle Familien in die Verzweiflung treibt wie kriege ich mein Kind durchs Gymnasium.
Da bleiben sehr viele psychische Verletzungen zurück und lebenslanges Lernen als die große Aufgabe die sich auch die Gewerkschaften nehmen um noch einmal jeden einzutrichtern.
Du bist unverständlich das reicht nicht was du machst. über die Arbeit hinaus weiter weiter weiter so in diesem Oliver Kahns Stile dass sie hier nochmal,
als Politikerin die eigentlich für alle anderen Aufgaben zuständig ist Rahmenbedingung und so weiter ja nochmal auf Bildung zu sprechen kommt als erstes und einziges um digitalen Fortschritt zu umrahmen ist.
Wirklich schlimm finde ich völlig daneben würde ich sie gerne tadeln. Das finde ich nicht gut.
Erwärmung. Erderwärmung. Wie sie das hier beschreibt ist einfach eine Frechheit finde ich wenn man überlegt dass sie seit 31 Jahren und wie sie Kanzlerin ist.
Die Erwärmung unserer Erde ist real. Sie ist bedrohlich sie und die aus der Erderwärmung Erwachsenen Krisen sind von Menschen verursacht.
Also müssen wir auch alles Menschenmögliche unternehmen um diese Menschheit Herausforderungen zu bewältigen. Noch ist das möglich.
Menschen um den menschengemachten Klimawandel,
leugnen zu verpassen dass es sie geht und danach sagt sie dann tatsächlich dass sie das Menschenmögliche tun Wir sollten wir sollten.
Sie sagt ja nur wir sollten was getan haben sie genau das nicht das Menschenmögliche.
Vor allem Es gibt den schönen Spruch Du kannst das Zitat Vielleicht zuordnen wer Menschheit sagt lügt der redet sich raus sagt redet sich raus der meint eigentlich sich.
Es gibt den Spruch Wer Menschheit sagt Ja das sagt Carl Schmitt der redet sich raus,
redet sich aus der man sich sagt sondern die anderen dass sie vorher beim Thema Fortschritt der digitale Fortschritt meint. Macht ihr das Thema Bildung.
Aber sagt man die anderen dass sie vorher beim Thema Fortschritt Digitaler Fortschritt meint.
Macht ihr das Thema Bildung Du bist da.
Dann kommt sie mit menschengemachten Klimawandel und wir sollten mal die einzige die wirklich sein sollte ist sie selber. Und sie kommt ja die Menschheit.
Dann kommt sie mit menschengemachten Klimawandel und wir sollten mal die einzige die wirklich mal sollte ist sie selber und sie kommt ihr so mit.
Die Menschheit sollte mehr. Das finde ich.
Das finde ich. Sie ist in dem Sinne die politische Vertretung der deutschen Menschheit.
Sie ist in dem Sinne die politische Vertretung der deutschen Menschheit. Und ich finde sie sollte mal.
Und ich finde sie sollte man weder diesen Zuschnitt bin ich wirklich.
Aber sie hat diesen Zuschnitt finde ich wirklich Graß und jetzt.
Und jetzt kann könnte sie machen wenn sie jetzt eine unbedeutende Pfarrerin wäre,
und sie würde dort jetzt in der Predigt sagen wir sollten dann hat die Pfarrerin keine macht irgendetwas zu tun aber einen Appell von der Kanzel. Immerhin kann sie an alle richten.
Genau.
Aber sie hat hier offenbar nicht verstanden welche Rolle sie gerade dort sitzt.
82 Millionen Deutsche dürften das so sagen wie sie und sie ansprechen. Sie ist die einzige die das nicht umdrehen darf.
Aber es passiert genau so.. Also ich finde es unmöglich. Und jetzt erklärt sie so ein bisschen mit wem für wen und wie sie das alles so wie ihr Sprechakt zu verstehen ist.
Ich bin mit meinen 65 Jahren in einem Alter in dem ich persönlich nicht mehr alle Folgen des Klimawandels erleben werde die sich einstellen würden wenn die Politik nicht handelte.
Es sind ja unsere Kinder und Enkel die mit den Folgen dessen leben müssen was wir heute tun oder unterlassen. Deshalb setze ich all meine Kraft dafür ein dass Deutschland seinen Beitrag leistet.
Letzter Satz war eine Lüge. Wie sie sagt es sind unsere Kinder und Enkel Wieso redet sie nicht mit den Kindern und Enkeln.
Warum redet sie mit ihrer Peergroup.
Warum redet sie. Adressat ist die Rentnerin Publikum das mal ganz deutlich zu sagen Es ist wirklich erschreckend.
Rentenreform. Es ist wirklich erschreckend da die Schweizerin war völlig normal.
Die Schweizerin noch völlig normal. Ein gutes Jahr. Auch wenn du gute Noten in der Schule hast ist es für sie völlig fremd sie würde sich erschrecken glaube ich wenn sie plötzlich ein Kind vor sich sehe mit dem sie spricht.
Ein gutes Jahr auch wenn du gute Noten in der Schule hast ist es für sie völlig fremd.
Sie würde sich erschrecken wenn sie plötzlich ein Kind vor sich sähe mit dem sie spricht.
Auch nach einem Jahr frei ist es für sie völlig Outer Space mit jemand anderem zu sprechen als einen noch älteren Menschen als sie selber.
Auch nach einem Jahr ist das für sie völlig Outer Space mit jemand anderem zu sprechen als noch ältere Menschen als sie selber.
Es ist wirklich schlimm.
Klingt dann natürlich hier. Ihr Standard dafür ist die Kanzlerin.
STANDARD Dafür ist die Kanzlerin.
Dabei tragen uns die Werte des Grundgesetzes von Freiheit Solidarität und der Achtung der Würde jedes einzelnen Menschen sowie die Prinzipien der Sozialen Marktwirtschaft.
Sie bleiben unser Kompass auch im nächsten Jahrzehnt.
Prinzipien der Sozialen Marktwirtschaft sehr schön das haben wir in dem Interview mit Ulrike Herrmann noch einmal deutlich gesehen.
Man kann es auch an anderen Stellen nachlesen was die soziale Marktwirtschaft,
ein gutes Propagandamittel war aber so etwas überhaupt nicht gibt. Man will nicht Kapitalismus will man nie sagen.
Das.
Deswegen sagt man soziale Marktwirtschaft und diese selbst wenn man noch an das alte Modell in irgendeiner Weise glauben konnte gilt ja nun seit den letzten 20 Jahren auch nicht mehr noch ein bisschen.
Alte Modell.
Sozialen Kitt ergeben hat ist einfach nicht mehr präsent. Man fragt sich Was ist denn damit gemeint.
Also ich würde ein bisschen einschränken bis 985 86 war die Lohnentwicklung des Einzelnen gekoppelt an die Produktivität da würd ich sagen Okay das kann man die soziale Marktwirtschaft nennen das ist aber jetzt seit 30 Jahren nicht mehr so.
Die Lohnentwicklung ist genau die Produktivität.
Seit 30 Jahren nicht mehr Atemzug mit den Prinzipien der Verfassung mit dem Grundgesetz.
Und dass sie das immer noch nennt in einem Atemzug mit den Prinzipien der Verfassung mit dem Grundgesetz und so weiter. Das ist einfach.
Das ist gar nicht so dumm dass sie das macht. Da ist sie sehr strategisch.
Die Neoliberalen hatten immer die Idee gehabt ob man nicht in der Verfassung den Kapitalismus verankern kann in einer ganz neuen Weise dass man,
beispielsweise in der Verfassung festlegt dass nicht mehr als 50 Prozent Steuern erhoben werden dürfen,
auf ein Vermögen.
Es gab immer wieder diese Idee von Milton Friedman zum Beispiel zu sagen wenn der Kapitalismus die Verfassung selbst ist,
dann sind wir raus. Dann kann uns niemand mehr zugreifen.
Bei ihr scheint das zumindest gedanklich eine Einheit zu ergeben.
Ein Jahrzehnt das heißt auch im digitalen Zeitalter hat die Technik dem Menschen zu dienen und nicht umgekehrt. Die Würde des Menschen setzt die Grenzen denn sie ist unantastbar.
Das ist der Kern unserer freiheitlichen Demokratie die jeden Tag mit Leben zu füllen ist.
Also wenn sie meint die Technik hat den Menschen zu dienen. Da kommen wir noch auf die CSM was da so vorgestellt wird zu sprechen.
Wenn das ein Versprechen ist ist das schon gebrochen und wird auch nie wieder eingehalten.
Dass sie das hier so formuliert finde ich das zeigt nur in dem Moment wo sie kann das so sagen In dem Moment wo man beginnt darüber nachzudenken sieht man das ist völlig entrückt ist ja sehr vielen Ebenen ist diese Neujahrsansprache völlig entrückt,
im Vergleich zu dieser Schweizerin die sagt einfach Okay wir machen jetzt mal Focus Brot und dann bleib ich bei einem Appell rein moralischer Natur und sagt dann eigentlich wissen wir das alle.
Aber dieser wie soll man sagen Dieser durchgestylte Imperativ der hier drin steckt bei ihr das ist wirklich erschreckend.
Also habe es ja mit einer ganz schlimmen Eiskönigin irgendwie zu tun.
Was solche Sachen angeht da bettet sie jetzt Deutschland nochmal ein und hier muss man auch sagen sie kommt jetzt auf Europa zu sprechen das ist eine große Lüge.
Wenn man sich anguckt wie Deutschland die letzten Jahre mit Frankreich umgegangen ist und wie in Europa alles blockiert wurde von einer Finanztransaktionssteuer zu VW Strafen und so weiter und so fort.
So kann man einfach nicht Neujahrsansprache mal.
Liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger in den vergangenen Jahren habe ich oft gesagt dass auch Deutschland auf Dauer nur dann gut geht wenn es auch Europa gut geht.
Denn nur in der Gemeinschaft der Europäischen Union können wir unsere Werte und Interessen behaupten und Frieden Freiheit und Wohlstand sichern.
Stimmt aber dann sollte man auch so handeln. Also genau das gleiche Politikversagen wie beim Klima.
Man sollte vielleicht griechische übersetzungen anbieten und dass man dort was sie dazu sagen.
Genau Europa wurde von keinem Land so verraten die letzten zehn Jahre wie Deutschland.
Europa wurde von keinem Land so beraten die letzten zehn Jahre wie Deutschland.
Das ist bezogen auf angestrebte Zinspolitik Inflations Regularien und die gesamte Austeritätspolitik die da eingelenkt wurde.
Das ist bezogen auf angestrebte Zinspolitik Inflations Regularien also Lohnentwicklung und sowas.
Genau die Austerität die da eingedenk der Umgang mit Staatsschulden und so weiter.
Der Umgang mit Staatsschulden und so weiter ist also wirklich alles verlogen so wie sie es hier sagen.
Es ist also wirklich alles verlogen so wie sie es hier sagt sie erwähnt dann nochmal kurz dass man jetzt einen Gipfel mit Afrika und China planen finde ich interessant weil sie Amerika völlig ausspart hier historisch nicht ganz unbedeutend.
Sie erwähnt dann nochmal kurz dass man jetzt einen Gipfel mit Afrika und China plant finde ich interessant weil sie Amerika völlig ausspart historisch nicht ganz unbedeutend.
Das Finale ist dann entsprechend.
Liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger ein neues Jahrzehnt liegt vor uns die 20er Jahre können gute Jahre werden.
Überraschen wir uns einmal mehr damit. Was wir können Veränderungen zum Guten sind möglich wenn wir uns offen und entschlossen auf Neues einlassen.
Da sollst du wieder machen. Sie sagt eigentlich nur denn jetzt macht mal.
Wieder da soll ich wieder sagt eigentlich nur jetzt macht mal..
Ich bin auch 65 und werde mich auch bald zurückziehen und dann soll jeder mal sehen wie er klarkommt Bildung drauf schaffen sich nicht allzu sehr von der Technik vereinnahmen lassen.
Ich bin auch 65 und dann soll jeder mal sehen wie er klarkommt.
Wir sind Bildung Frauen schaffen sich nicht allzu sehr von der Technik vereinnahmen lassen.
Ja man kommt zu unserem Modus bewusst negativ zu lesen was ich sagt weil man so sehr dann auch und wenn sie am Ende nochmal sagt Und jetzt lassen wir uns mal darauf ein. Ist ja auch so ein bisschen.
Das ist nicht negativ zu lesen.
Lassen wir uns mal darauf ein. Naja ich war mir ausgeliefert.
Ihr wart bisher mir ausgeliefert mit der Politik die ich mache.
In Sachen Klima Europa und so weiter und lasst euch nochmal mal weiter darauf ein fast schon Anspruch den sie hier formuliert.
Aber das steht ja auch in einer Tradition wenn man an die berühmte Ruck-Rede denkt.
Es muss ein Ruck durch Deutschland gehen. Von Weizsäcker.
Weizsäcker Ja dann ist es ja so dass dort eigentlich dieser neoliberale Impetus sich breit macht.
Dieser Ruck durch Deutschland ist eigentlich nur eine Disruption die durch Deutschland gehen soll und jetzt soll jeder mal selbst sehen dass er sich nicht so sehr auf den Staat verlässt dass er das neue erkennt und macht und dann brauchen wir etwas Unternehmergeist.
Da wird ja sogar Bezug genommen auf die Silicon Valley Industrie die in der Garage bastelt und dann erfolgreich wird und diese Ruck-Rede war ja extrem prägend für alle reden die danach kamen.
Grundsätzlich bezieht man sich gerne darauf jetzt ist sie natürlich nicht von dem Format das sie auch so eine Ruck-Rede halten wird aber so ein,
Schwundstufe dessen ist dann doch noch dort anzutreffen dass sie jetzt Aufbruch in etwas Neues und da müssen wir offen sein was,
am Ende einen enormen Druck auf die Leute ausübt die sich das jetzt anhören.
Denn wenn es jetzt für Sie in diesem oder nächsten Jahr schlecht laufen sollte dann können sie sich immer fragen War ich nicht offen genug für das neue Jahr.
Eine der Ansicht hier Outer Space die Reise so.
Allerdings war es nicht weit. Weizsäcker hat die Rede zum Herzog von Weizsäckers große Rede war ja die zum Tag der Befreiung.
Allerdings war es nicht Herzog. Herzog Ja.
Jetzt wird in Deutschland überlegt das ja auch gehört wahrscheinlich dass man den 8. Mai zum Feiertag macht mal gucken was wir im Mai darüber sagen können.
Es ist ja einiges in Bewegung so Damit haben wir einen Grundstein gelegt für.
Man könnte depressiv sein sagen weil man diese Politiker regieren uns.
Wir können aber sagen Nee es regiert hier ganz anders sind natürlich die großen Technique Konzerne aber auch in Europa gibt es Institutionen die wirklich einen Aufbruch wagen.
Und es sind nicht diese Politiker.
Christine Lagarde war französische Finanzministerin ist dem IWF vorstellig geworden und gleich vorstellig geworden und hat dann dort beispielsweise immer contra Schäuble gesagt Wir müssen mit Griechenland zum Beispiel anders umgehen.
Wir fanden Austerität auch lange gut bis wir gesehen haben.
Es geht ja nicht nur um Frankreich und Deutschland.
Wir haben hier eine andere Perspektive beim IWF. Und dann hat sie da sehr opponiert und Schäuble auch ein bisschen vorgeführt.
Denn Schäuble hat diese Autorität aus Austeritätspolitik immer daran geknüpft dass der IWF mit im Boot ist.
Lagarde gesagt Ich bin ja nicht mit im Boot weshalb es zur großen Verschleppung kam und so Christine Lagarde ist jetzt seit neustem EZB-Chef in und damit Christine Christine Lagarde.
Schäuble sagt Christian.
Also ist jetzt EZB-Chef hier in Frankfurt. Er hat damit die Aufgabe von Draghi übernommen sich um eine Sache zu kümmern Preisstabilität.
Wir werden gleich hören dass sie gar nicht genau weiß was das ist und selber ihr Haus mal drauf trimmt.
Wir müssen jetzt mal gucken was ist das überhaupt so und sie nimmt sich eine zweite Aufgabe mit dazu nämlich das Klima.
Das steht in den Verträgen an die sie sich halten muss wohl der EZB als Organ eine Aufgabe zugeteilt wurde nicht drin. Kümmert sich ums Klima und so weiter es geht nur um Preisstabilität.
Kann man aus der Preisstabilität vielleicht Klima Argumente ableiten. Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Christine Lagarde ist in diesem Posten sich um Europa und die Welt zu kümmern und das über das Geld irgendwie zu regeln.
Sie kauft jeden Monat für 20 Milliarden Euro weiterhin Anleihen auf privater und staatlicher Natur also Staatsanleihen und Unternehmensanleihen wobei die Unternehmensanleihen nochmal ein eigenes Programm und.
Es geht um sehr viel Geld und sie gibt jetzt einmal im Monat wie das halt so ist in diesem Post eine Pressekonferenz.
Und anders als die Neujahrsansprache haben wir einen richtigen Kontrapunkt diese Pressekonferenz die wir jetzt ausnahmsweise gucken ist nicht für die öffentlichkeit gedacht sondern da sitzen einfach nur 50 Journalisten die auf manchmal mühsam Englisch dann irgendwie noch Fragen stellen.
Markus Goerne zum Beispiel hab ich da gesehen.
Der macht die Börsen Berichterstattung in der ARD.
Da schlägt sich so etwas nie nie nie wieder nie nieder sondern da geht es allein um der Dax stieg weil Trump was gemacht hat und so weiter. Also von dem was wir jetzt hören.
Hat die öffentlichkeit bisher nichts gehört und wird auch weiterhin nichts hören. Trotzdem gibt's diese Pressekonferenzen zu gucken einfach bei Youtube z.B. öffentlich sind sie nicht.
Aber es ist wirklich erstaunlich mit welchen neuen Strategien Christine Lagarde jetzt reingeht Wir hören mal wie sie hier auf Fragen antwortet.
Zum Thema der EZB kriegt man irgendwie ein klimapolitische Programm in diesem EZB Auftrag rein der ebenso eng gefasst ist wirklich nur Preisstabilität und eigentlich ist es keine politische Institution.
Und sie beginnt hier mal eine Frage zu,
beantworten und sie macht das in mehreren Stufen und sie beginnt bei einer ganz kleinen die für uns aber super nachvollziehbar ist.
On Climate Change.
Everybody Responsibility Hirschi To See What You Feit Climate Change biodiversity.
Ein Components What We Do.
Testing of the Rest Things are happening who we know.
Ein Branchenfonds am Lücking hat mit PayPal die Place,
de Previews Benchmarks für die iPhones bei Low Carbon in Cleveland ãndert shame on the top of the Selective Exklusion ein Proxy Voting Guidelines in place,
to what we,
did not ableitbar very very Trophy in Berlin Reviews,
Very Large,
Protected.
EZB gibt sich über Christine Lagarde jetzt selber den Auftrag Grün zu werden.
Kann man beispielsweise bei dem Anleihekäufen unterscheiden zwischen.
Die machen irgendwie die Natur kaputt und die nicht so sehr deswegen investieren wir kaufen lieber von denen die Anleihen auf um so die Märkte entsprechend liquide zu halten.
Also trocknen wir gewisse Märkte vielleicht ein bisschen bewusst aus.
Klar man der Kritik da politisch zu handeln und sie nennt jetzt als allererste Stufe die eigenen Pensionsfonds des Hauses also die Mitarbeiter dort haben Pensionsfonds wie sie so sagt er ist nur eine Milliarde.
Muss man sich mal überlegen so ein Pensionsfonds für so einen ist ja auch nicht ein besonders riesiges Ding die EZB.
Aber gut diese eine Milliarde werden jetzt radikal begrünt und die gucken dann selber intern erstmal was bedeutet das eigentlich für die Stimmrechte die wir da haben wir sind ja auch irgendwo investiert.
Kriegen wir alle die gleiche risikoarme hin oder müssen wir uns plötzlich mit dunkel Flauten und sowas auseinandersetzen wenn wir nicht mehr in Kohle sondern in Windkraft Energie und so weiter da unser Geld stecken und daraus lernen die jetzt auch für das größere Programm.
Deswegen hat sie am Ende diesen schönen Satz gemacht aus kleinen Flüssen werden ja auch große Ozeane münden die einen großen Ozean.
Ich lese ja immer noch sehr regelmäßig das Handelsblatt.
Dort gibt es fast jeden zweiten Tag inzwischen ein Interview mit irgendeinem Fondsmanager der wesentlich größere Fonds betreut als sie,
alle machen sich jetzt Sorgen darüber wie sie jetzt auf der grünen Welle mitschwimmen können wie,
sie betreuen aufgefasst wird und es gibt aber auch einen enormen Druck auf diese Fondsmanager,
sehr viele die dort investiert haben sagen ja ich möchte aber ab sofort nicht mehr in Energien oder in Unternehmen investieren die besonders schädlich sind.
Ich sehe da eine globale Verantwortung und die managen jetzt auch ihre Fonds neu Nicht alle machen das bei Blackrock werden wir auch sehen dass das sehr wenig stattfindet während,
die Pensionsfonds haben jetzt schon einen enormen Druck ausüben können.
Wir sehen hier plötzlich auch Fondsmanager viel entscheidender sind für wirtschaftliche Veränderungen als wenn ein Ministerpräsident irgendeinem Unternehmen sagt Du Du Du Du sollst,
nicht unsere Umwelt zerstören oder so viele Leute entlassen.
Es sind am Ende die Fondsmanager die eine extreme Macht haben und,
sagen Die sind bestimmt nicht demokratisch gewählt worden und dann ist eben auch diese große Diskussion welchen Ansatz jetzt auch Manager wiederum von Unternehmen verfolgen wollen.
Er sei jedenfalls nicht demokratisch.
Wollen Sie weiterhin in diesen Fonds vorkommen dann müssen sie sich vielleicht von dieser Idee kurzfristige Gewinne verabschieden müssen eine langfristige Perspektive bieten die sich dann mit grünen Energien machen lässt. Zugleich ist das,
auch sehr heikel. Im Raum steht was alles möglich ist und wie grüne Technologien möglich sind und wir wissen,
es wird wahrscheinlich sein wie bei der Dotcom-Blase oder eine große Marktbereinigung geben wird wo ganz viel eingehen wird.
Und dann bedeutet das auch dass die die investiert haben in solche Fonds mit herben Verlusten zu rechnen haben wenn es nicht extrem gut diversifiziertes diversifiziert ist.
Schwieriger wird auch ordentliche Renditen zu bekommen. Das ist eine große Herausforderung aber ich glaube auch dass das momentan sehr stark,
zu beobachten ist wenn man den Finanztitel einer Zeitung aufschlägt.
Das Handelsblatt ist noch die beste Quelle denn die sitzen zum Beispiel hier und sind das einzige Medium das ein Live-Blog zum Lagardes macht.
Da kann man ein bisschen live nachlesen und die Stichpunkte rausholen.
Genau wie du beschrieben hast. Sehr viele machen sich jetzt Gedanken schon allein weil man jetzt weiß.
Wenn ich jetzt in grüne in erneuerbare Energien gehe und das gegen Kohle ausspielte hab ich eine gewisse Unsicherheit drin denn,
bei der Kohle ist einfach klar die Kohle Felder sind so groß und da kann man noch so viel rausholen und die Reserven Rechnung sind alle da und da weiß man genau da kommt es nur noch darauf an dass man das ordentlich manage.
Der Dienstplan stimmt um die Kohle abzubauen und zu verbrennen.
Nur weiß man auch in 50 Jahren wird nicht mehr aus der Erde Kohle geholt. Also diese Unsicherheit ist drin oder.
Da ist eine Sicherheit drin in 50 Jahren endet dieser Finanzierungsmittel.
Den kann man natürlich vorbeugen also diesen Verlust an Geld auch in 50 Jahren dem man jetzt schon in einen etwas volatilen Markt einsteigt.
Und er wird natürlich nochmal dadurch auch unberechenbarer das man nicht genau weiß wie die Politik handelt.
Wer wird denn jetzt eigentlich im November in Amerika Präsident. Einer der alle fossilen Brennstoffe Erzeuger einfach verklagen will.
Bernie Sanders oder einer der sagt Clean Coal ist doch nichts dagegen.
Man weiß es einfach wirklich nicht aber der politische Rahmen.
Spätestens in vier Iran ist Trump weg. Und dann kommt ein neuer Populist und es könnte jemand wie Bernie Sanders sein der einfach ganz klar mit dieser Mehrheitsmeinung reingeht.
Wir machen hier keine weitere Zerstörung und Fracking gehört von heute auf morgen.
Da ist eine gewisse Unsicherheit drinnen obwohl es bisher so sichere Anlagen geht und deswegen ist auch dieser Black Rock Brey von Larry King dem wir nachher noch sehr detailliert lesen werden.
Super interessant aber auch der Pensionsfonds den wir hier im Haus haben ist die übungs Masse.
Gleichzeitig lernen alle Départements in der EZB aus diesen Erkenntnissen.
Work oder dies on going in Verkehrsdepartement SADC schildert mit RISC Schley embedded in.
Terms of Modo sind Terms Of The Forecast ein Work in Progress.
Natürlich finde ich.
Und jetzt ordnen Sie das mal ein weil wir wie eben schon gesagt sie hat ja eigentlich ein klares Mandat den Verträgen steht drinne.
Ihre Aufgabe ist Inflation zu sorgen und zwar knapp unter 2 prozent dieses Ziel muss irgendwie erreicht werden.
Jetzt arbeiten alle Departements aber plötzlich auch am Thema Klima wie es jetzt eigentlich einzuordnen.
Sie kam neu ins Amt hatte Draghi nach sieben Jahren beerbt und macht jetzt erst einmal einst Strategy Review.
Also Sie geht nochmal den ganzen Methoden Catalog neu durch um diese Ziel.
Programmierung die die EZB hat neu auszurichten.
Und da ist das Klima ganz prominent platziert.
Sie wollen meint Sustainability.
Strategie.
An zweiter Stelle schon an erster Stelle aber niemals kommt das Klima ja aber zumindest sekundär.
Sie hat schon bei den Vorstellungen Sie musste sich ja auch im Europaparlament zeigen dass sie sich bei den Grünen in der Fraktion vorgestellt da ging es auch nur um Green Bonds.
Wie wird sie da irgendwie dafür sorgen und da hat sie schon den Schulterschluss mit Ursula von der Leyen und so weiter.
Green Deal und so steht es einfach eine Billion Euro im Raum die jetzt irgendwer verdienen will und der Fokus ist jetzt klar auf dieses mit Kohle Investitionen kriegt man es dann nicht mehr sondern so.
Man merkt in der Art wie sie spricht etwas sehr Fundamentales für unser kapitalistisches System das sich gerade erneuert durch das ganze Thema Klima.
Das ist nicht eine antikapitalistische Bewegung sondern man schaut jetzt ob der Kapitalismus eine Erneuerung schafft.
Denn man sieht hier an dieser gelöst hat mit der sie das alles vorträgt bei allem Ernst den sie dabei auch an den Tag legt.
Aber mit dieser Gelöstheit dass sie optimistisch ist dass endlich wieder Europa und auch der Kapitalismus mit europäischem Antlitz eine neue Herausforderung hat wie er jetzt damit umzugehen hat.
Denn wenn wir uns mal daran erinnern an die vergangenen Jahre als das Klima Thema noch nicht so präsent war gab es eigentlich nur solche Aussagen wie Wir brauchen Preisstabilität.
Davon rückt sie immer noch nicht ab. Das ist auch problematisch aber lassen wir es mal dahingestellt.
Aber es gab immer Krise es gab Preisstabilität. Es gab leichte Wachstumsprognosen.
Plötzlich aber tut sich ein ganz neues Feld auf über das man nachdenken kann das man bewirtschaften kann wo man versucht jetzt Vorreiter zu sein und dadurch,
eine neue Schubkraft weshalb er auch gerne bereit sind den Protest zu umarmen.
Genau der. Die Zäsur die historische Zäsur des Problems das du bereits beschreibst ist tatsächlich 2008 das ist schon zwölf Jahre her dass wir eine Zinsanlagen haben bei der sich alle fragen Wie soll das eigentlich funktionieren.
Null oder Negativzinsen Wie geht es eigentlich.
In Schweden versucht man jetzt so langsam den Negativzins Phase zu beenden und wieder zumindest null Prozent zu machen. Und Lagarde wurde darauf angesprochen.
Ja ich habe. Ich sehe das schon dass die das versuchen. Ich hoffe es hat damit zu tun dass sie jetzt wieder richtige Wirtschaft haben und sich das leisten können.
Wohl wissend fügt sie so in Klammern an die normale Wirtschaft in der das geht mit Zinsen da reinzugehen Leitzinsen die es eigentlich nicht mehr dar und es ist schon seit zehn Jahren so.
Und es gibt jetzt schon die ersten großen Studien da habe ich dann in der Rentner Republik auch da wird es groß machen deswegen habe ich jetzt nicht so präsent aber die ökonomen gucken sich gerade die letzten 800 Jahre an,
und sehen wie er die Zinsen sind 2000 im Jahr 2000 bei null.
Das kann man erst wenn man die Entwicklung zwischen dem 12. Jahrhundert wo die ganzen Städte gegründet werden und man noch reingeht mit.
Ich leide an Taler und gibt mir dafür drei zurück. Das war damals das waren so die Verhältnisse oder in Zügen gerechnet Keine Ahnung aber diese Verzinsung dass die bei null ankommt jetzt in diesem historischen Moment ist einfach so gegeben.
Da ist auch diese Lehman Brothers pleite oder so. Die ist einfach historisch sozusagen eigentlich eingepreist die war erwartbar.
Wie sie dann geschah ist da aber wir kommen nicht wieder zurück zu diesem eigentlichen wirtschaften würden das auch gleich von George Soros vor 100 Jahren im Fernsehen auf dieser Hochphase ist.
Die EZB eben auch die Sucht seit zehn Jahren ein Programm und das hat ja dann Ursula von der Leyen die mir gleich auch sagte ganz offen Das ist unser neuer Wirtschaftsmotor mal der alte nicht mehr funktioniert.
Nun hat sie sogar ein Programm. Ja man muss es ganz anders sehen als wie wir das übersehen haben nicht reagiert sondern das Klima ist endlich das worauf sie gewartet haben nämlich anders zu sagen.
Wir suchen eigentlich nur ein Programm und mit Klima haben wir jetzt eins.
Man muss es ganz anders rum sehen als wie wir das immer sehen Ach endlich haben sie verstanden das Klima sondern das Klima ist endlich das worauf sie gewartet haben nämlich der Anlass zu sagen Jetzt müssen wir es neu machen neue.
Die Identitätskrise Europas die ja auch eine kulturelle Krise ist die die Frage nach Gemeinsamkeit und all das aufbringt die man auch nicht beantworten konnte da die Nationen sehr unterschiedlich sind.
Hat man jetzt mit diesem Thema Klima etwas womit man auch sehr viel Identitätsstiftung wiederherstellen kann.
Für die ist es ein großes Geschenk.
Es wird immer noch so dargestellt wie du sagst es wird immer noch so dargestellt als hätten die am liebsten keine Proteste.
Nein im Prinzip sind die jetzt dankbar.
Schön dass ihr das gemacht. Dafür braucht man sonst sehr viel Berater von der Leyen viele Milliarden für Beraterverträge ausgeben müssen um darauf zu kommen.
Genau das ist super interessant genau so wie du sagst die EZB.
Dass es genauso wie die EZB.
Blackrock die Europäische Kommission brauchen die Klemann Proteste auf der Straße als Kulisse damit eine neue Politik möglich ist die wieder so etwas wie Wirtschaftswachstum ermöglicht.
Die Europäische Kommission Klima Proteste auf der Straße als Kulisse damit eine neue Politik möglich ist die wieder so etwas wie Wirtschaftswachstum ermöglicht.
Die Frage ist jetzt Welche Kennziffern liegen wir anders wird. Ganz grundsätzlich und.
Jetzt kennt sie ganz grundsätzlich.
Wird nicht instrumentalisiert. Nein.
Wird nicht instrumentalisiert. Aber Kreta ist in einem historischen Moment da wo sie sie trifft auf eine Welt in Resonanz. Das muss so muss man sagen.
Sie trifft,
genau und darf man nicht vergessen Der Kapitalismus ist das bislang intelligenteste System überhaupt überhaupt.
Das,
eigentlich was überhaupt Fortschritt ermöglicht vorher war es Stagnation Baugesellschaften.
Und und und dass der Kapitalismus reagiert nicht nur auf solche Dinge sondern er,
torpediert sie noch. Er lebt davon er lebt auch von so etwas wie einer schöpferischen Zerstörung wie Schumpeter das nennt.
Und er lebt eben auch davon dass man ihnen permanent kritisiert weil er nur dann sich optimieren kann und wie sie das jetzt auch in so einem Trial and Error Verfahren schildert wie man diesen Fonds managen könnte und das ist ein langer Weg und das ist work in progress,
das ist die Funktionsweise des Kapitalismus die sie zugleich beschreibt.
Der Kapitalismus ist zuweilen Error und damit das einzige Modell das wir kennen das Fortschritt ermöglicht alles andere war vorher so Zufall und so ein bisschen na da hat sich etwas durchgesetzt.
Die Menschen sind im 15. Jahrhundert genauso morgens aufgestanden wie im 17. Jahrhundert da gab es keine große Unterscheidung und selbst im achten Jahrhundert sind die Unterschiede jetzt nicht so mega dass man irgendwie sagt okay.
Es gab dann so Städte und Urbanisierung. Aber man muss ja wirklich sagen diese Umstellung auf Geld das zwölfte Jahrhundert das man auf dem Marktplatz geht und nicht mehr Eins zu Eins Tausch in Wohlstand für alle das thematisiert.
Geld ist ein symbolisch generalisierte Kommunikationsmedium das Zukunft. zur Verfügung stellt. über den Zins.
Ich gehe hin und sage Ich gebe dir eine Ziege Ich habe sie aber noch nicht in einem Jahr habe ich sie aber und sie wird ein bisschen größer sein als die die ich jetzt hätte ihm Eins zu Eins Tausch und dieses zur Verfügung stellen von Zukunft braucht Zinsen.
Und diese Zinsen brauchen Inflation.
Jetzt geht es wirklich ans Eingemachte jetzt stellt sie sich noch einmal selbst die Frage Was ist eigentlich mein Punkt 1 und warum ist Klimaschutz jetzt eigentlich auch meine Aufgabe.
Banks die legitimierter Authorities Komplement Climate Change Policies.
Auf.
Doing nothing,
to failing liest.
Der Determination European Commission oft Meany auf die euro area Liedes.
Sociedad Sustainability as found in monetary policy working poor.
So rechtfertigt nochmal warum sie sich jetzt auch ums Klima kümmert wohl wissen dass es eigentlich die politischen und so weiter aber gehört von denen es da wenig zu erwarten.
Warum es auch Ihre Aufgabe ist jetzt wissen wir aber ihre eigentliche Aufgabe ist ja diese.
Santoro and eingewöhnt Confederations Mandate Fernando de Treaty of price stability.
Die Preisstabilität das ist so eine heilige Kuh.
Preisstabilität.
Und was ist Preisstabilität ist eine Inflationsrate die.
Aber was ist Preisstabilität. Preisstabilität ist eine Inflationsrate von,
knapp unter 2 laut den Verträgen aber wie kommt. Wie kommen die Autoren dazu zu sagen Genau.
Unter.
Vertrag ist. Das ist eine wenn man so möchte eine willkürliche Festlegung die sich auch zeigt.
Und auch das ist eine Geschichte.
Die sich zeigt. Diese Angst besteht ja. Diese Angst wurde.
Diese Angst besteht ja diese Angst vor der Hyperinflation gerade in Deutschland kann man damit sehr gut Angst machen.
Gerade in Deutschland kann man sehr gut Angst machen. Nach 45 Jahren.
Nach 45 als wir alles verloren hatten.
Und dann sagt man immer Ja wir können nicht als Staat oder jetzt auch. Nun ist es ein bisschen schwieriger da wir nicht eine eigene Währung.
Und dann sagt man immer wir können nicht als Staat auch ein bisschen schwieriger da wir es anders. Wir können nicht einfach sagen wir drucken Geld.
Man könnte es anders regeln. Wir können nicht einfach sagen Wir drucken nur noch Geld wie wir es brauchen.
Wir brauchen das Geld selbst immer noch von den Nationalbanken gedruckt allerdings unter Beobachtung.
Ja Beobachtung Wir haben eine nationale Währung.
In Amerika ist es einfacher den USA ihre nationale Währung und der Kongress braucht Geld und dann bekommen die das dann auch von der Fed.
Und dann gibt es von dem Maastricht-Vertrag ja gewisse Grenzen die einzuhalten sind wenn ein Land,
wirtschaftlich gut aufgestellt ist dann darf eigentlich nicht mehr Staatsverschuldung sein als 60 Prozent im Verhältnis zum Bruttoinlandsprodukt.
Bei Griechenland waren mal 120 war man da mal an der großen Krise.
Man sagt eigentlich Maastrichter Vertrag schon bei über 90 im Verhältnis zum Bruttoinlandsprodukt bricht alles zusammen.
Und da gibt es jetzt sehr viele Wir werden vielleicht auch nochmal wenn wir bei über Friedrich Merz sprechen drauf kommen.
Da gibt es inzwischen aber ökonomen die dem widersprechen zum Beispiel ökonomen der modernen monetarisieren.
Sagen wir doch mal nach Japan. Dort haben wir seit Jahren mehr als zehn Jahren im Verhältnis zum Bruttoinlandsprodukt sprechen wir von 60 oder 90 sondern von 230.
Ist Japan zusammengebrochen. Nein.
Genau das habe ich auch gehört ist aber zusammengebrochen. Wenn man sich die Lage der Jugend in Japan anguckt muss man sagen Ja Japan ist zusammengebrochen aber es ist noch da.
Wenn man sich die Lage in Japan.
Aber das liegt nicht an der Inflation.
Genau man könne es politisch anders steuern.
In Japan fahren die Züge pünktlich und da fehlen halt Arbeitskräfte im Krankenhaus aber das Krankenhaus selbst ist da und da liegt es nicht an 260 prozent BIP Staatsverschuldung.
Und wir müssen auch sagen bei diesem Beispiel Druckerpresse in Deutschland angeschmissen wurden während des Zweiten Weltkrieges in Großbritannien und in den USA hat man auch Geld gedruckt um diesen Krieg zu finanzieren.
Man hatte nur mal das Glück auf der Seite der Sieger zu stehen.
Man war aber auch das stabilere Land man hatte an einen Diktator und die Inflation von Ländern die zu hohe Inflation haben wollen dass man das Brot für das Geld was man gestern noch bezahlte.
Am nächsten Tag nicht mehr bekommt und man braucht plötzlich zehnfacher. Das sind Länder sagen diese Leute,
die ohnehin sehr sehr instabil sind. Und da kommt das dann noch hinzu.
Aber bei stabilen Ländern ist Inflation gar nicht so ein großes Problem und man sieht ja auch dass wir trotz einer lockeren Geldpolitik jetzt keine hohe Inflation haben wir gehen ja fast auf eine Deflation zu.
Ja
Genau.
Das ist ein großer Kampf gegen die Inflation. Inflation heißt Verteuerung.
Vor 40 Jahren wenn man sich Grund und Boden gekauft hat war völlig klar dass der Zinssatz der acht neun Prozent ist und so weiter.
Das musste aufgefangen werden durch einen brauche ich auch als Arbeiter alle zwei Jahre nach acht Prozent Steigerung.
Haben die Gewerkschaften durchgesetzt jetzt mal wie gesagt in dieser Niedrigzinsphase und nochmal angeschlossen an.
Vorhin um sich die Zukunft verfügbar zu machen braucht man Zinsen.
Warum sollte man ein Jahr lang auf die Rückgabe einer Ziege warten wenn sie nicht größer ist. Es ist dieses alte Tausch Verhältnis nur nochmal mit Zeit eingerechnet.
Hat die EZB. Lagarde hat die Aufgabe für Inflation zu sorgen Inflation zu beobachten dieses 2 Prozent Ziel zu erreichen.
Und jetzt stellt sie aber fest Es gibt nicht nur die willkürlich. Warum eigentlich zwei Prozent mehr ökonomen von Fach Rechnen mit Approximation Hoffnung festgelegt.
2 prozent macht irgendwie Sinn das gekoppelt mit drei Prozent Staatsverschuldung sollte nämlich auch nicht weniger sein so 3 Prozent sollte es schon sein dass nämlich Deutschland ab.
Das ist nicht nur eine Obergrenze wie bei der Inflation auch eine Untergrenze. Und jetzt gibt's ja diesen historischen Moment.
Sie bekam eine doppelte Frage gestellt sie beantwortet die erste Frage die zweite Frage oder muss sie noch mal ganz darauf hingewiesen werden es gab ja noch die andere Frage die hier im Raum steht und wir hören uns das mal.
We Live Stone entfernt an Harvey Mascher in Flaschen ist Clayallee Something Lockhart,
lautet,
die Show Housing between One. Was ist die Reality. Los Santos,
ist,
ein Typ.
So bekommt die Frage Was ist jetzt mit den Hauspreise sagt sie.
Real Estate richtig Inflation ist unglaublich schwer zu messen wir müssen das noch einmal auf den Prüfstand stellen wir wissen gar nicht genau wie wir Inflation.
Das ist ungeheuerlich eigentlich was ich hier sagt.
Die EZB weiß gerade nicht wie man Inflation richtig misst. Und dieses Problem was ich hier beschreibe betrifft.
Sie kann aus der EZB rausgehen zehn Fußminuten,
entfernt von einem Wohnturm der gerade in Frankfurt entsteht indem werden Wohnungen für Quadratmeterpreise von 25 000 Euro verkauft also hundert Quadratmeter Wohnung für zweieinhalb Millionen Euro.
Dies nennt man Vermögenspreise Inflations sind unerhört.
Das sind unerhörte unerhörte Preise die bezahlt auch niemand der die Wohnung braucht zum Wohnen sondern und da macht sie eben diesen Unterschied.
Bezahlt auch niemand der die Wohnung braucht nein sondern und macht sie eben diesen Unterschied. Es geht jetzt in Immobilien.
Es gibt also Immobilien.
Da ist der ONA drin und man nutzt sie und dann gibt es eben diese Immobilien die für 25 000 Quadratmeter.
25000 Quadratmeter nur als Anlage in den obersten Etagen sieht niemand.
Die werden nur als Anlage gekauft also in diesen Wohnturm wird in den obersten zehn Etagen weder in Frankfurt noch an den Henninger Turm. Da zieht niemand ein.
Man kennt das aus London da gibts auch so schöne Fotos. Wenn man dann eigentlich eine beleuchtete Stadt hat muss es abends halb zehn. Und dann gibt es aber ganze Stockwerke die komplett leer sind und man denkt Die sind aber alle früh ins Bett gegangen.
Genau da ist irgendein chinesischer Pensionsfonds oder so.
Der investiert 300 Millionen kauft 100 Wohnungen stehen leer für die nächsten acht Jahre da wird keine einzige da kümmert sich keiner drum.
Und jetzt ist die Frage Und deswegen stellt sie die Real Estate.
Was ist eigentlich also erreichen wir eigentlich dass zwei Prozent Inflation wenn zwei Prozent Preissteigerung bedeutet.
Die Wohnungen sind einfach 300 Mal so teuer wie vorher.
Das rechnen wir mit rein dann kommen wir im Durchschnitt auf zwei Prozent. Gleichzeitig ist aber die ganze restliche Wirtschaft völlig abgeschmiert und der Inflations Wert wird einfach nur aufgefangen durch die Wohnung ist halt zu teuer.
Wenn man jetzt die Wohnung herausrechnet. Also wenn man den Inflations Warenkorb den man da immer so nimmt und sagt Wir nehmen das Wohnen raus,
da haben wir eine ganz andere Inflationsrate und dann sind wir ja wirklich schon in der Deflation weil das was Inflation noch übrig bleibt allein vom Hauspreise aufgesaugt und alles andere und deswegen ihr großes Dinge.
Ja wir müssen uns erst mal Gedanken machen wie wir das so wie wir Inflation überhaupt neu berechnen.
Wir brauchen hier eine ganz neue Kennziffer für das wie für die wichtigste Kennziffer unseres Mandats.
Man könnte auch selbst fragen inwieweit das was bei den Aktienmärkten stattfindet auch inflationär ist.
Dort haben wir Preisentwicklungen Wir haben seit der Krise verdreifacht.
Wir leben von der Realwirtschaft abgekoppelt was dort stattfindet.
Wir haben gerade beim Risikokapital verrückteste Investitionen wo sehr viel Geld einfach da ist.
Stichwort Vermögenspreise Inflation wo auch investiert wird.
Genauso wie solche Projekte wie dieser Wohnturm dort investiert werden.
Wird sicherlich nicht so relevant im Gesamten gesehen aber wo sich,
der Kunstmarkt auch vollkommen überhitzt wo,
man jede Woche in der dpa irgendwelche neue Rekorde angeliefert bekommt das Gemälde das noch 100 Millionen wert war fünf Jahre später für 30 Millionen verkauft wird Plus dann die ganze moderne Kunst die,
quasi als Spekulationsobjekt gleich hergestellt wird.
Genau so läuft alles in diesen Warenkorb ein.
Sie hat am Anfang das Inflations der aktuelle Informationswert ist 1,4 Prozent im Vergleich des Monats im Vergleich zum Vorjahr.
Kann man sagen Okay 1,4 Prozent ist jetzt nicht knapp unter 2 Prozent aber unter 2 Prozent und auch nicht null.
Also irgendwo zwischen 1 und 2 kann man eigentlich zufrieden sein aber es gibt eben diese krassen Turbulenzen durch.
Es ist einfach zu viel Geld da fließt aber nicht in die Wirtschaft sondern in den Kunstmarkt.
Also die Bilder werden jetzt wie Geldscheine selbst als Geld behandelt es ist gar nicht mehr Kunst im eigentlichen Sinne sondern ist fast eine Währung,
diese Wohnung ganz genauso die da irgendwo rumstehen und gebaut werden ja da wird irgendwie irgendwas aber diese Werte sind nur noch Buchwerte irgendwo in irgendwelchen Fonds niedergeschrieben und,
2020 Januar ist der Monat in dem sie dann einfach da sind.
Ja wir haben dieses Mandat Wir haben eigentlich noch eine zweite Aufgabe Klima aber schon bei der ersten wissen wir gar nicht mehr genau was ist woran orientieren wir uns eigentlich.
Da gab es eine sehr schöne Begegnung von Lagarde damals noch als IWF-Chefin 2018 hat sie Yuval Noah Harari eingeladen und das ist wieder so ein wunderschöner Moment von sprechendes denken wo sie wieder überrascht wird. Es gab noch eine Frage stand doch eine Frage im Raum.
Na gut ja und sie wird hier mal kurz in ihrer Anmoderation dieses Gesprächs von Harari selbst unterbrochen.
Standard,
ist TBV Points of Philosophy,
Experts.
Ökonomismus in Polz.
Economies.
Und da hat er vollkommen recht. Die ganze klassische ökonomie ist im Prinzip eine Märchen Erzählung kann man sagen,
und was sie aber nicht mehr sondern dabei der klassischen ökonomie Hans-Werner Sinn spricht dann ist das etwa so wahr wie irgendetwas von den Gebrüdern Grimm.
Aber nicht im negativen Sinne sondern es ist halt.
Gut.
Aber diese moralische Komponente der Deutschen ökonomie Diskussion mal ausgeklammert.
Wenn wir abends gucken Tagesthemen und heute die Inflationsrate von jetzt 1,4 Prozent dann ist das eine Erzählung der wir glauben während wir nicht erfahren wie Laga da sitzt und sagt Inflation.
Wenn wir haben ja die Inflationsrate von vier Prozent.
Wir glauben genau während wir nicht erfahren wie lange hat da Inflation.
Ich setze mir meine klugen Leute dran und ich berechnen könne sich natürlich auch der populistische ökonomie.
Ich setze mal meine klugen Leute dran damit wir das mal wieder ordentlich berechnen können.
Auf der Ebene das ist nochmal diese populistische ökonomie die Wissen an die öffentlichkeit hinausgetragen wird.
Geschenkt sozusagen. Da haben wir mit Hans-Werner Sinn in Deutschland genau den richtigen.
Geschenkt. Haben wir mit Hans-Werner Sinn sind genau die Richtigen.
So aber dass er eben noch mal sagt wenn sie beim IWF oder danach bei der EZB wenn sie was von Inflationsrate erzählen ist das halt einfach nur eine Story die alle glauben.
Aber dass er sagt ja wenn sie beim IWF oder bei der Inflationsrate erzielen ist das einfach nur eine Story die alle glauben.
Aber es bleibt da trotzdem eine Story. Die Frage ist jetzt kann man sie anders schreiben. Kann man sie anders schreiben gerade wenn man eine große Herausforderung wie die Klimakrise hat.
Aber es bleibt die Frage jetzt kann man sie anders schreitende kann man Sie schreiben gerade wenn man große Herausforderungen wie die Klimakrise hat.
Und da gibts jetzt schwenkt mal ein bisschen um zum Green New Deal. Nochmal beim Klimaschutz.
Da es ein bisschen unzufrieden.
Wir müssen sagen Das ist ja der Green Deal Es ist nicht der Green New Deal.
Ja beides. Also der Green Deal.
Beides von der Leyen spricht vom green deal und nicht vom Green New Deal.
Wir werden es kurz auseinander Der amerikanische Vorschlag ist der Green New Deal den gibt es aber auch in Europa gibt zum Beispiel von 25 die haben zusammen mit Naomi Klein im Green New Deal Konzept.
Auseinander Der amerikanische Vorschlag ist der Green New Deal weil er nochmal in den New Deal anknüpft.
Zusammen mit Naomi Klein. Deal Konzept es gibt noch ein paar andere Intellektuelle Gruppen oder Gruppen. Aber Green New Deal.
Es gibt noch ein paar andere die die Green Intellektuelle Gruppen oder auch politische Gruppen in Green New Deal haben wollen und anknüpfen an das was in Amerika gedacht wird vor allem auch von Bernie Sanders.
Ja das ist nochmal eine dritte Komponente dann wenn wir uns den amerikanischen Green New Deal wie er als Resolutionen von Cassio Cortes vorgeschlagen ist dann ist es ja kein Gesetz sondern es ist sozusagen eine,
Präambel für zukünftige Politik an der man sich orientiert die man dann mal haben möchte.
Aber da stehen jetzt noch keine Zahlen oder so weiter drin während das was die jetzt 25 vorschlägt ist ja schon ein ganz konkretes Zahlenwerk,
ausgearbeitet auf fünf Milliarden-Investitionen und so weiter rein staatlich dann ist auch die Frage Macht man über Schulden oder greift man ab oder gibt man,
Staatsanleihen dafür raus dass man das Geld einsammelt oder schöpft man nur Gewinner von privaten Leuten ab und so weiter.
Und dann gibt's eben jetzt diesen von der Leyen als drittes nochmal diesen ganz konkreten Green Deal der als ganz normales europäisches Gesetzeswerk.
Sie möchte es ja tatsächlich gerne auf fast Vertrags Niveau haben dass man neue Zollgrenzen als wirklich Schutzräume gegen Stahl von außen und so weiter da platziert. Also genau da muss man sie ein bisschen auseinanderhalten.
Wir sind jetzt nochmal bei einem vierten nämlich bei Andrew Yang der in Amerika auch gerade antritt mit dem Argument Geld für alle.
Er möchte das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen für die Amerikaner einführen 1000 Dollar Monat.
Und er hält sich jetzt an gar keine Green Deal Greno Deal irgendwie keine Ahnung welche Diskussion es im Raum sondern er knüpft nochmal an an. So wie ich hier gesagt wurde.
Inflation keine Ahnung was das eigentlich sein soll und dann ist es nicht eine große Erzählung was die ökonomen uns da anbieten.
Es geht ja nicht nur für Inflation sondern eben auch für dieses Bruttoinlandsprodukt das ja auch so maßgeblich ist für politische Entscheidungen Inflation und Bruttoinlandsprodukt und entgegenblickt hat ja die Frage Was würdest du eigentlich am Tag deiner Amtseinführung als Präsident tun.
Vineta,
Businessman.
Das ist erst mal super interessant Er kommt als Politiker und sagt Wir sind open for business. Was die Kämpfer des Klimawandels angeht.
Economic Benchmark.
DEMOKRATUR IN.
Moving,
Business.
Times.
Jetzt wo wir die Klippe der Berechnung wirklich Neues einzuführen und zu sagen Wirtschaftskraft durch Kohleverbrennung.
Jetzt wo wir die Klippe der Abrechnung runterfahren können wir wirklich drüber nachdenkt mal ein neues Bib einzuführen und zu sagen Wirtschaftskraft durch Kohleverbrennung.
Schreiben will ich eine Bücherei eine Null stehen ein neues Benchmark und alle versuchen keine Null dastehen zu haben.
Schreiben wenn ich eine Büchereien bleibt eine Null stehen und schon ist ein neues Benchmark und alle versuchen keine Null stehen zu haben. Und dann ist man weg von der Kohle.
Ist man der Ansicht super revolutionär.
Super revolutionär. Fratzscher und Märzen angesprochen da kann man noch mal drauf.
Ja man nochmal nochmal. Diese Verquickung dass jetzt ökonomen Politik machen wollen und Politiker mit ökonomischen Argumenten.
Diese Verquickung das jetzt ökonom Politik machen wollen und Politiker mit ökonomischen Argumenten.
Diese Verdrehung von Aufgaben das wir Neujahrsansprache von Politikern haben die uns gar kein Denkgebäude anbieten dann aber eine EZB-Präsident die mit dem größten politischen Projekt überhaupt.
Diese Verdrehung von Aufgaben das wir Neujahrsansprache von Politikern haben die uns gar kein Denkgebäude anbieten und dann aber den EZB-Präsidenten mit dem größten politischen Projekt überhaupt werben die größten Ideen Catalog plötzlich da Preiskontrolle einen Auftritt.
Wir haben die größten Ideen Catalog plötzlich in Pressekonferenzen auftritt.
Das eine völlig neue neues Arrangement von.
Das ist eine völlig neue neues Arrangement von die demokratische Seite liefert gerade gar nichts. Die Leute.
Ich bin mir sicher dass uns das gesamte Jahrzehnt durch begleiten wird. Ganz anders.
Werden ganz anders aus diesem Jahrzehnt rauskommen werden. Wir haben jetzt schon die Sachlage dass die demokratisch gewählten in so einer Fermate Starre verharren weil sie sich nichts mehr zutrauen oder gleich Amtsenthebungsverfahren und so weiter nur unter Feuer stehen.
Wir haben jetzt schon.
Fast froh sind dass sie nichts machen können. Das ist ja auch immer wieder Unterhaltung wie wir sie so einen vorsichtigen Appell an die Bürger.
Oder so.. Genau.
Was hat man geleistet. Der Berliner Bürgermeister hat sich etwas davon abgesetzt aber sonst ist es so dass man eigentlich froh ist dass man gar nicht so viel machen kann.
Man hat das auch sehr viel aus den Händen gegeben muss man sagen Das kann man vielleicht auch gleich nochmal thematisieren.
Aber hier tritt jetzt eine auf der sagt Wir denken nun über die Wirtschaft und über Wert in einer Gesellschaft.
BIP und Glückstadt lasse das ist im Grunde Niveau gleich nur dass eine Selbsterziehung der ökonomen die glauben wir immer weil sie uns in diesen Tagesthemen blaue dargeboten wird und das andere kommt aus heiterem Himmel als Nachricht einmal im Jahr gibts einen Glückstadt lassen aber im Grunde keine Niveau Unterschiede.
Es sind halt die großen Erzählungen da kann man bei Harari schön nachlesen auch ganz aktuell wenn man nicht immer nur die alten Philosophen sondern ein bisschen die aktuellen so,
sieht man bei Harry Hary kann man da gut tanken gehen was solche Ideen angeht aber wie er sagte Bib habe ich schon gelernt Inflation,
müssen sich alle mal neu angucken kann man genauso auf den Prüfstand stellen und so gehts ja durch.
Wir haben jetzt die EZB die dann mit Green Bonds vielleicht je nachdem was sie aus ihren eigenen Pensionsfonds Salerno Blackrock will jetzt haben wir diese Zertifikate sind einfach die Märkte abbilden und die wollen jetzt einfach diese,
Komponente Environmental Social Governance stellen einfach Forderungen.
Und wenn du denen nicht ansprichst weil du beispielsweise mehr als 25 Prozent des Umsatzes mit Kohleverbrennung machst dann fällt es halt aus diesem Aicha raus raus.
Das heißt aber gleich dass dein Unternehmen gleich mal 2 prozent an Aktien Eigentümern verliert.
Die kommen dann neu auf den Aktienmarkt und eine Investitionsentscheidung gegen den Trend den Blackrock zu treffen.
Das muss man sich dann auch erst mal trauen als Konkurrent auf dem Finanzmarkt.
Wir sehen auch hier wieder wo die eigentliche Macht sitzt die im viel größeren Druck ausüben können auf Unternehmen und BlackRock gehört zu den Mächtigen fünf was France anbelangt.
Ja genau.
Ich würde da völlig herausheben. Es gibt halt mächtige 4 und dann gibts Blackrock obendrüber.
Ja so könnte man auch sagen Ja die EZB 20 Milliarden im Monat investieren die sechs und sieben Millionen in eigene einen eigenen ersetzt.
Die EZB 20 Milliarden im Monat investieren die Blackrock sechs Billionen sieben Billionen in eigner an eigenen Assets.
Das ist einfach Das sind unerhörte Werte. Damit können sie wirklich da die Märkte ummodeln jetzt ist die Frage Wie kommt man jetzt.
Das ist unerhört.
Da die Märkte ummodeln jetzt ist die Frage Wie kommt man jetzt.
Wann würde Oma Erna akzeptieren dass man jetzt neu berechnet.
Wann würde Omer akzeptieren dass man jetzt neu berechnet wann haben wir vielleicht wenn man sie fragt was es eigentlich bedeutet und sie müsste das erklären.
Wann haben wir ein neues Modell für Inflation.
Man kann durch Nachfragen erklärt auch mal es entzaubern erzählt Du doch mal die Geschichte die du immer so erzählt bekommst. Genau damit hätte man.
Es gibt hier immer die Idee von Wir brauchen eigentlich erst mal eine totale Zerstörung also nicht nur schöpferische Disruption sondern es ist egal ob,
ein Weltkrieg wäre schon notwendig um Sohne krassen Erzählung neu zu stricken.
Und da stimmen wir uns nun mal ein. Der letzte Moment als man dachte okay jetzt können wir mal was Neues probieren beispielsweise Sozialismus ist 100 Jahre her.
Wir hören nur ein bisschen so ein paar Klänge SWR 2 Wissen Christiane Sievers und Nikolaus Schröder haben wir mal zehn Jahre zurück geschaut auf so einen Moment wo das möglich war.
Jetzt ist der Boden bis in seine Tiefen vier Jahre Weltkrieg. Jetzt oder nie muss die Saat des Sozialismus ausgestreut werden.
So Käte Duncker hat damals gesehen nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg ist alles kaputt.
Die Städte waren nicht so zerstört wie nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg da jetzt keine falsche Vorstellung aber es ist ziemlich viel kaputt.
Jetzt könnten wir es doch mal mit dem Sozialismus versuchen. Da hatte man zumindest die Idee jetzt so einen Moment.
Die Frage ist ja auch fallen wir hier wieder auf so eine Erzählung ein dass wir immer einen Krieg brauchen.
Oder haben wir nicht sowieso eine Wirtschaft die sich einfach mobil mobilisieren lässt auch ohne Krieg wie wir es ansonsten nur aus den Kriegszeiten kennen.
Alexandra Kasia Cortés wirklich gut als sie in Amerika mal in einer Fernsehsendung beschrieben hat.
Wenn man das so hört denkt man ja diesen Moment diesen Moment allergrößter Zerstörung könnte man sich eigentlich herbeireden und einfach sagen Der ist jetzt da wir können es jetzt machen wir brauchen gar keinen großen Krieg.
Bevor.
Er.
Das heißt Die Katastrophe ist da. Man muss jetzt nicht nochmal auf ein Ereignis.
Das ist sicherlich sehr merkwürdig dass wir so ein Ereignis zentriert sind in unserer Wahrnehmung,
Atomkraftwerk Fukushima passiert aber wir wussten ja vorher waren über alle Gefahren informiert. Man hätte nach Fukushima.
Ja machen trotzdem weiter.
Aber wir sind eben sehr fokussiert und reagieren.
Das ist etwas was man beim Green New Deal finden kann der.
Eine Reaktion auf die Wirtschaftskrise Man hat.
Aber zugleich,
auch welche die sagen Ja man hat ja damals bei der Kriegswirtschaft in den USA und Großbritannien die Katastrophe zum Anlass genommen jetzt anders zu wirtschaften und hat sehr schnell eine Entscheidung treffen können,
was wir da eigentlich haben es seine Idee vom Ausnahmezustand,
ist wenn es einen Souverän gibt der dann,
die entscheidenden Dinge tut ist sehr gefährlich.
Das sprechen von einem Ausnahmezustand das ist etwas was in den 20er Jahren,
Anfang der Dreißiger zu dieser Definition kommt souverän über den Ausnahmezustand entscheidet das mitunter undemokratisches weil das parlamentarische nicht mehr so gefragt ist sondern,
Alexandria.
Was wir.
Als Normalität wahrnehmen.
Wir sind nie in einem neutralen Verhältnis das dann gestört wird durch Ereignisse auf das wir reagieren müssen,
sondern wir sind eigentlich in einer permanenten Situation wo wir uns positionieren müssen und wo wir uns in Relation zu,
zukünftigen setzen müssen.
Kluge Politik wartet auf die nächste Katastrophe auf die sie dann reagieren kann.
Merkel nicht nur bei Fukushima sondern auch.
Für alle eingeführt.
Und dann haben wir das gemacht und so waren es dann auch 2015.
Entwicklungen reagiert die man vorher weitgehend ignoriert hat und.
Ein work in progress weil sie erkennt dass wir in einer permanenten Situation der Unsicherheit sind und dass wir nicht,
diese Neujahrsansprache suggeriert haben eigentlich alles ganz gut.
Ja man kann es nur immer wieder sagen. Cortez macht im Grunde Politik so wie wir diesen Podcast mit einem Modus der sofort Historisierung.
Da käme ich nie auf den Gedanken eine Neujahrsansprache zu halten in dem Modus meine Uhr sagt 31.
Dezember. Also machen wir einen Schnitt.
Blicken zwölf Monate zurück und dann überlege ich nochmal was ich zur Zukunft sage. Nein es hat alles eingebettet so wie wir auch jetzt schon verstehen können.
Die amerikanischen Präsidenten Kandidaten die wir jetzt haben sind alle irgendwie 70 oder älter also die von Relevanz.
Und da kommt es sehr darauf an was haben Sie vor 30 40 Jahren gemacht. Waren sie konsistent in ihrem Handeln und so weiter wie bei Hillary damals.
Sie hat sich schon vor 20 Jahren für die Krankenversicherung interessiert bei Cortés können wir jetzt schon ahnen wie das in 20 Jahren ist.
Wenn sie dann sagt könnte es auch mal Präsidentin werden dann blickt man natürlich zurück auf diesen Moment genau so wie sie jetzt wahrscheinlich schon darüber nachdenkt mit welcher Legge Sie will ich eigentlich später dann mal für die höheren ämter und deswegen lege ich jetzt schon mal die von Gerhard rein und sage.
Das ist sozusagen eine Politik die sich extrem von dieser Neujahrsansprache Modus Politik dieses Merkelsche,
morgens aufsteht und mal gucken in welche Richtung der Wind weht damit man am Abend vielleicht Anny dann lässt man es doch und wartet noch drei Monate bis man mal wieder irgendwie was zu dem Thema sagt.
Nee das ist einfach mittendrin und innerlich eben genau auf den Punkt weil wir können uns ja fragen Du hast Fukushima angesprochen.
Das war eine Naturgewalt ein Erdbeben in Amerika gab es zum Beispiel dieses Erdbeben von Haiti Teil Amerikas wo man sich auch fragte Warum handelt Amerika da nicht. Das sind doch so viele Tote zu beklagen.
Na gut weil ein Erdbeben was will man machen ist halt ein Erdbeben irgendwie eine auf der anderen Seite hat man dann eben diesen Moment wie dieses.
Was Sie da angesprochen hat in Puerto Rico den Wirbelsturm sei jetzt menschengemacht oder nicht und anders als ein Erdbeben würde ich sagen Ja da kann man durchaus wie sie in dem Modus herangehen zu sagen,
Dieser Wirbelsturm beim Menschen gemacht haben Menschen 3000 andere Menschen getötet zwar nicht in diesem direkten,
Wir können jetzt eine Schuld Erklärung personalisieren aber hier sind Menschen dafür verantwortlich ist ein menschengemachten Klimawandel der diesen Wirbelsturm mit verursacht hat. Warum handeln wir nicht.
Als Paul Haber angegriffen wurde wird doch auch gehandelt. Also eine ganz legitime Frage.
Gar nicht so Outer Space wie man so glaubt sondern eine ganz legitime Frage Warum handeln wir jetzt eigentlich nicht und wir könnten doch jetzt handeln und es gäbe doch genug Rahmen zu handeln.
Jetzt ist dieses Klima Thema eben wirklich da weil wir eben auch solche neuen Politiker eine neue Politikergeneration haben und jetzt müssen wir es aber trotzdem nochmal umdrehen.
Wir haben ja vorhin gesagt Der Klimawandel ist einfach nur ein neuer Modus für das alte wirtschaften das alternativlos kapitalistische Wirtschaften dem man alles austreiben kann also selbst Wirtschaftswachstum wenn man jetzt sagt Okay wir schaffen das nur durch weniger Konsum,
selbst das kriegt man in eine neue Erzählung eingebunden in der trotzdem in den Bilanzen plus irgendwo drin.
Ja ich bin da skeptisch darüber werden wir bestimmt noch oft reden.
Der Kapitalismus funktioniert nur mit Wachstum. Es gibt keinen Kapitalismus ohne Wachstum.
Kapitalakkumulation.
Kapitalismus kann in anderen Feldern wachsen und dann in anderen schrumpfen. Das erleben wir laufend in unserem Alltag.
Solche Bäckereien wo man in der Schweiz Brot kauft immer weniger findet und im Supermarkt kaufen muss.
Solche Entwicklungen gibt es allerdings ein Kapitalismus ohne Wachstum bedeutet auch dass wir Wohlstand einbüßen wenn wir Wohlstand.
Berechnen. Man könnte auch ganz anders über Wohlstand nachdenken wie das aussehen wird.
Aber zunächst einmal sind alle Fonds die sich auf die grüne Welle werfen oder Unternehmen die mehr oder weniger mitmachen daran interessiert Gewinne zu machen und sie müssen mehr,
mehr Umsatz machen als im vergangenen Jahr. Anders ist es nicht möglich.
Das andere wäre noch dass man das durch Lohnnebenkostensenkung hinbekommt das heißt Leute werden entlassen was aber auch wieder Wachstumswerte Kapitalismus ohne Wachstum ist nicht denkbar.
Das ist für mich eigentlich das Spannendste in diesen zehn Jahren wie wir sehen werden ob der Kapitalismus das tatsächlich schafft beides zu sein eine wachsende ein wachsendes Wirtschaftssystem und ein ökologisches Ich,
bin da sehr sehr skeptisch,
würde aber sagen dass die Zeiten für den Kapitalismus momentan obwohl wir alle so sehr darüber reden und Kapitalismuskritik längst in bürgerlichen Zeitungen und so weiter stattfinden gerade wieder,
erleben wo der Kapitalismus sich neu erfindet.
Der Neoliberalismus vielleicht an sein Ende kommt dass er sich nicht mehr durchsetzen kann.
Da würde ich nämlich auch klar unterscheiden.
Wir sind aber nicht mehr an dieser Krise wie wir das 2008 hatten wo man den Kapitalismus genereller in Frage stellte.
Dadurch dass man jetzt ein anderes Problem hat das man jetzt erst einmal viele kapitalistische Antworten findet nämlich so könnte sich die Wirtschaft verändern.
Aber da müssen wir unterscheiden zwischen dem Neoliberalismus.
Man kann auch sagen dass wir jetzt mit einer Teilkonzern haben die eigene Märkte erschaffen haben.
Apple-Stores Apple-Stores. Da haben wir nicht mehr den neoliberalen Markt oder so.
Da haben wir einen großen Platzhirsch weggehen von dieser neoliberalen Erzählung das Ende des Neoliberalismus wenn wir in diesen zehn Jahren,
so möchte ich hoffnungsfroh prognostizieren erleben.
Wir werden aber nicht glaube ich das Ende des Kapitalismus erleben. Und man weiß es könnte noch viel schlimmer werden.
Neoliberalismus auch das ist noch denkbar.
Also das Ende des Kapitalismus wäre tatsächlich das Ende der Welt.
Denn es ist also die Alternative.
Ich unterscheide nicht Kapitalismus von Sozialismus und Sozialismus politischer Sozialismus ist eine andere Form von Kapitalismus aber Kapitalismus heißt solange es mit Geld funktioniert ist es kapitalistisch Die Frage ist nur tatsächlich Erstens Was ist die Geldquelle.
Das war natürlich über 200 Jahre der fossile Brennstoffe denn da war sehr viel.
Man brauchte drei Menschen um Kohle auszubauen buddeln ein Menschen um die Dampfmaschine zu betreiben und dann konnten 100 Menschen mit dieser Energie etwas machen.
Das war genau diese Rechnung. Die Frage ist jetzt kriegt man es anders hin.
Muss die Geldquelle das Ausbeuten der fossilen Brennstoffe sein oder und deswegen auch hier Wohlstand für alle also die modernen Monetary Theory,
kann man nicht andere politisch klug eingesetzte Geldquellen haben wenn man weiß wie man die Inflation berechnet und wann man die Geldquelle auch mal zurückdrehen muss.
Reicht es da nicht zu sagen liebe Banken haut das Geld raus. Wir garantieren euch zwei Prozent Zins bei uns.
Solange ihr die Wirtschaft weitergibt also auch die Frage Braucht man dafür nach Hausbanken oder schaffen wir das demnächst mit einer App die wir an die EZB koppeln.
Dass die uns direkt das Geld gibt da wird gleich noch ein B9 klappt es ist sehr interessant nochmal den Modus von vorhin.
Seit 2008 sucht die Wirtschaft händeringend ein neues Wirtschaftsmodell und wir haben jetzt herausgefunden die letzten zehn Jahre hatten wir ein Wirtschaftsmodell du die Idee schon was hatten Kapitaleigner ihr Geld vermehrt haben.
Gleichzeitig ist eine jüngere Generation nachgewachsen die überhaupt gar keine Vermögenswerte aufgebaut hat.
Und das zeigt auch allein schon die beispielsweise Kreditkarten betreuen oder Schulden aus Bildung in Amerika.
Dieses Geld wird nie eingetrieben werden können weil es einfach nicht vorhanden ist diesen jungen Menschen kann man keine Häuser pfänden das Auto nicht wegnehmen kann man einen Fernseher nehmen dann kriegt man 50 Dollar für ein Studium oder so.
Da gibts gar keine Geldquellen mehr. Wir brauchen aber für diesen Kapitalismus neue Geldquellen da war das so interessant dass George Soros 2008 schon diesen Modus beschrieb in denen wir heute sagen endlich so ein bisschen übergehen.
Leslie Barista go home Latham gehoben sei,
the World Order together.
Dieser Halbsatz hat ihm das Genick gebrochen. Work and the better world order da sind alle aufgesprungen.
Wir ignorieren das Hirn trotzdem dazu was wir mit dieser World Order meint.
Problems konfrontiert den Think,
Global Warming Lottofee Investment sie,
is the World Economic Economy Drive geht aus Consumption bei Merck und Consumer Spending mordend Savic.
Motor ist viel Stoff. Es ist auch der.
Motor,
Global Warming Investment.
Mother of the World Economic.
Technology Consulting Building Sewing an,
Rivalinnen Zuhauses Justin,
Energie got to cost Mor,
Justins.
In Frankfurt hast du die letzten zehn Jahre eine Umwandlung der Stadt gehabt durch große Urbanisierung war die Nachfrage da riesige Gebäude hinzusetzen acht Stockwerke hundert Parteien in einem Mietshaus und so weiter.
Die sind hier in Niederrad zum Beispiel oder auch im Europaviertel wo vorher die Gleisanlage für die Messe waren.
Das sind heute alles Häuser also riesige Vermögenswerte aber alles Passivhäuser also alles Häuser die die Umwelt nicht weiter belasten und die auch wirklich keinen großen Kohle oder Gas brauchen sondern,
im Grunde eine Wohnung das ganze Haus weil alle dicht an dicht und nicht gedämmt und da ein Vermögenswert geschaffen ohne die Natur weiter zu belasten.
Es wurde einmal gebaut mit Beton und so weiter. Aber dann steht das halt für 50 Jahre.
Und in Amerika hat man dieses Problem. Da kann das keiner bezahlen.
Du kannst in diesen großen Städten Detroit und so weiter da irgendwie 10000 super teure Super gedämmte Wohnung hinsetzen weil es keine Käufer gibt.
Diese ganze Idee von der Amerikaner konsumiert einfach sechs Prozent mehr als er produziert verschuldet sich dafür krass und das ist das Wirtschaftsmodell das funktioniert nicht mehr.
Und jetzt braucht man neue Strategien der Investitionen und es hat eben 2008 genauso beschrieben wie wir es jetzt bei Lagarde und so weiter gesehen haben.
Schon wie soll man sagen zehn Jahre verschwendet könnte man auch sagen.
Das hätte man genauso gut vor zehn Jahren ohne dass man 18 Jahre Verarmung der Millennials macht und die Babyboomer nochmal raushaut hätte man doch einfach gleich machen können.
So ein großes Drama aber wenigstens ein bisschen nachgebaut.
Und dieser Frage Wie weit kann man diese ganzen sind es im Grunde nur Glaubensfragen.
Ist es nur eine neue Story die erzählt werden muss auch da aus der gleichen Sendung hat sich Soros dann nochmal sehr interessant geäußert.
Nein,
ich für,
skandalös. Denn das.
Hier.
Ist kein.
Sophisticated.
And.
Management so wie,
es
In der Housing Market.
Housing.
Explodierte Bieger Babo super Babo. Wie es auf konstant Kreditexpansion.
Häufiger.
Liest weißes fast,
nie,
Kontraktionen.
Extreme Ansammlungen von Buchgeld irgendwelchen Bilanzen stehen aufgrund,
von Fragen Wie wird sich auf eine Ebene stellt wieviel Engel auf einer Nadelspitze tanzen oder wieviel Kamelle durch ein Nadelöhr tanzen ist auf der gleichen Ebene wie warum zwei Prozent Inflation und warum ist das BIP eigentlich so gut wenn es ein bisschen im Plus ist.
Glaubensfragen sind ganz entscheidend für die ökonomie. In dem Wort Kredit steckt auch schon das Wort Glauben drin.
Kredite zurück. Ja genau. Ich.
Hoffen wünschen.
Glaube das Glaubensbekenntnis ist in der Wirtschaft eines das man glaubt dass man sein Geld zurückbekommt.
Und da kommt hinzu dass dadurch dass wir auch keine Golddeckung mehr haben ja Banken das Geld per Knopfdruck produzieren können und müssen nicht in irgendeiner Weise Goldreserven da haben.
Und das hat dafür gesorgt dass es diese Entwicklung der Kredite gibt.
Und da hat er natürlich recht wenn er das sagt wenngleich da kommen wir aber noch zu.
Man unterscheiden muss zwischen den Krediten die wir jetzt als Bürger haben weil wir zu viel konsumieren wollten oder uns ein zu großes Haus gekauft haben und den Krediten die der Staat hat,
zurückzahlen kann muss oder wie er das macht.
Ja genau die Golddeckung ist seit 40 Jahren Geschichte und trotzdem muss man aber.
Die Golddeckung ist seit 40 Jahren. Trotzdem muss man fast sagen die Kredite Hausbanken.
Trotzdem mal sagen die Kredite also Hausbanken geben Kredite nicht gegen Gold oder so oder da liegt irgendwo Gold aber trotzdem immer gegen Eigentum also diese Eigentums ökonomik heißt sondern so super wichtig.
Bedienen Eigentum des Eigentums ökonomik wichtig.
Banken wollen Sicherheit. Die Frage ist dann ist die Sicherheit garantiert.
Banken wollen Sicherheit. Frage Ist die Sicherheit garantieren kann man mit Gold oder auch das Gold immer noch glänzt.
Also kann man Beton mit Gold aufwiegen oder so auch das Gold so viel Wert hat ist ja immer noch weil es halt glänzt und so schön klingt das sind die einzigen beiden Sachen auf die es ankommt.
Das sind die einzigen beiden Sachen ob alle daran glauben dass man mit Gold immer vorwärts kommt aber entsprechend so wie er das hier sagt kann man kann man durchaus die vorausdenken lesen Zwanzigerjahren werden wir erleben wie die.
Und weil dann eben alle daran glauben dass man mit Gold immer vorwärts kommt aber entsprechend so wie er das hier sagt kann man da kann man durchaus die Forderung nach rausspringen in diesen 20er Jahren werden wir erleben wie die,
ökonomische Liturgie Realität mal aufgebrochen wird weil einfach Fragestellungen im Raum stehen wie z.B.
Ökonomische Liturgie und sakrale mal aufgebrochen wird.
Manchmal frage ich dennoch Wir brauchen wie zum Beispiel. Was ist mit Inflation. Also mit Lagarde Das müssen eigentlich alle ein bisschen alarmiert sein.
Was ist jetzt Inflation wenn Lagarde das fragt Müssen eigentlich alle ein bisschen alarmiert sein.
Aber sie stellt die Frage Was ist eigentlich Kation und niemand bekommt es mit.
Aguzzi stellt die Frage Was ist eigentlich Inflation.
Das ist ja das Erstaunliche Eigentlich müsste das dann drei Tage lang der Aufmacher in jeder Zeitung sein.
Das ist doch verrückt.
Eigentlich auch gedacht das Handelsblatt oder so zumindest kein Feuilleton oder so.
Aber vielleicht ist die Zeit dafür dass das Handelsblatt Manforter macht,
so wie die Lagarde überrascht war von dieser Frage Ach ja da war ja noch eine Frage im Raum könnt ich ja nochmal mich nach Feierabend mal hinsetzen und nochmal kurz drei Absätze dazu schreiben irgendwie fürs morgige Handelsblatt. Was ist jetzt eigentlich Inflation.
Wir müssen noch den Rahmen vollenden indem wir nämlich noch kurz auf die aktuelle EU-Kommissionspräsident in Ursula von der Leyen schauen.
Das ist jetzt ein Ausschnitt vom Dezember der ist genau so aktuell weil genau im gleichen Rahmen hat sie auch in Davos erzählt und bei der Klimakonferenz und so weiter.
Wir hören es in der übersetzung auf Deutsch wie es bei Phoenix fand Wir hören jetzt einen Mann der Ursula von der Leyen hören aber den Anspruch den sie hier formuliert den halten wir doch mal so Im Januar 2020 fest.
Es kann nicht angehen dass sie dann vor unlauteren Wettbewerb stehen.
Von Zeiten von wirklich verschmutzen Unternehmen und deswegen werden wir hier einen Grenz Anpassungs Mechanismus wählen.
Da ist man mit einem eingesprungen die Rede es geht ja darum kann man den Stahl in Europa Grüll machen indem man einfach sagt Grenz Anpassungs Mechanismus also jeder Stahl der von außerhalb nach Europa kommt kriegt einfach einen harten Strafzöllen von so und so viel dass er absolut unrentabel ist.
Dass selbst der Grüne Stahl in Europa und Grün heißt der Hochofen wird mit Wasserstoff betrieben statt mit Kohle das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen dass das überhaupt technisch möglich ist. Aber das ist ihr Ziel.
Den WTO-Regeln einhält. Da geht es auch darum die Innovation zu fördern.
Es geht auch darum qualitativ hochwertiges Essen auf den Teller zu bringen.
Es geht um die moderne Mobilität die gefördert werden muss. Dadurch werden auch neue Unternehmen und Märkte überall in Europa entstehen.
Green Deal ist unsere neue Wirtschaftswachstum Strategie und es handelt sich um eine Wachstumsstrategie,
die nicht verbraucht sondern vielmehr mehr zurückgibt als sie wegnimmt.
So haben wir das alle gehört. Ihr Anspruch ist weniger zu verbrauchen als der Natur wieder zurückzugeben.
Das wird sehr interessant sein auf diese Technik freue ich mich.
Ich finde es erstaunlich dass man hier ganz frei heraus sagt Zölle sind in Ordnung.
Ich finde das.
In Ordnung. Ich erinnere mich ganz genau und wir haben alle gesagt wollen wir doch ein bisschen durchwachsen.
Ich erinnere mich als Trump Präsident wurde und der mit Zöllen kam haben alle gesagt Um Gottes Willen und dahin wollen wir doch nie wieder zurück.
Es gab immer die Texte von Anfang an.
Eigentlich hat Trump recht bei China gab es immer.
Ja
sagen wir diese Freihandels Leute und das ist so schön zu lesen in dem Roman von Michel Houellebecq Serotonin wo es darum geht dass dort auch Landwirte rebellieren in Frankreich versuchen sie einen Protest und dann,
wird der Protagonist des Romans gefragt ob er glaubt dass der wirksam sein soll und dann sagt er,
Ich habe mein ganzes Leben lang mit Menschen zusammengearbeitet die,
den Freihandel wie an eine Religion geglaubt haben und das war sehr sehr stark zu spüren als Trump Präsident wurde diese Haltung plötzlich aber wenn man das verknüpft mit einem Ziel Weltrettung nenne ich es einfach mal,
sind Zölle plötzlich in Ordnung und dann wird,
auch von der grünen Seite applaudiert.
Anpassungs.
Grenze Anpassungs.
Dieser grüne übergang wird zu neuen Chancen für Unternehmen führen.
Wir müssen daher in das europäische Potenzial für Innovation investieren 70 Jahren,
haben die Europäer investiert in Kohle und Stahl und es war auch eine historische Versöhnung die dadurch möglich wurde und auch ein Wirtschaftswunder die Lebensqualität für die Europäer wird wieder zunehmen.
Dieser übergang benötigt Zeit Unterstützung und Solidarität.
Seit sie das so sagt und sie wiederholt ja immer das räsoniert sehr stark mit mir und ich weiß noch nicht genau was ich davon halten muss aber bisher war ja auch in Deutschland immer so.
Die EU haben wir ja um einen Weltkrieg zu verhindern. Die EU ist die Antwort auf ein Weltkrieg.
Also immer dieses ganz große Bild und jetzt sagt sie der Gründungs Moment und es ist eben nicht nur ein Mythos sondern es ist ein echter faktischer Moment der Gründung,
Europas war diese Kohle und Stahl Union,
Kohle und Stahl und kriegt man das nochmal wiederholt aber nicht mit Kohle und Stahl sondern mit dem gleichen Anliegen Energie um etwas herstellen zu können also Kohle als Energielieferant und ein Stadiums zu bauen aber eben ohne Kohle und ohne Stahl also mit,
Wind und Holzer kennen wir noch eine neue EU hin mit Wind und Holz kann man die ganzen,
Vertrags Architektur Europas nochmal auf das neue Fundament stellen.
Wind und Holz statt Kohle und Stahl das ist ja sozusagen das finde ich ist nicht nur so dahingesagt Ersatz sondern das ist sozusagen echter Denk Auftrag und für die Politiker irgendwie ein Arbeitsauftrag.
Es ist erst mal der Ansatz zu einem großen Wurf den es bei Jean-Claude Juncker. Juncker gar nicht gab.
Zu einem ganz großen Wurf.
Ja er hatte so ein Investitionsprogramm von 350 Milliarden aber mehr um die Krise abzuwenden aber diesmal ist es halt wirklich genau.
Er hatte so ein Investitionsprogramm von 50 Milliarden aber mehr. Ja aber er hat es auch überhaupt nicht als so etwas verkauft. Das hier ist ja nochmal eine neue Gründungs Rede die sich fast.
Ganz genau und sie macht halt so dieses Kohle und Stahl Wir brauchen etwas Neues.
Und ich denke diese auch Signe Hayworth so starke eine Billionen Euro in den Raum.
Also finde ich das wirklich bedeutsam. Zwei kleine Clips noch die IWF-Chefin.
Die wollen wir nur kurz abhandeln denn sie hat was gesagt in dem 1920ern vorkommen da nur kurz nachrichtlich rein.
Bemerkenswert die Einschätzung der neuen IWF-Chefin Georgia zu möglichen Risiken der Weltwirtschaft. Sie ermunterte heute in Davos die Staaten schwachem Wirtschaftswachstum rechtzeitig mit Ausgabenprogramme sprich Konjunkturpaketen zu begegnen.
Das gerade beginnende Jahrzehnt erinnere in mancher Weise an die 1920er Jahre hohe Ungleichheit rasante Ausbreitung neuer Technologien und Risiken im Finanzsystem.
Gehen jetzt nicht im Detail nach. Aber bei ihr auch eine große alarmiert.
Offenbar um so eine Klammer zu schließen Wir haben vorhin die Neujahrsansprache gehört wie ist es jetzt mit wir gehen ja noch zum Ende zurück zu einem Politiker Donald Trump in Davos da wo er angeblich die großen Fragen geprügelt werden.
Wir müssen es aber aus dem Blickwinkel der Comedians die sich das angucken auch angucken.
Ich habe es mir komplett angesehen. Das ist ja komplett mit dem Jimmy Kimmel gewählt hat. Irgendwie Super.
Der Ausschnitt den Jimmy Kimmel gewählt hat den fand ich irgendwie super witzig.
Wunderschön. Aber wenn man mal vergleicht wie Politiker über den Sachstand reden und Journalisten es doch wirklich bezeichnend.
Einfach wenn man mal vergleicht wie Politiker über diesen Sachstand reden und Journalisten es doch wirklich bezeichnend deswegen schließen wir ja mal mit einem Clip.
Eine Sache.
Ich habe mich selbstverständlich komisch ist ein Desaster.
Ist selbstverständlich komisch und man kann sagen Das ist ein Desaster.
Und dennoch ist es ja so dass es.
Und dennoch ist es ja so dass.
Tatsächlich einen Aufschwung in den USA gibt es ist auch so dass.
Tatsächlich ein Aufschwung in den USA gibt es ist auch so dass die USA eine große Unabhängigkeit von.
Die USA eine große Unabhängigkeit vom öl aus arabischen Ländern hat sondern es geschafft hat sich da eine Souveränität was die Ressourcen anbelangt zu schaffen.
Arabischen Ländern hat sondern es eben geschafft hat sich da eine Souveränität was die Ressourcen geschaffen Co-Produzent.
Genau die sie auch davor schützt ständig die Weltpolizei spielen zu müssen weil solche ölinteressen sie leiten.
Also muss man jetzt auch zugute halten auch wenn man Trump nicht gut findet dass sich dort etwas bewegt und was für viele Politiker hier etwas irritierend ist,
irritierend ist dass dort jemand auftritt mit einer solchen souveränen Geste und sagt Ich hab das jetzt mal gemacht während wir lauter Politiker bislang erlebt haben außer jetzt die EU die ständig sagen Ja wir haben ein bisschen was erreicht,
und Trump ist aber jemand der mit merkwürdigen Maßnahmen und Steuererleichterungen von denen nur sehr wenige profitieren.
Aber er ist jemand der sehr große Schritte getan hat während wir hier eigentlich Politiker erleben die fast stolz darauf sind dass sie kaum etwas machen können.
Man darf allerdings nicht auf Trump reinfallen. Diese Steuererleichterung war ja immens.
Man darf allerdings nicht Steuererleichterungen.
Es geht hier um Billionen Trillion im amerikanischen Billionen im europäischen.
Heruntergebrochen auf 150 Milliarden Unternehmen zur Verfügung stehen.
Heruntergebrochen auf 150 Milliarden im Jahr die den Unternehmen zur Verfügung stehen dass sie dieses Geld auch benutzen um Lohnzahlung zu leisten und dann vielleicht auch mal was ausprobieren.
Was ausprobieren wenn man das vergleicht mit Bernie Sanders Programm nämlich reinzugehen zu sagen Wir investieren jedes Jahr 100 Milliarden in Infrastruktur nicht nur damit wir eine neue Infrastruktur haben sondern damit wir auch.
Das ist klar Wenn man das aber vergleicht mit Bernie Sanders Programm nämlich reinzugehen und zu sagen Wir investieren jedes Jahr 100 Milliarden in die Infrastruktur nicht nur damit wir eine neue Infrastruktur haben sondern damit wir auch Leute in Lohnarbeit haben die diese Infrastruktur teuer herstellen.
Leute in Lohnarbeit haben die diese Infrastruktur herstellen.
Die schafft genau diese zwei Komponenten die Trump eben nicht liefern konnte nämlich zum einen eine neue Arbeiterschaft die diese Infrastruktur hinstellt und eine neue Infrastruktur.
Die schafft genau diese zwei Komponenten die Trump eben nicht liefern konnte nämlich zum einen eine neue Arbeiterschaft die diese infrage stellt und eine neue Infrastruktur. Absolut.
Ich bin ja Sanders.
Naja bei Trump haben wir wirklich nur das Kapital ein bisschen mehr Kapital bei denen die schon Kapital haben weshalb die ein bisschen mehr Spielgeld haben.
Und natürlich wächst dadurch die Wirtschaft aber da kann man also wenn dieses Wirtschaftsmodell tatsächlich acht Jahre so gefahren wird wissen wir wie dieses wie diese 20er-Jahre ausgehen nämlich mit Amerika das wirklich bankrott ist.
Also das kann man sich nicht leisten nur in diesem Finanzbereich zu investieren indem man Geld aus dem Staat rausholt also sozusagen Handlungsmöglichkeiten der Regierung nimmt und keine neuen Arbeiter in eigene Arbeit bringt sondern nur,
Trippel down Modell.
Deswegen würde ich sagen Ja Trump hat sich jetzt gerettet.
Allerdings haben viele schon die Befürchtung dass es nicht einmal bis zum Wahltag reicht also nicht mal dieses Jahr bis November reicht.
Bevor da dann tatsächlich auffällt.
Ich würde sagen die paar Pluspunkte es bei Trump mehr an Themen die vorher wichtig waren,
beispielsweise beim Umgang mit diesen Legal Highs also Betäubungsmitteln und so weiter,
Arzneimittel Missbrauch der in Amerika unfassbare Ausmaße angenommen hat also 80 Prozent aller Schmerzmittel werden während in Amerika verabreicht ohne dass ärzte nochmal groß Diagnostik machen sondern die geben trägt das Rezept abhängig.
Da gibt es ein großes Interesse der Pharmaindustrie einfach die ganze Bevölkerung abhängig zu halten weil es unglaublich lukrativ ist.
Da kämpft also ein bisschen dagegen an und gegen illegale Drogen und so weiter.
Aber dieses in Amerika die Einwanderung so abzukupfern.
Dass man gar nicht mehr genau weiß wer erledigt dort eigentlich die Arbeit die bisher von Einwanderern gemacht wurde dann gar keinen neuen Arbeitsmarkt zu schaffen und ohne Infrastruktur auch nicht aufzubauen sondern sich nur an dieser Mauer und so weiter abzuarbeiten. Das ist,
im Grunde ist es Blasen. Seit 2008 werden da die Blasen aufgepumpt und Trump hatte da oben mal ein bisschen mehr Steuererleichterungen.
Und da kommt ein bisschen was unten an.
Zugleich ist es sehr transparent was er in Davos gemacht hat.
Man kann sich ja nicht darüber empören dass er weiß dass er durchaus zu schätzen.
Stimmt. Da sollte man sehr ehrlicher.
Ehrlichkeit mit Til Schweiger einer Meinung.
Ja man hört zu.
Man hört man hört so viel falsche Rede in Davos.
Da geht es immer um die Menschheit Familie und was weiß ich alles. Das stimmt ja alles nie und dann tritt dort jemand auf und sagt Ja ich vertrete amerikanische Interessen und ihr werdet noch sehen wie toll das ist. Es ist ja in Ordnung das so zu tun.
Grundsätzlich war die amerikanische Politik in den letzten Jahrzehnten nicht viel anders als das was Trump dort realisiert.
Wo ist das Problem.
Das verstehe ich nicht Man möchte eigentlich zu so einem diplomatischen sprechen das ist irgendwie zu unanständig wie Trump das formuliert aber an sich ist das nicht stark ab von Hillary Clinton vertreten würde.
Genau. Til Schweiger saß bei Markus Lanz und hat genau dieses Argument gemacht.
Trump mag zwar blöde sein aber er ist wenigstens ehrlich Er sagt es ganz einfach Argumente.
Man muss aber dazusagen in Davos sehen wir immer nur was auf der Bühne passiert und die Bühne war immer klar da guckt die Weltöffentlichkeit zu.
Das heißt der eigentliche Flurfunk in Davos findet jetzt auch auf der Bühne statt wenn auch erst mal nur bei Trump.
Aber die Kommunikationsarbeit also die Leute die da hinfahren nach Davos Die wissen schon eigentlich die sind jetzt nur ein bisschen überrascht dass es auch auf der Bühne jetzt so gesagt wird dass es eigentlich gar nicht so viel Verschiebung wie man immer glaubt aber für uns für uns Fussvolk.
Damit gucken von außen ist natürlich gut. Zum Abschluss Bananen,
Es gab eine große eine große Reportage bei PBS PBS Frontline machte aber irgendwie so große Reportagen und da ging es um das zerrüttete Amerika und die Banane.
Für diesen Film Vier Stunden lang interviewt dreieinhalb Stunden oder so. Und wir gucken uns die allerletzten Sekunden aus diesem Gespräch an.
Ist zweimal zweieinhalb Stunden ist absurd im Redefluss will unbedingt seine Botschaft loswerden und so weiter.
Das zweite Gespräch endet dann nochmal.
Diese Sachlage Wahlkampf in Amerika so wie folgt einschätzt.
Schleusung Social.
Schiess.
Re
Re Re tdw.
Trumps US-System,
Obama.
Barack Obama.
Sehr interessant.
Sehr genau wie wichtig die auch sein wird.
Es gibt da doch eine interessante Parallele.
Eine interessante Parallele die er zieht. Und das ist glaube ich auch so schön wenn man über diese wirtschaftlichen Zusammenhänge redet dann sieht man plötzlich ganz andere Bündnisse die sich auch tun oder.
Wenn man über diese wirtschaftlichen Zusammenhänge redet dann sieht man plötzlich ganz andere Bündnisse die sich auftun oder.
Verbindungslinien zum sich auftun die man sonst nicht so hat wenn man sich zum Beispiel auf dieses kulturelle Identitätspolitik.
Verbindungslinien zumindest die sich auftun die man sonst nicht so hat wenn man sich nur auf dieses kulturelle Identitätspolitik konzentriert dann sind die Lager ganz klar und eindeutig zu trennen.
Die Botschaft Die hat diese allerletzte Satz Ich rede da zweieinhalb dreieinhalb Stunden und der letzte Satz ist Obama war ein sehr Manea Establishment Figur,
wo man ja sagen muss Ja ich Obamas hier so eine Chiffre für Er war der letzte Präsident der diese Art von Politik machen konnte.
Er regt sich ja beinahe wahnsinnig darüber auf bzw. das ist ja dieser Anlass dass man so ein Präsident hat der ins Amt kommt und plötzlich aufhört zu twittern im Wahlkampf total aber plötzlich ausgetauscht im Establishment angekommen.
Und dann beginnt plötzlich die Worpsweder Elite rauszuhauen durch diese Erpressung also entweder eine Trillionen Dollar bis heute Abend oder die ganze Wirtschaft ist bankrott und in dieser Stimmung in der alle sehen,
die Elite wurde mal wieder rausgehauen Ich wurde vergessen beginnt da mit so einer Gesundheitsreform und knüpft das wichtigste Thema der Amerikaner ihre Gesundheit an den Staat auf eine Art und Weise wie es vorher nicht da war und.
Trägt das Argument aber gar nicht hin. Es geht ja gar nicht um den Staat sondern es geht eigentlich um dich.
Das Ding geht halt so durch. Aber wir sehen ja bis heute dass es für Nachwirkungen hat,
und wenn jetzt da und sagt Ich bin wahnsinnig froh dass erstens Clinton die Wahlen nicht gewonnen hat sondern Trump weil das auch bedeutet auf Trump folgt auch bei den Demokraten nicht Clinton sondern ein Populist.
Er mag was Elizabeth Warren sagt und gegen Bernie zu Bernie sagt er gar nichts und er sagt im Grunde alles.
Er wünscht sich so ein Typ wie Bernie der einfach mal ordentlich aufräumt und jetzt auch an die kleinen Leute denkt weil er dieses Argument die Millennials der.
Von ihm das kann man ihm die ganzen drei Stunden geht es nur darum dass die letzten zehn Jahre die Millennials überhaupt nichts abbekommen haben und man so aber keine Wirtschaft bauen kann weil die Alten mit ihrem Vermögen sterben.
Da gibt's ein bisschen Erbe und so Ja aber da ist nichts Konstruktives mal drin in dieser Wirtschaft.
Er will mit seinem populistischen Hebel aufbrechen und ihm ist völlig egal ob Trump oder Bernie macht.
Mein Eindruck gewesen der sich dieses Gespräch das dieses Gespräch führt ganz wunderbar in die 20er Jahre die wir damals haben. Welchen Clipper.
War mein Eindruck schon häufiger.
Die Kälte,
ist jetzt ein Star in der ökonomie.
Sie ist Vertreterin der modernen Monetary. Seit ein paar Jahren hat ein Interview der Süddeutschen Zeitung.
Zu gewissen ökonomischen Mythen und auch zu bei ihm aussieht. Vielleicht werden sich erinnern Trump hat während des Wahlkampfs immer gesagt Ja die Staatsverschuldung ist so hoch getrieben.
Hillary Clinton nannte ihn den König der Schulden. Aber er ist stolz drauf und hat dann auch mal in einer Fernsehsendung gesagt.
Beraterin für Sanders.
Aber sie weiß hier durchaus auch Trump in gewisser Weise zu loben.
Carlton Economic Topic.
Waldheims.
Places Surrogate das Budgetdefizit deckt ist ja.
Viel.
Geld.
Pritz Assets.
Trump Administration.
Trump Administration stärker als dafür,
als Problem. Er ist.
Benefiz Tageskarte,
Distribution,
von Trump dafür.
Fehlt derzeit in Flaschen ist anfahrenden,
Daniel Kahneman Employment Spending Nadjas Government Spending,
Tageskarte kriegste dafür sind Paulson,
Big.
Spender,
der dafür sitzt Medien.
Das ist ja auch so sagte rausholt Helikoptergeld. Helikoptergeld,
muss natürlich klug gemanagt werden dann sollte die Chefin wissen wie man Inflation misst und dann auch da handelt. Wenn es in Gefahr läuft.
Das ist kein Freibrief um einfach zu sagen Jetzt wird das Geld unters Volk geworfen.
Nicht Helikoptergeld da sind doch andere die Idee bei den Demokraten um Sanders eben diese Idee der Vollbeschäftigung,
sehr fasziniert ist diese Idee der Vollbeschäftigung ganz wunderbar erfolgen indem der Staat dann sagte ich stelle.
Vielleicht können Sie sich noch daran erinnern 1998 hat er Helmut Kohl mal die Statistik dass er 300 000 Wahlhelfer angestellt hat.
Dadurch sank auch die Arbeitslosenquote.
Solche Maßnahmen gibt's immer mal wieder auch aus anderen Gründen.
Aber das ist eben eine überlegung wie man es schafft eine Vollbeschäftigung herzustellen die dann aber zugleich dafür sorgt dass beispielsweise Infrastruktur aufgebaut erweitert wird oder dass grüne Projekte unterstützt werden.
Diese Idee ist dass der Staat Monopol hat und quasi das Geld drucken kann sogar so weit dass Sie sagen man kann im Prinzip,
gleich das Finanzministerium auf die Taste drücken lassen dass das Geld gedruckt wird.
Aber diese Unabhängigkeit die uns jetzt auch nochmal begegnen wird bei uns begegnet ist bei.
So etwas wie Preisstabilität oder mit schwarzer Null,
bei konservativen Auftritt muss man sagen ist eben ein Konstrukt aus der Zeit als man die Bundesbank gründete Ende der 50er Jahre als man sagte man löst,
die Banken ab von der Regierung damit nicht so etwas wieder passiert wie,
unter Hitler und zugleich,
aber schon so etwas wie der Neoliberalismus an dem man sagt,
Da soll die Politik jetzt mal nicht mehr Zugriff darauf haben denn wir können eigentlich die Geschichte des Neoliberalismus auch als eine begreifen wo,
die Politik ganz viel Macht abgibt an die Banken an Unternehmen eben an die Wirtschaft und nicht mehr primär,
durch die Finanzkrise erlebt dass es so eine Idee von einer Rückkehr der politischen ökonomie.
Und das hat man 2008 vorausgesehen aber sonst hat das kaum einer gesehen.
Durch den Green Deal durch,
dieses ganze Thema Klima erleben wir jetzt eine politische ökonomie wieder die ganz stark angetrieben von den Fragen des Klimaschutzes.
Erleben sie überall außer in Deutschland. Da haben wir nur Hans-Werner Sinn und so ein bisschen Marcel Fratzscher Natürlich.
In
Aber wenn man sich wirklich umschaut.
Deutschland.
Die Kelten wie sie heißt dann Börni.
Dann haben wir mit seinem Grundeinkommen übrigens das was du machst.
Michael Müller mit seinem solidarischen Grundeinkommen ist ja auch darauf ausgelegt die Leute ein bisschen aus der Arbeitslosigkeit statistik raus und in Bezug zu setzen.
Finanzierungsfragen.
Petty macht ja diese Krohne große Green Deal oder Green New Deal diese Finanzierungsfragen mit Varoufakis zusammen die Lenya so etwas wie monetäre Theorie als politisches Programm völlig Apnoe.
Sind.
Eigentlich sehr traditionelle Keynesianer.
Genau. Und dann gibt's natürlich noch Elisabeth Warren die einfach sagt Ich will den Kapitalismus der 70er Jahre zurück der es reichte wenn der Vater verletzt war und zu Hause bleiben musste dass die Mutter einen Job annimmt halbtags und damit wird dann die Wohnung bezahlt.
Dass das einfach reicht dieses Gefüge will sie wiederherstellen und ist darüber hinaus halt Ultra kapitalistisch sie sieht halt einfach das Silicon Valley das durch Monopole zerstört wird weil diese Unternehmen zerschlagen damit sie dann wieder machen können was sie wollen ohne dass die Politik hinschauen muss.
Da darf man jetzt nicht in so eine Falle tappen wie es die Deutschen gerne machen und so eine sozialistische Soße bei den Amerikanern sehen sondern dass es da zwischen Bernie und Elisabeth Warren liegen einfach Welten.
Er ist der Sozialist Green Deal Er will die hundert Milliarden Investitionen über den Staat also über Verschuldung.
Er will coole Leute verklagen da Verträge brechen sozusagen.
Die haben ja laufende Verträge und gleichzeitig riesig in die Staatsverschuldung gehen um Infrastruktur aufzubauen.
Das ist überhaupt nicht vereinbar mit dem was Elisabeth Varian will die will einfach nur den Ultra Kapitalismus aber in dem Rahmen einem ganz klaren Rahmen stattfinden kann,
Kopplung von Lohn Zahlung an die Produktivität und so weiter.
Aber das sind absolut absolute.
Bist du noch. Du bist immer noch warum ich natürlich nicht.
Ich will das gar nicht ideologisch bekunden sondern ökonomisch dass ich daran glaube dass man diesen Rahmen schaffen kann.
Gewissheiten Maxis.
Er ist zu einer Zeit geschaffen worden wo wir ganz starke Nationalökonomen haben wo der Freihandel lange nicht so ausgeprägt war wo wir ganz andere Strukturen haben und wie das jetzt wieder funktionieren soll.
Man könnte es schaffen aber nur mit einem wirklichen Staatssozialismus könnte man ein solches Programm durchziehen vielleicht noch auch mit so einem radikalen Sozialismus.
Wagenknecht argumentiert auch sehr keynesianische davor hat ist in meinen Augen relativ illusionär vielleicht ist es doch Augenwischerei dass sie wirklich glaubt dass man,
den Kapitalismus so einfach wieder an die Kette gelegt bekommt bzw. ja dann doch wieder ganz den Kapitalismus machen lässt.
Denn das widerspricht sich eben und der Kapitalismus tendiert zum Monopol der Kapitalismus tendiert dazu,
die Ungleichheit zu vergrößern denn nur dann steigen auch die Renditen und das ist gar nicht denkbar.
Aber da kommt dieses große aber was wäre denn wenn man sagt.
Aber was wäre denn wenn man sagt Mindestlohn 110 Dollar landesweit Untergrenze und Obergrenze ist das Milliardenvermögen 50 Millionen zwei Prozent pro Jahr.
Mindestlohn von 15 Dollar landesweit als Untergrenze und Obergrenze ist das Milliardenvermögen und ab 50 Millionen wird eben zwei Prozent pro Jahr rausgezogen aus diesem Vermögen.
Das sind zwei Grenzziehungen mit denen haben wir keine Erfahrung.
Das sind zwei Grenzziehungen mit denen haben wir keine Erfahrung. Könnte man aber einfach durch einen politischen Handstreich aber glaubst du dass man das will.
Die könnte man aber einfach durch einen politischen Handstreich Ja das könnte man.
Das hat sie ja gesagt. Mindestlohn 50 Dollar ist die Untergrenze landesweit oben.
Na das hat sie ja gesagt. Mindestlohn 110 Dollar ist die Untergrenze landesweit und dann oben diese Reichensteuer für die 50 Millionen sind frei und ab dem 50.
Diese Reichensteuer.
50 Millionen sind frei und ab 50 Millionen millionsten pauschal zwei Prozent und ab dann drei Prozent jährliche Abschöpfungen.
Und ersten millionsten pauschal zwei Prozent und ab einer Milliarde oder so. Dann drei Prozent jährliche Abschöpfung dieses Vermögens.
Die will sie aber abschöpfen um damit etwas zu finanzieren. Genau damit will sie den Sozialstaat finanzieren aber das sorgt ja weiterhin dafür dass die Ungleichheit wächst.
Den ganzen Sozialstaat. Alle Unis kostenlos und so weiter.
Nur weil oben zwei oder drei Prozent wegen mir auch fünf Prozent abgezogen werden wächst wird dadurch die Ungleichheit bald wachsen die proportional wenn man sich das mal anschaut.
Wir haben bei den 500 reichsten auf der Welt das hat Oxfam jetzt in der Studie veröffentlicht einen Vermögenszuwachs von 25 Prozent innerhalb eines Jahres.
Das heißt wenn die zwei Prozent oder drei abgeben müssen ist das nicht weiter tragisch und man muss dann auch sehen dass die Vermögen weiterhin nach oben so schnell wachsen.
Ganz.
Dann sind auch die 110 Dollar Mindestlohn ganz schnell null und nichtig bzw.
Sind auch wieder nur ein Hungerlohn.
Genau. Nein nicht ganz.
Der Preisdruck nicht nur für Lohnarbeit sondern insgesamt sorgt dafür dass im Supermarkt für 110 Dollar viel zu kaufen ist.
Da bleibt ja die Marktlogik soweit bestehen die Marktlogik bleibt insgesamt bestehen und das einzige Modell ist eben zu sagen,
Wir haben unten eine kontinuierliche Lohnzahlung und eine pauschale Abschöpfung um Corrida zu bilden der klarstellt nicht Trippel down sondern in dem Falle dann wirklich,
ab und steckt es unten als sozusagen garantierte Lohnzahlung.
Im Idealfall käme es ja gar nicht zu diesen großen Vermögens weil die vorher schon als Lohnzahlung ausgezahlt werden wenn es nicht dazu kommt dass staatlich organisiert.
Dass das Modell und das finde ich eben so beeindruckend an der Argumentation auch zu sagen,
so ein Modell also freie Marktkräfte Ultra Kapitalismus aber in diesen Staaten Schranken passt irgendwie zu Amerika und zwar viel mehr als dieser Bernie Sanders Sozialismus.
Aber das ist ja eine Illusion dass die Marktkräfte dann frei sind. Wir haben ja Märkte die aufgeteilt sind.
Ich verstehe auch nicht warum sie das Silicon Valley als.
Silicon Valley funktioniert. Was diese Konzernstrukturen anbelangt,
so wie fast alle großen Konzerne und Unternehmen die auch hier in Deutschland die Nazizeit prima überlebt haben nur sind sie eben sehr schnell gewachsen dort,
auch aufgrund gewisser Entwicklung oder auch an einem exponentiellen Wachstum das durch gewisse Fortschritte,
zustande gekommen ist.
Aber ich verstehe diesen Feind Silicon Valley immer weniger in Bezug darauf zu sagen Ja wenn wir die mal zerschlagen haben dann haben wir wieder einen guten Kapitalismus geschaffen.
Warum. Warum soll das so sein.
Was ist Google schlimmer als Springer-Konzern.
Das beschreibt sie im Detail und das ist auch ziemlich die gleiche Argumentation wie die beispielsweise von dem Herrn Wundt dem Kartellrechts Amtschef in Deutschland.
Bei Google. Es ist nicht allein die Größe sondern es ist dieser Mechanismus eine Marktmacht zu nutzen um damit sofort einen anderen Markt zu übernehmen.
Bei Google ist es nicht allein die Größe sondern es ist dieser Mechanismus eine Marktmacht zu nutzen um damit sofort einen anderen Markt zu übernehmen also beispielsweise die Suchergebnisse gleichzeitig.
Suchergebnisse gleichzeitig zu nutzen um.
Zu nutzen um und da muss Google in Deutschland auch diese Milliarden in Europa diese Milliardenstrafen zahlen um die Suchergebnisse gleichzeitig zu nutzen um Produkte zu promoten auf der eigenen Plattform zu kaufen also als Marktplatz und Marktteilnehmer gleichzeitig.
Produkte zu promoten.
Und Marktteilnehmer gleichzeitig proprietäre Märkte über die Digitalisierung geschrieben sehr gut bei Suhrkamp.
Digitaler Kapitalismus heißt das Dort beschreibt er das und er sagt damit ist ein Ende des Neoliberalismus gekommen weil man dann nicht mehr diesen quasi freien Markt auch wenn das immer schon ein schönes Märchen war aber,
auf jeden Fall gar nicht mehr.
Da hat sie natürlich recht. Aber zu glauben dass alles gut sei Ausbeutung im Kapitalismus gibt es ja immer noch der Kapitalismus lebt ja von der Ausbeutung und nur weil man da zwei Prozent abschöpft.
Also warum sollte das damit so viel besser werden. Es ist besser als nichts ist besser als das was jetzt passiert.
Derzeit ist der Modus ja wie folgt Börse in einem der 50 Bundesstaaten geboren,
und hast danach natürlich nicht die freie Wahl auf welcher Uni Du gehst weil nur deine Unis in seinem Heimatland solange sie staatlich organisiert sind erlauben dir für 10 000 Dollar zu studieren Sobald du den Bundesstaat verlässt und nicht irgendwo anders und so weiter auf eigene Faust.
Er kostet das 30 40 000 Dollar im Semester oder im Jahr jeweils kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an welcher Liga du damit spielen willst.
Und wenn man jetzt sagt man macht pauschal diesen Ausbildungsbereich kostenlos und das Geld dafür was man braucht nimmt man einfach von denjenigen die mehr als 50 Millionenvermögen haben.
Ist das eine ganz eins zu eins Transferieren von Geld ist eine richtige Umverteilung.
Da steckt gar keine weitere Komplexität dahinter als das was ich eben beschrieben habe es gibt eine allgemeine Steuerkasse aus der wird Output mäßig das Bildungssystem bezahlt und Input mäßig.
Einmal im Jahr allein weil Vermögens Bestände ermittelt werden abgeschöpft und mehr Raffinesse ist da gar nicht dahinter ist einfach nur dieses Modell und das sozusagen über die ganze Gesellschaft gesponnen.
Weil eben weil der Kapitalismus so funktioniert und zu diesem Monopol Bildung führt geht sie von oben rein und bricht das sind die Vermögens Akkumulation privat.
Da macht sich ganz pauschal mehr als 50 Millionen das es dann auch egal es muss ein Vermögenswert sein es muss kein Geld sein sonst reicht genauso Gebäude und notfalls muss man halt zwei Prozent seiner Liegenschaften verkaufen.
Also ganz hart kalkuliert weil es diese Grenzen braucht um gegen die Monopolisierung also die natürliche Tendenz des Kapitalismus anzutreten.
Ihr Modell ist das zu sagen Es ist im Grunde das am wenigsten revolutionäre Modell.
Mich wundert.
Sanders will die Revolution und sie sagt Ich habe gute Erinnerungen an die 70er Jahre.
Sie kommt mir dieser Nostalgie. Sie erklärte immer wie es damals war als sie hörte wie die Eltern darüber sprachen wie man das Haus jetzt hält. Und dann kommt auch ihre Erzählung.
Damals als ich dann gerade meinen ersten Lehrerberuf also mein ersten Lehrer Job hatte hatte ich plötzlich ein Kind und war alleinerziehend und nur weil meine Tante 80 Kilometer zu mir zog und zehn Jahre mit mir lebte konnte ich Lehrer bis hin zu Harvard-Professor werden.
Und sie will genau in diesem Modus wieder zurück. Und ich würde sagen wir lachen immer sehr über dieses nostalgische denken.
Aber wenn jemand in die 70er Jahre zurück will gleichzeitig mit allen Entwicklungen die wir heute haben.
Man muss einfach nicht abgeben und man kann auch mit einem Auto fahren.
Da würde ich sagen Das ist ein legitimes politisches Anliegen warum nicht. Es ist so einfach möglich bei Börni Revolution weiß man nicht.
Mich wundert das ein bisschen weil du eben so sehr beklagt hast.
Bei der deutschen Politik und auch generell dass so wenig Neues gewagt wird und nun fasziniert dich eine Frau die sagt Wir versuchen 15 Jahre wieder zurückzukehren und Bernie Sanders ist mir aber ein bisschen zu viel.
Weil das eben so viel Neues ermöglicht. Der Kapitalismus ist die Wachstums Maschine überhaupt die hat uns in 200 Jahren Geschichte von 800 Millionen Menschen auf der Welt zu acht Milliarden geführt.
Weil das eben so viel Neues ermöglicht. Also Der Kapitalismus ist die Wachstums Maschine überhaupt.
Die hat uns in 200 Jahren Geschichte von 800 Millionen Menschen auf der Welt zu acht Milliarden geführt.
Das sind nur 200 Jahre Geschichte die zu all dem führte zum Mondfahrt Raumfahrt Handys dem ganzen Kram bis vor 200 Jahren war das absolute stagnation Fettabbau.
Wir sind nur 200 Jahre Geschichte. Die Raumfahrt ist dem ganzen Kram.
Bis vor 200 Jahren war es absolute stagnation Fettabbau 60 Prozent der Leute haben.
60 Prozent der Leute haben irgendwie das Feld bestellt und die anderen waren haben Pferde und so weiter gemacht.
Diese 200 Jahre Geschichte die wir jetzt hatten waren durch diese kapitalistische Logik umso näher rankommen an einen funktionierenden Kapitalismus umso besser.
Diese 200 Jahre Geschichte die wir jetzt hatten waren durch diese kapitalistische Logik möglich und umso näher wir rankommen an einen funktionierenden Kapitalismus umso besser.
Aber wo funktioniert der Kapitalismus wir uns alle.
Elizabeth Warren für uns alle Du willst kein Bauer sein und ich will kein Schmied sein.
Für uns beide wie wir hier sitzen die Privilegierten aber mit Blick auf die Welt und mit Blick auf die Katastrophe mit Blick auf die wachsende Ungleichheit die,
im Namen des Kapitalismus geführten Kriege kann ich nicht sagen Der Kapitalismus funktioniert so prima.
Ich hoffe ja dass wir diese Debatte noch weiter fortsetzen und ich hoffe das wird der Kandidat denn sicher ist glaube ich. Wenn du jetzt mal ganz strategisch,
einzelne Inhalte präsentieren ein Duell Sanders Trump würde sehr wahrscheinlich für Sanders positiv ausgehen auch wenn sie sich von Clinton sehr deutlich unterscheidet.
Ähnliche Probleme in diesem Wahlkampf bekommen am Ende wäre,
es ganz lustig dass die Times,
ihre Unterstützung bekannt gegeben hat.
Die Leser Ja das ist ja auch irgendwie sehr schön zu sehen wie diese Zeitung sich nochmal Ausschwingen glaubt ganz wichtig zu sein.
Über was aber geredet geredet wurde war das sehr sehr erfolgreichen Podcast in den USA mehr oder weniger ist ein bisschen.
Schwach ausgedrückt aber doch eigentlich ist er für Sanders dem 7 Millionen Menschen regelmäßig Zuhören im Podcast der extrem einflussreich ist.
Sehr viele junge Wähler Leute die Sanders angewiesen sein wird.
Darüber wurde viel mehr gesprochen und das hat mich sehr amüsiert. Da sieht man auch wieder wie gewisse Gatekeeper immer noch glauben.
Ab
Vor allem was in dem Sinne sondern es war so klar isoliert klingt es dann entsprechend deutlich überlegen sprengende denken.
Sofort.
Wen würde ich wählen wenn jetzt morgen Wahl wäre und festgelegt.
Hunderte Artikel dazu während ein paar freundliche oder weniger freundliche Kommentare zu dem.
Den Modus der New York Times zwei Frauen überhaupt zwei Kandidaten vorzuschlagen.
Zwei Frauen nämlich klobiger und wollen das hat auch niemand verstanden weil auch in dem Modus wie vorhin besprochen,
Amy klobiger ist Vertreterin des Establishments kommt aus dem Senat als ja schon sehr auffällig und so weiter mit klarer Agenda und wirklich beeindruckender Geschichte.
Aber eben nicht mit. Wir brauchen entweder hier Revolution oder strukturell Change.
Die beiden sind gar nicht vereinbar also wenn dann muss man sich wenn man ihn dort mitmacht muss man sich wenigstens zwischen den beiden eigentlich entscheiden. Da kann man nicht beide.
Das geht eigentlich nicht deswegen war dieser Text ohnehin schwer zu verstehen.
Man konnte ihn wenn man ihn inhaltlich aufgreifen wollte immer nur so fragend eigentlich was sollen.
Man jetzt nicht ernsthaft sich mit den Inhalten auseinandersetzen. Denn na klar die zusammen und macht dann so einen politischen Text aus den kann man da lesen muss man aber nicht.
Aber es ist so. Es war also so ein bisschen aus der Zeit gefallen nicht ganz auf der Höhe der Diskussion.
Gerade weil man jetzt hier mal banal und wirklich so zeigt dass er da die Diskussion versteht weil er sie auch gerne stolz angetrieben hat und jetzt sozusagen Früchte einsammelt was das eigene Handeln angeht.
In der Hinsicht war dies nur ein bisschen Banane wobei Amerika ihm auch sagen diese Zeit es ist im Grunde vorbei weil wenn in den Bosman kommt reden alle nur drüber,
und finden es entweder gut oder nicht. Aber werden dadurch nicht umgestimmt es ändert.
Und da denke ich bei Rogan ist das etwas anderes nämlich dass es die Chance hat sehr viele unpolitische Hörer mit unpolitisch meine ich meine ich nicht dass diese Leute grundsätzlich nicht an politischen Dingen interessiert sind.
Aber nicht so klar Sich positionieren können Ja ich bin Sozialdemokrat.
Er hat also eine diffuse Gruppe was auch gefährlich sein kann die dann plötzlich anfängt den Vater und Gott so zu sehen aber dadurch dass er eben dieses unpolitische Publikum hat.
Toll sagt Bernie das scheint mir ein korrekter Typ zu sein und ich finde auch dass das ganz gut beginnt bei denen auch eine gewisse Politisierung dadurch eher,
den Effekt der dann eintritt dass man sagt Okay,
dann will ich den wohl auch unterstützen oder beschäftige mich zumindest mit dem was selbstverständlich bei der Times nicht mehr so stattfindet.
Dollar.
Jetzt haben wir ein Thema über das auch sehr heftig diskutiert wurde im Januar und auch ein Thema das uns noch die Wechselkurse begleiten Gesichtserkennung.
Heftig diskutiert wurde im Januar.
Das Thema Gesichtserkennung.
Da gab es eine Anhörung vor Tests wieder einmal. Aber ich will erst mal an etwas erinnern das vielleicht manche noch im Ohr sein könnte.
Dunkel.
Berger Das ist der Sohn von,
der Titelsong zur zweiten Staffel von Big Brother damals Zeig mir dein Gesicht zeigt mir wer du wirklich bist,
Big Brother kam ja mit diesem Versprechen Wir beobachten jetzt die Menschen mit der Kamera und dann zeigen sie ihr wahres Gesicht.
Hier gibt es keine Rollen hier gibt es keinen Scripted Reality wie man nachmittags Fernsehen erleben kann sondern die Leute wie sie wirklich sind und ein interessanter Effekt hat ja stattgefunden. Dass man.
Gesehen hat dort verhalten sich die Leute so wie sie sich verhalten aber sie verhalten sich nicht anders.
Durch die Kamera. Nicht viel anders.
Könnte es nicht sein dass die Menschen sich schon immer so verhalten als sei eine Kamera präsent.
Agieren wir immer sehr stark.
Was die Soziologie sehr beschäftigt. In welchen Kontexten wir auch welche Rolle annehmen.
Wir haben aber hier noch so eine Dystopie.
Eine Anspielung auf George Orwell. Diese Dystopie dass man permanent beobachtet wird ist aber inzwischen auch Teil unserer Realität.
Durch die überwachung die immer weiter ausgebaut wird die aber auch nochmal stärker wird durch diese Gesichtserkennung,
also Kameras in der Lage sind auch das Gesicht zu erkennen ist zuzuordnen das abzugleichen mit Profilen mit Daten die man über die Person hat was mich.
Fasziniert ist dass wir hier in den Zwanzigerjahren das Gesicht ist extrem wichtig für ganz viele Diskurse Diskurse in den 20er Jahren.
Dadurch dass das Kino ja dann seine erste Blütezeit erlebt ein sehr berühmtes Buch Der sichtbare Mensch,
von 1924 er als einer der Ersten eine Theorie des Films vorlegte und erst einmal,
den Film das Kino vom Theater abzugrenzen und die Unterscheidung zwischen,
Kino und Theater besteht darin dass wir im Kino Nahaufnahmen sehen können wir sehen ja auch Menschen wie man das im Theater sieht aber das Kino kann Nahaufnahmen zeigen,
und größer zeigen wie sie vorher wahrgenommen haben das heißt die Wahrnehmung verändert sich durch die Technik entscheidend auf das Gesicht so habe ich mein Gegenüber noch nie gesehen. Ich habe noch nie ein Gesicht gesehen.
Acht Quadratmeter großes Kino kann ich es erleben. Das verändert nicht nur das Schauspiel sondern verändert auch unsere Selbstwahrnehmung.
Man hat herausgefunden niemand,
ändert sich das kosmetische Verhalten der Menschen als sie anfangen ins Kino zu gehen Sie frisieren sich schminken sich wie die Stars die sie auf der Leinwand sehen.
Ich will einen kleinen Auszug Vorlesen aus Der sichtbare Mensch.
Schon mit der Auswahl der Schauspieler dichtet der Filmregisseur und gibt seinen Gestalten die entscheidende die wesentliche,
Substanz auf dem Theater bekommt der Regisseur seine Figuren und Charaktere im Text des Dramas fertig und hat nur einen Darsteller zu suchen der dem Bild das die Worte des Dramas geben entspricht.
Auf dem Theater charakterisieren die Figuren sich einander mit ihren Worten auf dem Film ist es ihr Aussehen welches vom ersten Moment an ihren Charakter bestimmt,
was er hier beschreibt ist was wir bis heute im Kino erleben nämlich eine Typ Besetzung.
Jemand der Böse ist soll böse aussehen.
Da gibt es dann auch gewisse rassistische Traditionen welche den bösen ist oder denken wir an die James-Bond-Filme die Bösewichte russisch aussehen sollen und oft gar keine Russen sind sondern von Deutschen gespielt werden.
Aber er spricht auch davon dass der Charakter diesen Begriff konnte man damals noch in den 20er Jahren eine andere Konnotation verwenden als man das heute tun würde.
Entscheidend ist dass der sich im Gesicht deutlich macht.
Das ist auch.
Sehr virulent wird in den 20er Jahren die Physiognomie Leere die ja sehr weit zurückliegt die eigentlich im 18.
Jahrhundert begründet wird durch Lavater auftaucht.
In den 20er Jahren durch die neuen kriminologischen Techniken wie kann man eigentlich Menschen katalogisieren kann man Menschen daran erkennen dass sie ihnen am Gesicht ablesen ob sie Verbrecher sind oder,
ein Verbrechen zu begehen bis hin zur Rassenlehre die dann immer prominenter wird dass man plötzlich,
die Menschheit immer an Typen.
Man glaubt dass es Menschen sind weil sie zu einer Rasse gehören und das ist etwas was sich sehr stark breitmacht in den Zwanzigerjahren worauf die Nazis dann auch zurückgreifen werden.
Das ist aber noch zum Teil ein sehr unschuldiger Umgang damit.
Es gibt ein Buch das.
Na ja aber Sigmund Freud hat ja damals auch bevor er sozusagen die Menschen in 1000 Stunden Sitzung in den Kopf gekrochen ist fing er auch an zu vermessen den Kopf zu vermessen und daraus aber wirklich alles abzuleiten.
Ob das damals schon so unschuldig war. Klar im Vergleich zu heute mit dieser technischen überbauungen. Aber so ganz unschuldig.
Nie.
Unschuldige jemand wie August Sander ein Fotograf.
Der Zeit verschiedene Typen eine Typisierung findet.
Das sind die Jungbauern. Der alte Bauer und er wollte eigentlich ein Gesellschaftspanorama auf,
Fotografien.
Diese Idee ob man für einen gesellschaftlichen Stand typische Gesichter so eine große Angst vor kollektiv Gesichtern,
in der modernen Welt in der Großstadt wo alles durcheinander läuft da verlieren die Gesichter ihre eigene Charakteristik dort gleichen sie sich an und man kann sie nicht mehr voneinander unterscheiden.
Diese kulturkritische Ausprägung dann gibt es eben auch die ganz dezidiert rassistische Ausprägung.
Man sieht an diesem Gesicht an und das deutet darauf hin.
Dass dieser Diskurs kommt. Es gibt ein sehr sehr gutes eine sehr gute Studie die ich nur kurz empfehlen will von Roland Meier operative Porträts.
Da wird auf 400 Seiten die Geschichte von der Gesichtserkennung und der Typisierung erklärt und er fängt an im 18.
Jahrhundert bei Lavater ins neunzehnte Jahrhundert mit kriminalistischen Studien die,
zu den 20er Jahren weiter in den 60er Jahren wo Andy Warhol auch so eine Reproduzierbarkeit von Gesichtern in seiner Kunst vorführt.
Er hat immer wieder sich ein neues Antlitz versuchte anzunehmen Meinhof war mal dicker mal dünner schnitt vor der Kamera wenn sie dann mal in Haft war damit man ihr Gesicht nicht wiedererkennen kann.
Horst Herold der ja damals der,
Polizeipräsident BKA-Chef war der.
Alexa Wer war Horst Herold.
Horst Herold war ein deutscher Jurist und von 1971 bis 1981 Präsident des Bundeskriminalamts.
In dieser Funktion wurde er zu einer Symbolfigur der Terrorismusbekämpfung in der Bundesrepublik der 1970er Jahre insbesondere im Zusammenhang mit den ATT.
Alexa.
BKA-Chef.
BKA-Chef der versucht hat Strategien zu entwickeln wie man Gesichter erkennen kann beziehungsweise wie man mit Adressen mit Gesichtern verbinden kann.
Bis hin zu Facebook wo wir ja auch das Gesicht schon im Namen haben wo wir sehen.
Da spricht er dann von operativen Porträts bei Gesichtern sonst immer ganz stark so eine Idee der Repräsentation.
Ich will ein Beispiel nennen aus der Zauberflöte,
das Porträt als Repräsentation.
Dies Bildnis ist bezaubernd schön wie noch kein Auge,
Tamino in der Zauberflöte Ich habe meine Aufnahme von 924 herausgesucht. Da sieht man da,
das Radio. Und dann werden auch Aufnahmen immer wichtiger.
Hier haben wir also eine Figur die da steht ein Bildnis von einer Frau sieht also die Repräsentation einer Frau und sich in die Repräsentation verliebt und diese dann auch am Ende der Oper trifft.
Da haben wir noch die Repräsentation und der Unterschied dazu ist das operative Bild hier ist das Gesicht in erster Linie Informationsträger.
Das sehen wir jetzt durch diese Entwicklung der Gesichtserkennung dass man nicht mehr sagt ist ein Bild des repräsentierten Steffan sondern ein Bild von deinem Gesicht Stefan und das soll mir,
Aufschluss darüber geben Bist du glücklich.
Das glauben ja manche Gesichtserkennung sagen zu können gehörst du.
Wie alt bist du. Wo wohnst du bist du vermögend oder zeichnet sich an deiner Haut irgendetwas ab was darauf schließen lässt dass du vielleicht einen ungesunden Lebensstil.
Wir sehen das gerade wieder in China Corona Man macht eine IBA Messung indem man das unverhüllte Gesicht denn das Einzige was unverletzt bleibt ist das Gesicht am Flughafen einfach mal kurz und wärmer Kamera ausleuchtet und guckt ob da jetzt,
lila leuchtet. über siebenunddreißig gerade oder nicht.
Ich erinnere mich auch gerade weil du auch Repräsentation ist ja total entscheidend.
Bevor man irgendwie dazu kam biometrische Bild in Personalausweis und so weiter die Passagiere und deren Papiere zu unterscheiden aber immer so führen diese Form der Repräsentation.
Als ich damals Soziologie studiert und ein bisschen zu den Historikern rüber ging da hatten die einmal das thematisiert wie man im alten Rom.
Als es noch eine klare Grenze zwischen Bürgern und Bürgern gab und so weiter wie man die Bürger auch in Abwesenheit repräsentiert hat indem man nämlich ihre Büste mitnahm.
Es gab Prozessionen wo man entweder seine eigene Büste mitnimmt aber es konnte auch jemand anders in deinem Namen vorstellig werden indem er,
nicht das Foto sondern wirklich den Klopfenstein einfach mitnahm von Zuhause und meinte hier ich bin in Vertretung von diesem Stein hier,
ich repräsentiere eine Das zeigt so ein bisschen dieses Gesicht als auf der einen Seite dieser große Emotions Träger unverhüllte war.
Die Diskussion über Gesichts Verhüllung in Europa sind ja nun auch sehr virulent und politisch sehr aufgeladen.
Aber dieses Gesicht kriegt man nicht versteckt und es scheint so eine tausendjährige Geschichte länger Rom Zweitausend Jahre Geschichte zu geben.
Das Gesicht tatsächlich als Modell als Figur sozusagen immer da zu haben und dieser Repräsentation und Gedanke ist wirklich alt.
Jetzt kommt aber eben dieser operative Gedanke dazu dass wir mit dem Gesicht einen Link haben zu einer Person.
Für eine Rasterfahndung so dass Otto Schily schon als er noch Innenminister war sagte als es um die biometrischen Pässe gegen die Pässe sind auch ein Wirtschaftsfaktor.
Wir zeigen dass Deutschland das Know how und die Innovationskraft hat um im jungen Sektor Biometrie Standards zu setzen.
Und dann gab es auch gleich eine Studie der Europäischen Kommission Biometrie Frontiers.
Da sprach man davon dass man mit dieser biometrischen Erkennung an Grenzen an Flughäfen für.
Effekte sorgt das bedeutet Man gewöhnt die öffentlichkeit erst bei Grenzkontrollen an Biometrie und Kameras und Gesichtserkennung und all das,
und später kann man dann sehr gut zu einer kommerziellen Anwendung kommen weil die Leute das dann als etwas,
Vernünftiges Normales ansehen.
Wir haben vielleicht heute auch etwas das man sich so bewusst macht wie stark eigentlich die Gesichtserkennung schon vorangeschritten ist bzw. wie groß die Datensammlungen schon sind in denen wir wahrscheinlich alle vorkommen.
Es gab dazu eine Anhörung und Alexander Cortés die jetzt eine Expertin dazu befragt wie weit ist dann mit der Gesichtserkennung.
Brad.
Pitt Tanzshow.
In China exekutiert bei.
Facebook.
Bei Facebook,
Wikipedia,
Snapchat.
Ido.
Die wie soll man sagen. Wenn du Mitglied eines Unternehmens wärst das daraus Gewinn schlagen könnte das ist,
der Drang es zu machen ist so groß weil es so einfach ist und gleichzeitig so lukrativ.
Wir werden ja im Salon nach diesen Texten der New York Times lesen in dem es auch noch mal beschrieben wurde,
wie schnell die Behörden 600 Behörden in Amerika darauf ansprang dass die Möglichkeit bestand fernab einer juristischen Grundlage wohlwissend es trotzdem zu machen.
Sobald die Möglichkeiten da sind der Ansicht ist dass eine Technologie die wenn man sie als negativ bewertet tatsächlich einfach nur ächten kann im Sinne von gar nicht einsetzen anstatt nur irgendwelche Spielereien damit zuzulassen und sei es nur,
die Ansammlung von Instagram,
Datensätzen Facebook-Daten sitzen und so weiter und so fort.
Ich finde auch dass sie beides beleuchtet.
Autoritäre Staaten sind.
Zumindest in der westlichen Welt zusammen während wir bei China ganz stark,
Staatskapitalismus dafür sorgt dass diese Unternehmen gebunden sind.
Müssen eigentlich sehen immer mehr und das ist vielleicht auch eine Tendenz die wir in den zehn Jahren wie wir uns hier unterhalten werden beobachten können.
Das Vorbild scheint mir immer mehr China zu sein.
Was die Regierungskunst anbelangt das man dort hinschaut ist ja schlimm Es gab ja auch,
relativ viele Berichte darüber wie weit diese Social Credit Verfahren schon ist und was das für eine Einschränkung bedeutet oder für eine überwachung man aber dann sagen kann,
dass wir Teile davon übernehmen und das ist ja immer etwas sehr sehr schleichendes. Und wenn es dann mal.
In
Die Hände von Flüchtlingen geht um herauszufinden wie alt sie wirklich sind macht sich da vielleicht ein 18-Jähriger zum 16-Jährigen aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Das heißt der Körper durchleuchtet und da gibt es in der breiten Bevölkerung einen ganz großen Zuspruch Ja das ist ja auch wichtig dass die uns nicht anlügen.
Aber genau das sind immer dann die ersten Schritte dorthin dass man,
flächendeckend solche Techniken für irgendetwas einführt und bei der Gesichtserkennung haben wir ja auch ein wunderbares Narrativ Terrorismusbekämpfung deswegen müssen wir das machen.
Zugleich hat man Gesichtserkennung die sich prima ausweitet dann auf den gesamten öffentlichen Raum und alle zu Verdächtigen macht.
Man darf man nicht unterschätzen wenn man in Deutschland wenn in Deutschland was man hört so eine Nachricht in München gab's eine Schlägerei in der U-Bahn und da kriegt man so ein Bild vorgelegt schwarz weiß irgendwie aus drei Ecken und man erkennt im Grunde nichts.
Und das führt dann immer so ein bisschen in die Versuchung zu sagen Ja es ist eine Technik die so nicht richtig funktioniert wenn man sich.
Anschaut wie diese Kameras funktionieren die interessieren sich ja nicht dafür das Gesicht so zu sehen wie wir sondern werden mit Kontrast gearbeitet mit Farbe und so weiter und so Spektralfarben Analysen.
Man hat ja jetzt schon in Handys die Möglichkeit eine vierte,
Kamera Modul das nur schwarzweiß fotografiert um nochmal mathematisch Material zu liefern das Bild schärfer zu machen weil diese kann man nur dafür da Kontraste zu rechnen.
Die wertet einfach nur Graustufen gegeneinander aus und bringt damit eine eine Tiefenschärfe hin.
Also nicht Teamchefin Tiefenschärfe sondern eine einen tiefen Einblick in eine Fotografie die man sich menschlich gar nicht vorstellen kann als braucht man gar nicht diese Art von Information genau wie beim Messen mit Werbe,
Kameras oder Samsung zum Beispiel macht ja immer noch eine optische Gesichtserkennung wenn sie dich fragen Bist du denn der Handy.
Apple macht ja nach einer Weile schon diese 30.000 die da Radames sich auf dein Gesicht gestreut werden.
Apple lernt ja durch jedes entsperren das Gesicht immer neu kennen da Mimik einfach dazu kommt.
Dieser Datenschatz an unterschiedlichen mimischen desselben Gesichts ist sozusagen unendliche Bandbreite Yuval Noah Harari war auch in Davos um seinen 20 Minuten Standard Vortrag über die Herausforderung des 21.
Jahrhunderts zu halten hat dort auch die technische überwachung so eine Frage an das Plenum gestellt.
Glauben Sie Kim Jong Un würde sich der Technik verweigern seine eigene Ansprache per Smartphone an die Leute zu Hause zu senden und gleichzeitig eine Gesichtserkennung laufen zu haben.
Ob die denn wirklich glauben was ich ihm sage oder ob sie es mir noch vorspielen oder an einem Morgen sind einfach weg.
Bei denen man einfach nachgemessen hat Pulsschlag Pulsschlag misst man schon seit fünf Jahren bei Kindern zum Beispiel einfach optisch.
Da wird einfach der Kontrast so richtig auseinandergezogen sodass man kleinste Farb Veränderungen im Gesicht sieht.
Und dann kann man in Baby Bett nicht nur das Kind schlafen sehen sondern man kann auch den Puls sehen weil die kleinste Veränderung des Tons wenn das Gesicht das Blut gerade rein strömt wieder raus und rein und raus.
Das kann man einfach sehen. Diesen Impuls diese kleine Veränderung kann man einfach wie unter einem Mikroskop richtig deutlich machen.
Und dann kann man während man im Wohnzimmer sitzt auf einem Bildschirm sehen mit welcher Herzfrequenz das Kind gerade schläft.
Der technische Rahmen ist so unmöglich groß. Die Frage ist Wie weit treibt man.
Da kann man auch nicht sagen wenn mal in guten Händen ist kann nie in guten Händen sein.
Das wird auch deutlich wo sie nicht in guten Händen ist wenn wir uns noch Russland ansehen da gab es einen,
Bericht im Weltspiegel darüber eine Messe dort ist der Reporter wo es um überwachung und Gesichtserkennung geht auf dieser Messe.
Auf einer Messe für Sicherheitstechnik in Moskau. Der aktuelle Trend Gesichtserkennung viele russische und chinesische Hersteller sind da.
Er hat mich schon erkannt. Das System als Pörtner. Wer gespeichert ist darf rein.
Erstellt wird ein biometrische Modell. Die Kamera vergleicht dann Punkte im Gesicht mit dem Modell nebenan. Der Verkäufer trägt eine Body Cam an seiner Brusttasche.
Messebesucher werden ungefragt aufgezeichnet. Die Polizei könnte sie im echten Leben mit einer Datenbank vergleichen.
Er verwendet diese Systeme. Das kann im Stadion sein. An einem öffentlichen Ort im Bahnhof.
Ich finde das sehr nützlich wenn man am Eingang Leute herausfiltert die eine Bedrohung darstellen. Das macht mich glücklich.
Jetzt sehe ich hier unten unter dem Welt die Informationen über mich.
Da steht zum Beispiel dass ich eine Brille habe mit 99 Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich wirklich aussehe.
Allerdings nur mit einem Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit da ist er sich nicht so sicher dass sie auf ungefähr 30 geschätzt werde.
Ein schönes Kompliment. Und,
mein Gesicht ist sowieso überall. Wenn sie rüber zur Metro laufen 20 000 Kameras da werden sie hundertprozentig gefilmt.
Wenn ein Polizist sie finden müsste könnte ja auch 20 000 Videos durchschauen. Mit diesem System geht das aber deutlich schneller.
Ja eben nicht dass man das Schwachsinns Argument.
Mehr als 170000 überwachungskameras gibt es in Moskau etwa 3000 können schon Gesichtserkennung. Bald sollen es alle sein.
Mehr als 3000 Verbrechen wurden vergangenes Jahr so aufgeklärt.
Auf einer Messe für Sicherheitstechnik in.
Horst Seehofer zwar etwas zurückgerudert was Gesichtserkennung anbelangt total verworfen.
Nee hat sie nur durchs Parlament bringen und danach wieder einzubauen.
Weil er weiß wie die Diskussion läuft und es gab natürlich nur Geheimtext und so reagieren natürlich auch die entsprechenden. Es gibt ja auch gute Lobbyisten entsprechend ist weil wir meinten die guten Hände Technik in guten Händen.
Man muss es sich tatsächlich so vorstellen wie den Ring in Lord of the Rings.
In dem Moment wo du diese Technik ist verwandelt sich deine Hand in so tiefschwarz böse weil du kannst dem nicht widerstehen.
Egal welches Anliegen Du hast. Sicherheit schlägt dann immer über die Stränge.
Es ist einfach zu reichhaltig. Es kommt einfach zu viel warum.
Aber das hört man am Ende dieses Berichts noch vom Weltspiegel.
Es wird beschrieben dass auch jetzt schon solche.
Hecken auf überwachungskameras die Leute selbst am Haus haben und dort auch Bilder abgreifen.
Generell wird dann berichtet was alles noch so alles abgegriffen werden kann.
Und dann heißt es am Ende des Berichts würde es in Deutschland Protest geben und das glaube ich nicht.
Wir erleben ja immer dass das eigentlich vollkommen egal ist dann kommt irgendwann dieser dümmste Satz Ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen aber es hat ja bis auf ein paar kleine Gruppen oder datenschutzrechtlicher,
hat sich ja nie jemand empört über all das was so in den letzten Jahren stattgefunden hat.
Was ich auch nicht wusste 2001 beim Superbowl gab es schon Gesichtserkennung da hat man das einfach mal getestet in dem Stadion wo sie alle saßen hatte aber vorher niemandem Bescheid gesagt und auch da ist nicht viel Größeres passiert das,
man auch ganz bewusst immer mal wieder ein paar Gesetze und Grenzen.
Es ist ja nicht so schlimm denn.
Beim Superbowl steht halt auf einer Eintrittskarte. Sie sind im öffentlichen Bereich im Fernsehen übertragen wird sie werden hier auch gefilmt.
Genau das bedeutet dann auch Gesichtserkennung.
Nur genau die Frage ist dann Wie muss man eigentlich erklären wie man gefilmt wird dass man die ganze Zeit gefilmt wird ist natürlich ungewöhnlich. Auf der anderen Seite Wenn du als Prominenter im Stadion bist wirst du die ganze Zeit gefilmt. Da ist einfach klar was du da.
Ja
Genau. Aber das ist vielleicht doch ein Unterschied den wir machen können weil das auch bei Seehofer immer wieder ist.
Naja wenn ich irgendwo her geht werde ich auch gesehen und werde ich auch erkannt.
Die meisten Menschen sind hier nicht Personen des öffentlichen Lebens.
Also ich kann natürlich nicht auf die Berlinale gehen und sagen Ich möchte aber nicht erkannt werden.
Da wird man mich hin und wieder erkennen.
Aber die meisten Menschen werden anonym sich durch eine Stadt bewegen und das ist ja auch eine ganz große.
Überhaupt die Bedingung für Freiheit dass man auch ungesehen sich irgendwo aufhalten kann was nicht bedeutet dass man nicht durch Zufälle auch auf jemanden treffen kann.
Man ist eigentlich dabei sich mit einem Seitensprung zu treffen und dann noch jemand über den Weg.
Das kann selbstverständlich passieren aber es ist etwas anderes ob ich das in einer so systematischen Form habe also eine moralische Komponente Die Frage ist ja immer so hat man ein Anspruch auf Freiheit.
Beim Seitensprung hat das so eine moralische Komponente Die Frage ist ja wirklich immer wieso hat man so einen Anspruch auf Freiheit Das Problem ist in dem Moment wo du erkannt wirst als jemand begegnet du nicht mehr einer unschuldigen Welt sondern ließ auf dich zugeschnitten.
Das Problem ist in dem Moment wo du erkannt,
begegnet du nicht mehr einer unschuldigen Welt dies es auf dich zugeschnitten.
Also wenn du mit 50 000 Monatseinkommen zu Rewe gehst und dann plötzlich die Preis anzeigen 30 Prozent höher als bei jemand anders.
Also wenn du mit 500 000 Monatseinkommen zur Rewe gehst und dann sind plötzlich die kleinen Display den Preis anzeigen 30 Prozent höher als bei jemand anders.
Online interessiert das weniger wird auch nicht groß dokumentiert wie Amazon mit Preisen spiele.
Online interessiert das weniger und es wird auch nicht groß dokumentiert wie Amazon mit Preisen spielt die wissen ja genau wer da kommt da 500 Signale werden irgendwie aus genau Hotelbuchungen welche Wer kriegt welche Preise beim Flüge buchen und beim Reisen.
Die Signale werden nicht irgendwie Hotelbuchungen auch sehr interessant.
Umbuchung welche wirklich welche Preise bei Gebühren und Preisen.
Dieser Zuschnitt dieser dieses ökonomische Gefängnis in dem die plötzlich drinsteckt das ist nicht mehr allgemeine Marktkräfte sind sondern sie auf dich zugeschnitten werden das ist das Problem.
Dieser Zuschnitt dieser dieses ökonomische Gefängnis plötzlich drinstecken.
Es ist nicht mehr allgemein die Marktkräfte sind sondern sie auf dich zugeschnitten werden. Das ist das Problem.
Und wir haben ja von Merkel gehört die Technik hat den Menschen zu dienen.
Wir haben ja von Merkel gehört die Technik hat den Menschen zu dienen.
Deshalb würde ich die Frage welchen Menschen weil sie den Menschen dienen die Frage ist nur allen oder nur einer Klasse von da muss man als Eigentümer sagen.
Auf die Frage welchen Menschen den Menschen dienen fragen Ja oder Nein klasse fanden wir Eigentümer sagen sie ist ja nicht die Kapitaleigner.
Weil sie es ja nicht die Kapitaleigner sondern im Grunde auch technischen Kapitaleigner.
Doch schon die die die Produktionsmittel haben denn das ist sehr teuer diese Technik zu entwickeln und das Militär ist sehr lange dabei aber gute Vorarbeit die erst mal geleistet wurde ist ja eine die.
Auch nicht mehr.
Genau. Ich war ja überrascht. Ich habe damals noch 2013 oder 14 so eine F.A.Z.
Mal so ein Text geschrieben da hat jemand in Amerika eine überwachungs Drohne gebaut die 50 Quadratkilometer auf einmal überwachen kann.
Also wurde wirklich mit einem Adleraugen oben nicht mit dem Hubschrauber dem Auto folgen sondern das Ding bleibt einfach da oben stehen und du kannst trotzdem dem Auto folgen weil das werden noch 30 Minuten und du bist trotzdem noch im Range und der hat die Kamera einfach so gebaut dass er sich diese.
Zwei Megapixel Chips aus den ersten Handys nahm Stückpreis waren irgendwie 35 Cent oder so.
Dann hat er aber Tausende von diesen kleinen Sensoren verbaut und dann einfach ein Objektiv drüber geschnallt das die Auflösung hinbekommt.
Da hat Giga Pixel Kamera mit Megapixel Chips gebaut die im Stückpreis verschwinden geringer also die die Fluc Apparatur war damals noch sehr viel teurer als die Kameratechnik Heute ist beides wahnsinnig billig,
wenn man immer erklärt bekommt Wir bräuchten mal ne Seenotrettung überwachung des Mittelmeeres oder so.
Wir wissen nicht in welchem Auto saß eigentlich welcher iranische Politiker.
Nee das ist auf den Zentimeter genau bekannt. Und da sitzen auch Leute da gucken Sie sich das live an und wenn ein Flugzeug abgeschossen wird dann gucken sich das auch Leute live an.
Aber diese Möglichkeiten gerade in diesen Gebieten der Welt sind einfach die komplette überwachung kriegt man aber nie zu sehen Man kriegt dann CNN Bilder wenn das mal so nachgebaut wird in der Visualisierung obwohl es da viel bessere Live-Bilder gibt von solchen Momenten.
Also Man verschleiert auch immer noch sehr wie weit die Technik ist und über die Preise der Hersteller muss man heute wirklich nicht mehr reden weil das ist einfach das Budget ist nicht mehr auf solch eine überwachungstechnik ist einfach.
Die Frage ist also Wie werden wir mit unserem Gesicht umgehen Eine Möglichkeit ist Botox ist auch eine Möglichkeit das Gesicht stillzulegen.
Einen anderen Ausdruck anzunehmen sich quasi vor der Lesbarkeit des Gesichts zu schützen.
Kann man ja gleich bei der.
Eine andere Möglichkeit um diesen Themenkomplex abzuschließen Wer eine philosophische Antwort darauf Slavoj žižek gibt und zwar einen Auszug aus,
Hollywood wo er eine Dokumentation mit verschiedenen Hollywood-Filmen auseinander unter anderem auch mit Vertigo von Alfred Hitchcock.
Da geht es darum dass sich ein Mann in eine Frau verliebt die dann stirbt und er findet eine Frau die der ersten sehr ähnlich sieht und,
erwartet dann von ihr dass sie sich wieder verwandelt als die die vulgäre Judy ist.
Ein paar ganz fundamentale Dinge die uns vielleicht auch irritieren werden.
Ich wollt.
Viel in der.
Lücking.
Ich habe mich.
Radikal.
Das Gesicht.
Was er gesagt hat das Gesicht dahinter ist ein Nichts.
Hinter dem Gesicht ist ein großes Nichts. Aber wenn wir jemand anderem begegnen wir gleich mit unseren Fantasien.
Das bezieht sich auf,
keinen Geschlechtsverkehr sondern Wir schlafen mit jemand anders nicht sondern mit unserer Fantasie die wir von dem anderen haben.
Das Gesicht ist deswegen sehr interessant und es ist sehr schön gelöst dass man nur zur Hälfte sieht in den entscheidenden Szenen.
Eine Idee irgendetwas dahinter könnte aber,
auch sehr kritisieren diese Idee überhaupt die dieser ganzen Physiognomie Leere und Gesichtserkennung zugrunde liegt dass man im Gesicht überhaupt etwas Entscheidendes ablesen kann,
außer vielleicht wenn jemand eine Hautkrankheit hat oder dass man ablesen kann dass Subjektivität nochmal etwas,
ganz anderes ist und dass das auch Postmoderne,
nichts zu tun haben wenn wir dem gegenüber eine,
intuitive feministische Andeutung indem er sagt Männer,
erwarten von Frauen dass sie so aussehen Das bedeutet Männer haben selbst keine.
Subjekte sondern brauchen die Frau um ihre männliche Subjekte bestätigt zu bekommen. Das.
Heißt dass die Frau ist deswegen auch ständig verlieren.
Das bedeutet dann für ihn dass nur Weiblichkeit die tatsächliche subjektiv.
Ist. Das ist aber eine überlegung die zunächst einmal sehr philosophisch verstiegen wirkt.
Andererseits kann man sich mit einem solchen philosophisch,
philosophischen Pirouette ein bisschen raus aus dieser,
Idee dass wir jetzt durch die Gesichtserkennung die sicherlich hochproblematisch ist wirklich,
lesbar sind sondern wir können sagen Wir sind sehr viel mehr als unser Gesicht und wir sind sehr viel mehr als das was Maschinen auslesen können denn wir dürfen nicht auf diese,
Prämisse hereinfallen die von,
Wissenschaftlern oder auch diesen Industriezweigen immer so stark gemacht Mensch ist gleich und dann ist er entweder wie ein Computer oder ein Gesicht eigentlich nur eine Datenbank die man auswerten kann.
Und damit hat man etwas über das man kann in philosophischer Weise entgegenhalten dass man das nicht tun kann und dass wir dennoch sehr stark schützen können so stark wie auch überwacht sind.
Da kann man wirklich zu unterscheiden zwischen warum blickt man in ein Gesicht wenn es um Sicherheitsfragen geht.
Wie erregt ist jemand oder welche Temperatur bringt er mit wenn er hier einreist.
Das hat mir natürlich sehr gutes wissenschaftliches Wissen weil man kann die Temperatur messen und den Pulsschlag und das sind Zahlenwerte und so weiter.
Bei den Emotionen ist wirklich schwierig dass es diese philosophische Richtung von Theater-AG.
Ich finde es immer ein bisschen amüsant wenn hinter dem Gesicht ist nichts. Die Frage ist wer füllt.
Da kann man ja einerseits wie du das referiert sagen. Es ist immer der Zuschauer der die Inhalte füllt.
Die Frage ist was bleibt dann von dem anderen gibt's selbst da und da gibt's dieses Buch von Ervin Goffman das ja auf Deutsch diesen wunderbaren Titel hat.
Wir alle spielen Theater. Im Englischen ist es irgendwie der Expression of Self in Every Day Live oder so.
In beiden Sprachen sehr guter Titel sehr aussagekräftig.
Und er beschreibt eben auch noch einmal diesen Moment indem man einen selbst entwickelt und das Bild ist ein dreijähriges Kind auf der Schaukel das von der Oma angeschaut wird und es möchte gern dass die Oma weiter schaukelt.
Also muss das Kind etwas zurückgeben und das ist eine positive Emotion das Kind zeigt dass das Schaukeln Spaß macht weil es weiß die Oma freut wenn das Kind Spaß hat.
Und damit bringe ich die Oma dazu die Schaukel zu bedienen.
Dieser soziologische Mechanismus dieses gegenseitige Verständnis und dann eben diese Idee von selbst gemeinsam aufzubauen also nicht sich zu fragen Wer bin ich und wer ist der andere sondern wer sind wir gemeinsam.
In diesem Moment ist auch so ein bisschen situations bezogen.
Luhmann hat ja mal sehr darauf aus nochmal die Interaktion selber vorzustellen.
Hätte dieses riesige Werk Funktion und folgen formaler Organisation seine Dissertation seinen Einstieg in die Soziologie und zu sagen Organisationen sind so ein richtig eigenes Ding.
Und dann gibt es da eben dieses eine Kapitel drin. Interaktion in Organisationen wo er einmal beschreibt und wann gilt all das nicht was ich gerade über die Organisation schreibe.
Wann gilt nicht dass der hierarchisch höher gestellte auch der mächtigere Raum ist und so weiter.
Naja wenn sich Menschen begegnen also in dem Moment wo sich Menschen begegnen bleibt fast nichts von der Organisation übrig.
So ein bisschen Respekt und so weiter. Das ist der Chef ich sehe ihn selten. Also ist die Zeit knapp und ich will sie gut füllen und so etwas natürlich.
Aber wenn Menschen in der Kaffeeküche ein Gespräch führen zu dritt dann ist für den vierten der den Raum betritt ziemlich klar Die haben über Abwesende gesprochen.
Und wenn der Chef in den Raum kommt ist im Moment nicht der mächtigste. Vor allem nicht wenn alle merken oder mitbekommen dass wir über ihn gesprochen haben.
Dann dreht sich sehr viel um. Deswegen ist diese direkte Begegnung in Gesichter schauen Gesichter auch wahrnehmen.
Super interessant und auch super relevant fürs Zusammenleben natürlich auch super interessant für die ökonomische Ausbeutung nur die Emotionen selbst,
kann man halt aus dem soziologischen Kontext befreit dann tatsächlich nicht so gut deuten wie man immer glaubt.
Genauso wie dieses Verhalten auf Facebook.
Johnny Häusler hat gestern sehr gut einen Tweet geschrieben hatten sich nämlich die neuen Facebook-Daten runtergeladen Man kriegt jetzt ein bisschen mehr von Facebook wenn man danach fragt,
und man kriegt unter anderem auch mit welchen Signal Worten und Stichworten Werbetreibende der das eigene Selbst angeboten wird schon geschrieben.
Wenn ihr daraufhin eure Werbebudgets ausgeht dann ist vorbei.
Ich fühle mich so missverstanden von Facebook. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch diesen super Hashtag boring Rest Fake wo prominente Frauen gezeigt werden in Momenten in denen sie einfach nur,
da sind Sie gucken sich ein Baseballspiel an Sitzen der ersten Reihe vor einer Modeschau eben nicht dieser Photo Moment.
Sie grinsen und so weiter sondern sie gucken einfach nur zu und dieses Gesicht ist in diesem Moment so langweilig dass alle glauben sie sind genervt.
Egal wie interessiert sie wirklich sind es ist in diesen Momenten wo man nicht weiß man wird gefilmt.
Man kommt nicht zu dieser Expression auf dasselbe wie Goffman schreiben.
Man sitzt gerade nicht auf der Schaukel und man wird nicht von der Oma angeschaut und so weiter.
Dann ist ein Gesicht fast Aussage los. Dann sitzt man wie so ein Braunbär da und hat keine Mimik und damit auch keine Aussagekraft.
Das Innere schlägt sich dann doch nicht so nieder. Man kann in dem Moment immer noch Puls messen und so was eine Temperatur aber so richtig heraus bricht dann doch nichts.
Dieses Nachdenken ist vielleicht dann doch nicht ganz so falsch wie man kann.
Zugleich sind es keine Situationen bei denen man sagen kann.
Diese Idee,
dass jemand der unbeobachtet ist authentisch ist. Jetzt wo wir uns gegenübersitzen geschweige denn,
eine Kamera aufstellen würde. Das ist für mich eine Kategorie die überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
Warum soll man nur weil man unbeobachtet ist nicht für sich selbst eine Rolle spielen. Glaubt man dabei immer an so etwas Ursprüngliches das sich dann im Gesicht manifestiert manifestiert sich,
Authentizität.
Dass man,
ganz gut aneinander vorbei kommt dass es in einer Gesellschaft mit so vielen Leuten auch sinnvoll. Man muss den anderen nicht irgendwie mit seinen eigenen Geschmacklosigkeiten belasten.
Format strenge beim Militär nimmt extrem viel Sicherheit Unsicherheit.
Du weißt einfach genau man läuft sich auf einem Hof gegenüber. Du musst nicht salutieren bevor nicht der Ranghöhere salutiert hat und wenn das lässt da musst du nicht und dann ist auch für alle klar sondern es ist einfach. Die Regeln sind einfach klar.
Jetzt war man hier so schön beim Gesicht. Da stellt sich natürlich eine Frage die wir uns alle stellen.
Bei,
worry.
Just for.
Work,
Technology.
And.
Dispens.
Was würde ich.
Ich überlege kriegst du genug aus deiner Morning Routine oder Basse ihren abtat.
Morning Routine oder du hier ein Update.
Ab.
Das ist sehr gut für den internationalen Markt erzählte kürzlich eine Verkäuferin beim Kaufhaus in Düsseldorf.
In Abteilung,
für Männer.
Wegretuschiert.
Das Problem sei nun aber dass.
Andere.
Die darauf abgestimmt sind ein großes Problem Es gibt sehr viele verschiedene Hauttypen und gerade international betrachtet zu individualisieren.
Individualisierung findet überall statt bis hin zu Nobelmarken,
mit einem eigenen Logo versehen lassen oder was auch immer.
Alle hätten sinnlos wertlos.
Ausdifferenzierung,
sehr interessant diese Entwicklung.
Wir sind hier bei der Skies vorgestellt der Hersteller ist ein LOreal.
Der größte Kosmetikhersteller der Welt im Grunde das Disney der Kosmetikbranche 77 000 Mitarbeiter sorgen dafür 23 Milliarden Euro Umsatz.
Und das ist spektakulär und jetzt ist immer die Frage Was verkauft man den Leuten eigentlich einfach nur den nächsten Lippenstift. Das ist wieder nur eine Farbe.
Lasst doch die Leute zuhause selber mixen. Man kriegt ein kleines Gerät ein Napf in dem drei Farben drinne und je nachdem wie die Lage ist im Gesicht wird dann neu gemixt vielleicht ein bisschen dunkler ein bisschen heller oder für jeden Tag neu.
Und Kosmetik und Consumer Electronics dass es im Grunde diese Verknüpfung hat uns noch gefehlt.
Kosmetik ist eigentlich die Analogstick Art und Weise überhaupt einkaufen zu gehen da Kosmetik zu kaufen.
Da hat man reine Mechanik entweder Düsen oder irgendein Gewinde um den Lippenstift zu drehen oder so.
Und das wurde jetzt dieses Jahr neu verknüpft damit wir uns scharf darüber unterhalten können was da gerade vor sich geht.
Müssen wir kurz ins Jahr 2016 zurückblicken. Gucken ist nämlich der letzte Zeitpunkt wo ein kluger Text zur Sachlage entstanden ist.
Was verkaufen Kosmetik Leute eigentlich gerade auch wenn wir übers Gesicht gesprochen haben was verkaufen die eigentlich das Ding ein bisschen schöner oder wie auch immer.
Der Industrieverband Körperpflege und Waschmittel gab damals eine Studie heraus hat nämlich die Marktforschung das Marktforschungsinstitut Rheingold einen Auftrag bekommen sich mal den Markt die Marktlage anzuschauen und die Psychologin im,
hat diese Studie betreut,
und äußerte sich dann bei Spiegel Online sehr ehrlich darüber und hat uns diesen Text dankenswerterweise mal eingelesen.
Rheingold Befragung gaben 77 Prozent der Jungen und Mädchen an dass sie vor allem nach Sicherheit und Stabilität suchten.
Ein Teil der Befragten habe bereits durch Trennungen familiäre Unsicherheit erlebt sagt er.
Dazu komme der gefühlte Kontrollverlust über den Körper während der Pubertät und das Gefühl angesichts von Wirtschaftskrisen und Terror in einer zunehmend unsicheren Welt zu leben.
Aber die junge Generation habe eine Strategie gefunden damit umzugehen Zitat Das Gute ist dass die Jugendlichen nicht in Haltlosigkeit abrutschen und durchdrehen.
Sie finden bei Freunden und Familie Halt und nutzen Schönheitspflege um sich selbst zu bearbeiten lautet das Erkenntnis aus der Studie.
Zitat Je ohnmächtiger wir uns fühlen desto wichtiger ist es für uns Kontrolle zu gewinnen wenigstens über unser äußeres schreibt es im Zitat.
Wir sind sicherheitsorientierte und bearbeiten mit Kosmetik die German Angst.
Zudem sei Kosmetik ein Mittel um sich Wohlbefinden zu verschaffen.
Teure Produkte mit edlen Inhaltsstoffen sollen dazu beitragen sich innerlich aufzurichten besser zu fühlen.
Man kann es richtig sehen wie sie da sitzt in ihren Konferenzräumen. Wie verkaufen wir mehr Sicherheit wenn wir schon so weit haben dass die Behandlung des eigenen Gesichts der Rettungsanker in dieser haltlosen Welt ist.
Man kann so richtig sehen wie sie da ihren Konferenzräumen überlegen Wie verkaufen wir mehr Sicherheit wenn wir sie schon so weit haben dass die Behandlung des eigenen Gesichts der Rettungsanker in dieser.
Und dann entscheidet man sich dafür.
In den 20er Jahren gibt es die Idee der kalten Persona das heißt man muss ein äußeres annehmen das,
sich als besonders stabil oder auch als eines zeigt das an dem nichts haften bleibt das sich mühelos durch diese Gesellschaft vor allem durch den urbanen Raum bewegen kann.
Dazu gehört auch dass man nicht so viel von sich preisgibt und dass man eine mögliche Geschlossenheit herstellt körperlich aber auch im Gesicht.
Und das ist etwas was die Kosmetik verspricht.
Porentief gereinigt wird erst dann alles wieder verschlossen wird sodass man dann eine Teflon durch die Welt schreiten kann.
Und diese Verkaufsargumente macht es jetzt beim Kosmetik aber das kann man genausogut bei den ganzen Uhren der Hersteller.
Der Hersteller meiner Sportschuhe den ich sehr schätze aber nicht namentlich nenne hat ein neues Modell.
Das richtet sich an Soldaten mit einem ganz speziellen Feature.
Eigentlich sind die Ohren nur noch Software. Die könnten im Grunde die ganze Software einpacken aber ein bisschen mehr kostet mal ein bisschen mehr Geld.
2000 Euro und das spezielle Feature ist.
Du hast ein Beleuchtungs Modus der auch dann dir die Information der Uhr anzeigt wenn du durch ein Nachtsichtgerät auf das Display schaust.
Das Display wird also ein bisschen beleuchtet aber nicht so hell. Es soll nicht blenden durch Nachtsichtgeräte acht tausend neun hundert neunzig Euro.
Es ist unglaublich was hier gerade noch für Cash in Situationen durchgefãhrt werden entsprechend haben wir den Rahmen gesetzt um uns bei L'Oreal nochmal weiter über Perso zu informieren.
Du verknüpft dein Lippenstift Generator mit einem Instagram-Profil willst dann Bilder aus der Farbe her gut gefallen die neuesten Trends in denen du mitgehen möchtest.
Und dann wird er die Farbe für die Lippen zurecht gemacht und für das ganze Gesicht oder du fotografiert das Kleid das du anziehen möchtest,
und wählt dann auf dem Fotografierten Bild den Punkt aus wo er die Farbgebung des Kleides so gut gefällt dass du es auch auf der Lippe oder im Gesicht haben willst.
Das ist einfach perfekt ich kann so richtig sehen wie junge Mädels super scharf darauf sind und du kannst natürlich die riesige Sammlung an allen Farben zuhause runter dampfen auf ein kleines Töpfchen.
Ich wollte sagen ist es nicht tatsächlich ein Fortschritt dass man nicht fünfzig oder hundert Lippenstifte besitzen muss sondern eben mit sehr wenigen zurechtkommt weil die sich dann farblich darauf abstimmen.
Genau das war nur der kleinere Markt. Denn hier gehts noch um Beauty.
Schon vor fünf Jahren oder so ist diese gigantische Kosmetik Markt übernommen worden von Helf Gesundheit die Reinigung der Haut das ist noch wichtiger als schön auszusehen.
Und da das wie jetzt Geld verdient wird es wirklich unglaublich.
Hört mal was ich euch hier verkaufen wollen.
Also Du trägst ein kleines Ding mit deinem pH-Wert misst ein einzelne Meter großes Pflaster das daraufhin deine Kosmetik zusammenstellt weil dein pH-Wert ist ja anders als meiner.
Es war ja Quatsch wenn du jetzt Creme kaufst in der irgendwelche Ingredienzien drin sind die dir gar nicht helfen.
Obwohl diese ganze pH-Werte Ideologie eine gute Verkaufsstrategie seit vielen Jahren ist für alle möglichen Produkte denn normalerweise hat man mit dem pH-Werte überhaupt gar keine,
Probleme erklärte als müsste man das immer wieder neu austarieren als würde man.
Eines Morgens wenn man das Falsche aufgesprüht hat oder so werden auch Probleme geschaffen um sie dann gewinnträchtig lösen zu können.
Aber nochmal einen Schritt weiter eine Optimierung der reinen Schönheit hier geht es schon sehr viel weiter Hier geht es eben darum dass der Körper muss,
optimiert werden dass er weiterhin gesund bleibt und so der erste Schritt Das sind,
Chips die jetzt auf die Haut aufgesetzt werden.
Der nächste Schritt ist es aber auch schon gibt es gibt ja inzwischen die Apple Watch die ohne weiteres SKG herstellen kann.
Da kann man sich aber fragen Ist das für die Jungen Fitness Leute oder doch für die Senioren Generation die schwer zu schwer zu vermarkten ist weil du jetzt ein cooles Produkt machen.
Mich wundert das offenbar. Ich kann sehr nachvollziehen dass jemand sagt ich wechseln meine Mode sehr stark und möchte jetzt möglichst viele Lippenstifte haben und wenn ich das auf einer praktischen Wege,
reduzieren kann das ich nicht kaufen muss.
Was mich aber sehr wundert ist dass es offenbar eine große Sorge gibt dass irgendetwas mit dem Körper nicht richtig stimmen könnte.
Denn in der Regel funktionierten Körper ganz gut.
Es sei denn man bekommt etwas sehr heftiges aber da kann diese permanente Angst dass man jetzt gerade die Nahrung nicht genügend zugeführt hat vollkommen idiotisch.
Also ich gehe jetzt mal in diese Apnoe weil es genau diese Angst die du beschreibst. Ich gehe mal diese App von meiner Uhr.
Was sie mir aufschlüsselt. Erstens Herzfrequenz und,
dann Body Batterie aus verschiedenen demografischen Daten mit vergleichst Personen meiner Altersklasse wird jetzt eine Botti Batterie ausgehend von wie lang hab ich geschlafen und so weiter.
Dann aus verschiedenen demografischen Daten mit vergleichst Person meiner Altersklasse wird jetzt eine Body Batterie ausgehen.
Wie lang habe ich geschlafen und so weiter. Es gibt einen Sensor für den Sauerstoffanteil in mein Blut und so wird eine Body Batterie ein Wert ausgegeben bei 5 von hundert Stresslevel bei 30 von 1000.
Es gibt einen Sensor für den Sauerstoffanteil in meinem Blut und so wird eine Body Batterie ein Wert ausgegeben dass bei mir 5 von 100 Stresslevel liegt bei 30 von 100..
Scheint ziemlich gut zu sein und ganz neu.
Zu sein und ganz neu produziert seit zwei Tagen oder.
Also würde ich jetzt seit drei Tagen oder so Atmung der Wert ist Br. PM Breath permanent.
Der Wert ist. Br. pm.
Also es wird jetzt mitgezählt. Bei neu eigentlich.
Es wird jetzt mitgezählt. Ich bin gerade bei neun wie viel atme ich eigentlich und das soll mir diese Sicherheit.
Ja erst alles was man wissen kann.
Also zum einen man misst erst mal alles was man messen kann.
Es gab halt der pH-Wert lässt sich super Messen vermarkten weil das einfach meine ich hab keine Ahnung es ist mir auch unklar.
Was macht man dann wenn man zu viel atmet. Kann man dann auch sagen lass es jetzt mal für die nächsten Minuten.
Eine persönliche Frage Weshalb hast du eine solche schreckliche Uhr.
Ja weil ich doch so ein bisschen Sport bin ich schon in diesen Topf gefallen.
Naja aber du bist ja noch ein junger Mann. Also dass du jetzt ein paar Kilometer laufen kann ohne dass wir dich danach im Krankenhaus wiederfinden wird ja machbar sein.
Ich habe gestern erst einen Text in der Süddeutschen über den Produktmanager also ein Produkt Leiter zuständig für die Produkte von meiner Sporttaucher gelesen und er meinte auch der Ansatzpunkt ist natürlich der Sport.
In dem Moment wo du laufen gehst wird so einfach deine Drängens Daten haben.
Habe damals als Schüler genug Sport gemacht wo auch immer so Laktat Werte und das war super aufwendig und nervig und es hat ja irgendwie zu.
Trotzdem brauchst du solche Trainings Resonanz Daten ein bisschen Feedback das liefert dir die Uhr halt einfach so du kannst halt mit seiner Uhr sehr viel besser trainieren als irgendwelche Olympiasiege von allein vor 31 Jahren oder so.
Und dann war der Marketingtrick Uhr hast.
Wieso nimmst nicht die Sportler einen ganzen Tag in der Hinsicht bin ich genau in diese Falle getappt.
Aber ich sage Ich mache halt freiwillig in dem Sinne dass ich mich schon dafür interessiere ich mich eigentlich seit drei Tagen interessiere ich mich jetzt dafür wie ich mich eigentlich warum nicht. So funktioniert.
Man kann es messen und deswegen wird es auch gemessen. Und jetzt ist allerdings die Frage Wie werden die Menschen noch vorführen.
Also Ich kriege hier echtes Feedback weil es ist ein echter Trainingsplan in dem ich so drin stecke.
Übrigends und da werden wir auch noch drüber diskutieren im Widerstand zu diesen kapitalistischen Auswüchsen.
Ich möchte gerne auf eigene Faust gesund durch die Hitze kommen im Sommer das bringt einfach Fitness mit sich sehr viel besser als irgendwelche Annehmlichkeiten wie Klimaanlage im Auto oder so.
Man könnte mir eine Klimaanlage im Auto gegen die Hitze verkaufen oder Fitness und dann entscheide ich mich lieber für die Fitness.
Du willst ja lieber kein Mittagessen und dafür lieber kein Mittagessen statt Sport ja auch so Abwägungen die man treffen kann.
Ich bin ein Verfechter der Klimaanlage. Ich esse einfach gerne.
Ich esse einfach gerne aber ich mache dafür auch Sport auch wenns eingeschränkt ist und Klimaanlagen mag ich nicht und ich möchte gern solide durch den hitze sommer kommen Klimawandel und so..
Klimaanlagen mag ich nicht irgendwelche sowieder durch Hitze. Ich schlafe ja sogar mit Klimaanlage im Sommer.
Das wäre für mich ein No-Go. Dann würde ich mich ausgeliefert fühlen wenn ich hätte wenn ich eine Klimaanlage zum angenehmen schlafen brauche würde ich sagen Hier stimmt etwas nicht.
Ich will das Fit in Fitness steht ja auch für Anpassung und Leistung darf man aber nicht übersehen was das so bedeutet.
Wie wird man allerdings verführt. Die DCS macht es ja ganz ganz ganz fies.
Es gibt ja so eine Zauberformel Schönheitspflege plus Skins bietet dir diese Selbstsicherheit.
Jenes Kind dreht sich ja.
Gern.
Heising.
In Weimar,
sind.
Faces Me.
And,
rush Act.
Textor.
Miriams The Magic,
Experience.
Spricht der personalisierte Algorithmus zu uns.
Eine lustige Frau ist ein Algorithmus und erklärt wie sich dieser Algorithmus optimiert hat was er alles intus hat um jetzt richtig auslesen zu können.
Mit Bezug auf Picard hat Dietmar Dath geschrieben Zitat Technik erzählend zu vermenschlichen artikuliert den Anspruch die Geltung menschlicher Ethik auch auf sie auszudehnen.
Zitat Technik erzählen zu vermenschlichen artikuliert den Anspruch die Geltung menschlicher Ethik auch auf sie auszudehnen.
Wenn wir das nicht schaffen entgleitet uns die Menschlichkeit die wir für unseren fixen Besitz und unser Erbteil halten.
Wir haben hier menschliche Technik gesehen aber nicht in diesem Sinne wie Dietmar Dath Das hofft und wünscht sondern dass es die Perversion davon dass da irgendeine Frau stehen sagt Oh Allmen Algorithmen und nicht die dir.
Wir haben hier menschliche Technik gesehen. Aber nicht in diesem Sinne wie Mandates hofft und wünscht sondern dass es die Perversion davon dass er seine Frau steht sagt ein Allgäuer.
Und ich diene dir und das ist es seins da gibt es gar keine Widersprüche.
Und das ist ja Science da gibt es gar keine Widersprüche.
Und dann sitzt man da in einem Café und fotografiert sich gegenseitig ins Gesicht damit irgendwie die Crème der aufzusitzen Recht gestellt wird.
Wieder.
Das Ausmaß an wirklich Technique Perversion ist unglaublich.
So ein Punkt bei dem ich sagen würde Es gibt eigentlich nur ganz wenig zu optimieren.
Sicherlich haben manche Leute Hautprobleme Probleme dann das entsprechende Make up aufzutragen.
Aber das ist ein ganz ganz marginales Problem das hier plötzlich als ein ganz großes zu sehen ist.
Und plötzlich fangen die Leute aber auch an das zu machen.
Das ist ja ein bisschen ein Effekt den man sehen kann. Man nutzt eine Wetter-App und die nutzt man aber plötzlich 28 Mal am Tag auch wenn es reichen würde vielleicht morgens und abends mal drauf zu schauen.
Es gibt Leute die fahren nicht mehr drei Meter zum Supermarkt mit dem Auto ohne vorher die Navi App anzumachen oder sich einfach mal den Verkehr anzugucken wo er sonst die Technik selbst.
Zum Selbstzweck verknüpft das nur noch lose mit irgendetwas.
Es ist ja auch eine permanente Beschäftigung mit der Technik und darüber auch mit sich selbst die stattfindet.
Derzeit könnte man ja viele andere wichtige Dinge tun indem man sich auf diese ganzen Apps und diese Sachen einlässt verschwendet man extrem viel Lebenszeit und,
auf Dauer unglücklich machen dann wieder die Apps unglücklich.
Und dafür werden so etwas anzubieten haben. Aber es ist ja so dass man sich einfach da rausziehen kann sie würde sagen 99 Prozent aller Frauen die sich schminken haben genügend.
Möglichkeiten dafür. Niemand braucht so eine App.
Deswegen ist es ein Problem das von der Industrie geschaffen wird das anschließend gelöst werden wird von dieser Industrie.
Genau Es ist nämlich nicht nur Geldverschwendung sich sowas zu kaufen sondern es ist auch eine Zeitverschwendung. Diese ganze Youtube Ideologie kennt sie ja auch zur Morning Dorothée.
Ja tolle Videos.
Wir lernen von uns gegenseitig wie die Morning Routine aussieht.
Eigentlich ein Wunder dachte ich gerade wie spät die Kosmetikindustrie denn das ist ja nun Kernbestand von YouTube seit zehn Jahren dass man diese Morning Routine sehen kann Es gibt sie jetzt im übrigen auch mit so einer ökologischen Botschaft.
Ganz genau.
Na klar.
Unter der Dusche. Was für die Umwelt tun will man kann während man sich den Wasserhahn abdrehen. Toll.
Ja das ist unglaublich Erkenntnisse vor allem neu.
Da wäre man vor 30 Jahren noch nicht drauf gekommen.
Weißt du wo die erste Morning Routine in der Popkultur so ganz wichtig wird.
Das ist nämlich unser Patrick Bateman den sehen wir bei der Morning.
Da stimmt die.
Das ist eine ganz klassische Morning Routine die wir da erleben.
Genau und zwar ganzheitlich Sport Ernährung Gesicht bis hin zu den Poren säubern. Good morning in diesem American Psycho ist vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht. Das hier ist jetzt American Psycho.
Du hast diese Messeständen da wo du hingehen kannst um nochmal das kleine Video für deinen Youtube-Kanal zu drehen wurde das vorgeführt wird was da passiert. Und sie zeigen dir einfach wie deine Morning Routine absofort aussieht.
Zu
Ende.
Ging.
Eine einzige Herisau.
Eine hoch individuelle Oh ich fahr nach Las Vegas. Ich brauche mehr Feuchtigkeit aber dann nochmal prüfen. Mit dem Handy Aufsatz. Ob das auch wirklich stimmt.
Man sollte sich morgens einmal abfotografieren an den entscheidenden Stellen.
Und dann wird die Maske darauf.
Wange Stirn und Dekolleté und dann wird die Maske ein bisschen abgebaut.
Alles wird angepasst und ich wage hier schon zu behaupten hier klar aber hell ist es auch im Sinne von Anti-Aging.
Angepasst und ich wage zu behaupten.
Dass es auch im Sinne von ein sehr starkes.
Ist auch ein sehr starkes.
Argument.
Argument in der Hinsicht drin dass hier auch 40 50 60 und 70 jährige Frauen angesprochen werden und nicht nur die YouTube Generation.
Ja man muss bedenken Die meisten ja die meisten Produkte würden von den hochpreisigen Sachen reden sind so teuer dass die sich vielleicht Influenza leisten könnten aber normale junge Menschen könnten sich die nicht leisten.
Weil erstens die heutige Generation hat kein Geld.
Wir reden hier von einem kleinen Bottich der dann sofort 200 Euro kostet.
Mit dem Abo immer nachfüllen und so die Farbe erst richtig Geldbewegungen.
Sehr beliebt übrigens bei Hochzeiten wird ja gerne viel Geld ausgegeben das hat mir kürzlich mein Friseur erzählt das dann auch extra für Hochzeiten so ein Profi Make up verlangt wird inklusive,
inklusive bestimmter Botox Cremes.
Botox.
Die kosten dann 2 300 Euro aber die trägt man dann auf und die legen dann das Gesicht für mehrere Stunden lahm mit denen man dann prima die Hochzeitsfotos machen kann.
Ist eine Sensation. Das kann man sich immer leisten.
Da gibt man dann mal viel Geld aus das kann man sich natürlich nicht immer leisten.
Im Fernsehen wird es ja schon sehr stark eingesetzt diese Botox Cremes spezifisch junge Menschen.
Man hat sich einen sehr spezifischen Zugriff auf junge Menschen in wichtigen Lebensphasen oder halt.
Ohne Halt aussehen ja.
Nicht wie 40 aussehen obwohl du 55 bist ganz groß und es war nicht überraschend dass dies auch jetzt mittlerweile wirklich viele Rentner publique Produkte.
Auch wirklich.
Horn.
Defibrillator für Zuhause.
Zuhause kann man auch immer so mit nehmen was praktisch.
Passt in die Tasche.
Man weiß ja nie. Er hat jetzt gesagt Es stimmt ja auch solche Fälle passieren zu Hause und wenn du selber kannst Lebenschance von 100 auf 90 prozent.
Er hat jetzt gesagt und es stimmt ja auch solche Unfälle passieren zu Hause,
und wenn du selber helfen kannst steigert Lebenschance von 100 auf 90 prozent kann mir ein bisschen Großfeuer dass es nur zehn Prozent sind aber mal gucken weil die größte Todesursache.
Prozent weil die größte Todesursache.
Wir leben auf jeden Fall entsprechend ungesund und lang dass man das Riesenmarkt demnächst.
Wir leben auf jeden Fall entsprechend ungesund und lang dass man das Riesenmarkt demnächst stecke weil Leute mit 50 Jahren mit an Herzproblemen zu haben bis hin zu mehrere Schlaganfälle und Herzinfarkte und so weiter.
Mit 50 Jahren Herzprobleme zu haben bis hin zu mehreren Schlaganfällen und Herzinfarkte und so weiter und schnell helfen kannst.
Da kannst es dann eben auch interessant wie.
Das ist dann eben auch interessant wie das vermarktet wird.
Weiß,
weiß.
Weiß.
Die Eltern auf.
Genau dann bin ich über einen Tweet gestolpert den Referee Gorz von Bosch. Bosch ist dieser große Hersteller.
Zitat Vorsatz 2020 weniger naschen. Der Bosch Smart Home.
Tür und Fenster Kontakt an der Süßigkeiten Schublade hilft bei jeder Schubladen öffnung erhältst du eine individuelle Push-Benachrichtigungen.
Zitat Finger weg sagt dann dein Handy.
Wie das geht und welche Automation zusätzlich helfen erfährst du hier und dann bei Bosch ein bisschen klicken was im Angebot haben,
soll Ich stell dir vor du hast einen kleinen Magneten der paarweise den einen musst du an den Schrank und den anderen an die Schranktür sodass du immer so brauchst du eine Push-Nachrichten hast du selber den Schrank auf machst auf dein Handy die dir sagt Finger weg.
Macht keinen Sinn oder warum wird das vermarktet. Kann jetzt jeder mal kurz drüber nachdenken. Wozu braucht man sowas.
Die Antwort ist Wenn du deinen alten Eltern einen Defibrillator gekauft hast,
macht es ihnen nicht Sinn den auch beispielsweise an die Dusch Tür so ein Ding zu machen oder an den Kühlschrank sodass du morgens auf dein Handy nachgucken kannst und deine Eltern schon ihre Morning Routinen absolviert haben oder eventuell tot in der Ecke liegen.
Wird immer noch nicht ehrlich vermarktet. Der Defibrillator. Da kommt man nicht drum rum bei Kosmetik immer noch für die hippen Instagram Leute und so weiter obwohl das eigentlich schon für Old Republic ist und Bosch kommt jetzt mit sowas und macht ihr noch so ein Weger naschen. Dabei geht es ja wirklich um Leben und Tod.
Mir fällt aber noch etwas ein bei dem Nasheed zu bleiben,
sehr daran interessiert sein ärzte,
weniger Zucker essen.
Die Versicherung geht dann wenn sie diese kostenintensiven Medikamente bekommen sollten dann werden sie stärker daran beteiligt wenn sie immer,
noch zugegriffen haben sind große Möglichkeiten der Kommerzialisierung und womit die Menschen sich selbst kontrollieren wollen.
Werden Sie dann am Ende auch kontrolliert werden und wer nicht in der Lage ist diszipliniert zu sein. Der soll doch auch dazu stehen.
Aber ich finde ja generell vollkommen richtig wenn jemand sich bewusst ungesund finde ich finde ich fabelhaft.
Ganz genau. Die Frage ist immer findet man noch gesehen oder ist man damit dann alleine.
Einsamkeit ist ja immer ein großes Problem. So wie gesagt wurde ja dass der Defibrillator hält Kontakt mit dir und zeigt dir die Batterie aufgeladen Er ist einsatzbereit Ich muss noch nicht hin und die Batterien tauschen noch,
könnte der Vater oder die Mutter jeweils das Ding bedienen.
Sie brauchen noch nicht den jüngeren Sohn der sich mit Technik auskennt. Die Batterie wechseln oder eben hier bei Bosch guck doch noch mal nach ob jetzt die Morning Routine deine 90 jährigen Mutter schon durch ist oder nicht die Sorge machen muss.
So und jetzt komme ich so ein bisschen wirklich in die perversen Sachen hier das ist unglaublich.
Wir gucken jetzt was du uns dann beschreiben muss. Ich bin sehr gespannt wie Deine Beschreibung.
Das.
Engagement in der Company.
Dieser Mensch hat ein Stofftier auf dem Arm das keinen Kopf hat sondern nur aus einem Rumpf und einem verelenden Schwanz besteht dass sich ganz toll anfühlt.
Fußball Größe. Es ist kuschelig und umso mehr du kuscheln umso mehr wedelt das mit dem Schwanz das von Hunden kennen.
Größe. Ja.
Ja
Und das ist dann dein Emotional Support Roboter.
Ja. Für den Abend und dann gibt es noch so einen kleinen Schneemann könnte man sagen So ein Weiser der auch anerkennend nickt.
Das,
ist ein kleiner Roboter der sieht einfach ein bisschen süß aus.
Kindchenschema.
Genau wir gucken gleich nochmal einen Ausschnitt dazu.
Der steht ungefähr so groß wie eine Blumenvase oder eine Urne oder so. Keine Ahnung kann er so rumstehen. Es sieht so aus als würde er sich angucken.
Der steht ungefähr so groß wie eine Blumenvase oder eine Urne oder so. Keine Ahnung kann er so rumstehen.
Es sieht so aus als würde er dich angucken hätten mich zwei schwarze Knopfaugen und so weiter und die Funktion das ist so wahnsinnig.
2 schwarze Knopfaugen und so weiter und die Funktion es ist so wahnsinnig Wir gucken jetzt mal eine Situation die es wie folgt zu beschreiben ist in Washington Post Journalist der sich für dieses Thema interessiert.
Wir gucken jetzt mal eine Situation die es wie folgt zu beschreiben ist in Washington Post Journalist der sich für dieses Ding da interessiert Wir sind kleine Roboter und er trifft jetzt auf eine Marketing Frau des Herstellers.
Dieser kleine Roboter und er trifft jetzt auf eine Marketing Frau des Herstellers und möchte mit ihr über diesen Roboter der uns schon als Emotional Support und so weiter vorgestellt wurde.
Und möchte mit ihr über diesen Roboter reden der uns schon als Emotional Support und so weiter vorgestellt wurde.
Wir sehen also jetzt zwei Menschen und einen Roboter im Bild und wir überlegen uns das kann man auch hören.
Wir sehen jetzt zwei Menschen und einen Roboter erzählt und wir überlegen uns auch höhere.
Aber wenn man sieht ist noch deutlicher sind es wirklich zwei Menschen und ein Roboter.
Aber man sieht es noch deutlicher sind es wirklich zwei Menschen.
E-Moll Robert.
Sie hat ihren Markt Text Runde geredet Botox Creme nochmal aufgetragen morgens Ich fühle mich gelangweilt von ihrem eigenen Text.
Hat ihren Marchetti Runde geredet. Botox Crema nochmal aufgetragen morgens völlig gelangweilt von ihrem eigenen Text und man vermutet sie ist der Roboter.
Der Moderator bin ich mir aber auch nicht sicher. Vielleicht drei Roboter oder zwei Roboter und ein Mensch ist ganz klein und Roboter.
Gleichzeitig redet sie ja.
Und die Reden über Emotionen was ist wirklich gruselig.
Wir reden über Emotionen.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen Grusel als ich es gesehen habe. Es ist ja nun auch.
Das ist eine Erfahrung die ich immer stärker mache dass ich im öffentlichen Raum Menschen begegne und mir nicht mehr so ganz sicher bin ob da irgendwas passiert ist ob sie vielleicht von irgendwo her kommen oder,
man kann das Leben von John Carpenter irgendwie sich merkwürdig verhalten zumindest so leicht verschoben und wenn ich mir,
Storys von sehr erfolgreichen Influence ansehe bin ich mir nicht mehr sicher ob die noch zu meiner Familie gehören oder ob ich vielleicht über Nacht irgendwo anders gelandet bin.
Es hat einen gewissen Grusel Charakter und es wird umso gruseliger. Im März kommt die dritte,
Staffel von Westwall. Die wird dann nicht mehr in Westwall spielen sondern in der echten Welt Die Roboter sind ja ausgebrochen und mal gucken wie viele der wiedererkennbar von der echten Welt,
Jetzt sind sehr viele Menschen einsam und brauchen irgendwelche Kuscheltiere die mit dem Schwanz wedeln oder so kleine Roboter.
Samsung hat sich gedacht haben wir mal komplett sinnlos.
Sodas.
So Bally ist ein kleiner Ball. Durchmesser 50 Zentimeter keine Ahnung.
Der reut aber nicht wirklich sondern einfach nur Fake Räder. Sobald er rollt sind die Füße oben wie bei einem Käfer und dann kommt er auch nicht mehr weiter.
Absolutes Fake Ding rollt jetzt auf der Bühne dem Sprecherder hinterher und filmt ihn gleichzeitig.
Man kann hinter ihm auf der Leinwand sehen wie Marley aus der Vogelperspektive den Typ filmt und wir fragen uns jetzt natürlich was will er uns hier verkaufen.
Fitnesstest Moving.
Wird auf smarte Weise.
Wenn sie ehrlich wären würden Sie sagen das ist für deine 90 jährige Mutter.
Aber glaubst du dass es immer so dass das nur für alte Leute gedacht ist.
Da kannst du dir ein anderes.
Ich stelle mir gerade sehr viele Leute vor die.
Aber wozu,
machen Tamagotchi eigentlich.
Tamagotchi.
Da stimmt es aber.
Relativ sinnlos.
Also ich frage mich ein bisschen Wozu kaufen.
Eine Technikbegeisterung an sich generell.
Ja aber das Ding hat ja keine Technik ist ja super reduziert Ball ohne Knöpfe ohne alles.
Aber.
Irgendwas passieren sollte für irgendwas. Die meisten Unfälle sind verquickt.
Will man sein wenn man dieses Gerät hat. Und das gilt ja nicht nur für die 90-Jährige.
Ich sehe es ja wenn ich irgendwo in Cafés sitze das sich Anfang 20-Jährige über ihre Verdauung unterhalten das ist normalerweise 85-Jährige.
Aber mittlerweile ist das ja ein Thema das für Anfang 20-Jährige extrem wichtig geworden ist.
Ich frage mich immer Was ist der Kaufes Impuls. Wie wollen Sie solche auslösen.
Ich frage mich immer Was ist da kaum Südpols welche auslösen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen dass man das als überwachungskamera für die älteren Familienmitglieder so wie man die Apple Uhr Erkennung ist wirklich nur als Weihnachtsgeschenk für die Eltern zu vermarkten. Niemand braucht es für sich selber.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen dass man das als überwachungskamera für die älteren Familienmitglieder so wie man die Uhr die Stotz erkennt wirklich nur als Weihnachtsgeschenk für die Eltern zu vermarkten.
Auch das wie sich selber abseits eine wirklich massive Sharky ist wie eine Woche im Jahr und ich sehe so ein verkaufst Kinga für das Reutter durch die Wohnung.
Wenn man denn wirklich Marchi fährt aber man fährt man schon Ski dass man eine Anerkennung braucht die eine Woche im Jahr.
Und ich sehe so ein verkaufst Kicker für das Ding Reutter durch die Wohnung da kann ich mal nachgucken wo sie in welchem Zustand steht sie. Oder liegt sie irgendwo. Ja aber dann eben wirklich Remote Control so wie er das sagt.
Da kann ich mal nachgucken sie überall wo sie in welchem Zustand steht und wo er aber dann doch nicht Remote Control er da sein Gesicht finde ich.
In der Hinsicht finde ich es hätte man das ganz ehrlich als die.
Hätte man es ganz ehrlich als für die.
Verzicht. Ich stelle mir vor dass ich jetzt hier um die Wohnung herum und kommt jetzt angerollt oder so. Das ist schon und es ist.
Aber du hast doch auch zum Beispiel eine Alexa die wir ja schon verwendet haben. Okay aber die meisten Leute die Alexa haben sind eher jung.
Aber wirklich nur für den Podcast.
Kann sein. Da kommt zur Technik Affinität rein Bally.
Und.
Haben jetzt nicht nur die Leute da sitzen die glänzende und sich etwas vorlesen lassen oder irgendwie dass der Sohn,
die Eltern ein bisschen kontrollieren kann oder denen man ein Musikstück vorspielen kann sondern es ist schon auch dazu da dass junge Leute das irgendwie toll finden dass sie eine Dienerinnen im Haus haben die sie rufen können.
Man kann es immer für alle vermarkten und solange die Attraktivität hoch ist. Ich nicht mal auf der Buchmesse vor ein paar Jahren mit Joana Zimmer unterhalten.
Man kann es immer für alle vermarkten und solange die Attraktivität hoch ist.
Ich habe mich mal auf der Buchmesse vor ein paar Jahren mit Joana Zimmer unterhalten das ist eine blinde Schlagersängerin. Im Grunde hat mir das mal so beschrieben wie das war als Steve Jobs das iPhone vorgestellt hat.
Schlagersängerin hat mir das mal so beschrieben wie das war als Jobs wie.
Für die Blinden die konnten plötzlich alles machen.
Ich konnte plötzlich alles machen jeder Inhalt auf dem Display vorgelesen werden konnten alles mit Sprache bedienen.
Jeder Inhalt auf dem Display konnte vorgelesen werden. Sie konnten alles mit Sprache bedienen. Das ganze Ding ruft mal jemanden an Schreib mal die Nachricht.
Das ganze Ding ruft mal jemanden an Schreib mal die Nachricht sowieso ist das Wetter der ganze krame.
Wie ist das Wetter. Der ganze krame ist für diese Leute überlebenswichtig eigentlich die alleine morgens ihre Morning Routine und die brauchen wirklich eine Morning Routine. Da ist es eben nicht nur ein Spaß oder so.
Ist für diese Leute überlebenswichtig eigentlich wieder so morgens ihre Morning Botin und die brauchen einen wirklich ohne Routine aber es ist eben nicht so ein Spaß. Und da.
Und da gibts so ein Verkaufsargument für alle anderen ist es glaube ich so Konzept dass man wenn man Bali irgendwo mal durch eine Belene Wohnung rollen sieht oder so würde ich mich doch sehr wundern.
Gibts Kaufargument für alle anderen ist es genauso Konzept dass man wenn man irgendwo mal durch eine Belene und wollen sie wäre so würde ich mich doch aber sehr wundern.
Der Markt für Blinde ist nur mehr ein sehr kleiner versteckter.
Deswegen muss es breit vermarkten sofern überhaupt was ich wirklich erschreckend fand Samsung nochmal.
Hauri.
Samsung Jams Sport machen mit Samsung Jams. Sie kommt also auf die Bühne. Mit so einem Korsett.
Rumpf und jedes Bein ist eingefasst in so ein komisches Exoskelett. Und jetzt setzt sie noch eine Brille auf.
Fitness Programs,
Fitness Coaching.
Fitness,
Glasses.
All das ist bedrückender als der Film.
Pikmin Fitness-Trainer.
Ready.
Jetzt kommt ein Hologramm das sich vor ihr aufbaut.
Made.
Bark weiß wird mein Galaxy Jams Salsa Agri.
Zwingli.
Hier bin ich und sage Ich will die 70er Jahre zurück. Ich will einfach dass die Leute sagen bewegt dich mal ein bisschen geh mal spazieren.
Gegessen wird was auf den Tisch kommt.
Und wenn du irgendwelche psychischen Probleme hast dann redet man nicht so viel darüber macht man nicht so viel Sorgen reiß dich mal zusammen.
Das waren ja die Sätze die man damals hörte und ich kenne sehr viele Leute wie meine Großeltern die einfach gut damit gefahren sind.
Ja so eine Auswertung. Ja du bist mit dem Knie nicht nah genug an den Boden gekommen die übung hat wenig Sinn gemacht beim nächsten Mal geht ein bisschen tiefer und übrigends wenn du läufst hast du einen leichten Hang nach links achtet darauf dass so starten wir jetzt in den Zwanziger.
Bis in die knie mich nah genug an den Boden kommt die übermannen sind gemacht beim nächsten Mal geht ein bisschen tiefer und übrigends wenn du läufst hast du einen leichten Hang nach links achtet doch mal drauf.
So hatten wir jetzt in die 20er Jahre. Das ist traurig noch trauriger Meditation. Ich weiß nicht ob du schon mal versucht hast. Nein natürlich nie.
Das ist traurig.
Noch trauriger Meditation. Ich weiß nicht ob du schon mal versucht hast zu meditieren. Ich auch nicht.
Ich habe gehört man soll sich auf seine Atmung konzentrieren und findet genau findet man irgendwie zu sich selbst.
Ich habe gehört man soll sich auf seine Arbeit konzentrieren und dann ist er jetzt die.
Falls du es nicht schaffst die Atmung zu konzentrieren oder sonst irgendwie kriegst du jetzt auch hier ein kleines technisches Gerät an die Hand.
Ein.
Hochhaus.
Widerspricht ich den zwei Grundprinzipien irgendwie. Lasst die Meditation Meditation sein also macht gerade nicht so eine komische technische Auswertung.
Und ja du musst dich auf deinen Atmung konzentrieren also auf dich selber und nicht auf irgendeinen Gerät das für dich vibriert wie du atmen sollst. Genau widersprüchlich.
Ich habe wenig Ahnung davon schien mir nur irgendwie auf der Hand zu liegen dass das irgendwie totaler Quatsch ist.
Du hast du bist du sagst uns jetzt an was dich das erinnert.
S-Bahn A Transportmaschine weiß.
Paks.
Sweet.
Home.
Da
Seit.
Wir.
Kein Rollstuhl für Menschen die einen Rollstuhl brauchen.
Einen.
Man sitzt da drin in so einem bequemen Sitz und der fährt ein wie man es möchte durch die Gegend dass der Ohrensessel auf Rädern der hier angeboten wird exakt Valli.
Tipp.
Haben sie auch sehr viele Troubles durchgemacht.
Nur hat man jetzt eben eine schlanke sportliche Frau eingesetzt aber die Wahrheit würde anders aussehen bei der Vermarktung hier würde ich auch sagen geht es um etwas ganz anderes.
60 Prozent Gewichtigkeit Mobilität für die Dicken und alten schließen wir das Segment ab.
Tony.
Vielleicht können wir noch anknüpfen an das was ja da vorgestellt wurde auch dort vorgestellt.
Noch anklopfen. Erst dann stellt nämlich ja,
richtig aber auch dort vorgestellt nämlich es verändert sich auch das Kino und das Kino wird immer kleiner Es findet jetzt bald auf dem Smartphone statt und damit ist nicht gemeint dass man selbstverständlich auch in der Flix auf dem Smartphone streamen kann.
Es verändert sich auch das Kino das Kino wird immer kleiner Es findet jetzt bald auf dem Smartphone statt und damit ist nicht gemeint dass man selbstverständlich auch Netflix auf dem Smartphone streamen kann sondern man überlegt jetzt gerade.
Sondern man überlegt jetzt gerade.
Wie kann man denn eigentlich große Hollywood Inhalte auf das Smartphone holen beziehungsweise extra für das Smartphone produzieren.
Wie kann man denn eigentlich große Hollywood Inhalte auf das Smartphone holen bzw.
Extra für das Smartphone produzieren und eine neue Streaming Plattform die in wenigen Monaten starten soll.
Und eine neue Streaming Plattform die in wenigen Monaten starten soll es.
Es wurde auch bei C.s vorgestellt.
Ist schon ein bisschen länger bekannt dass es das gibt man hat schon sehr viele Unterstützer wie Steven Spielberg und Guillermo del Toro sehr viele Schauspieler sind schon aufgetreten und promoten gerade auch einen eigenen Youtube-Kanal.
Ist schon ein bisschen länger bekannt dass es das gibt man hat schon sehr viele Unterstützer wie Steven Spielberg und der Toru der Schauspieler sind schon aufgetreten und promoten gerade das.
Die haben auch einen eigenen Youtube-Kanal und haben eine Milliarde.
Wir haben jetzt eine Milliarde eingesammelt glaube ich so viel wie Netflix der eigenen Content ausgibt,
ja sogar noch relativ klein.
Aber sie wollen selbstverständlich auch von den Leuten die diese nutzen auf dem Smartphone Preis verlangen drei vier sieben Euro Dollar. Man weiß es noch nicht ganz genau.
Aber wir gerade in dieses Interview,
um zu erfahren worum es da eigentlich geht dann ist es so dass Inhalte sind die man nicht nur auf dem Smartphone sondern nur auf dem Smartphone guckt und die abgestimmt sind auf die Besonderheiten des Smartphones.
Fantastik.
Das Versprechen ist auch das kann man auch sehen sich zum Beispiel die Szene eines kurzen Films den man sich ansieht.
Ob man jetzt gerade das Smartphone hochkant oder quer hält das ist ein filmisches Format das an die Gegebenheiten an die Gewohnheiten des Sehens mit dem Smartphone angepasst wird.
Es ist die Idee auch dass man sehr teure Inhalte also Hollywood Inhalte nun auf das Smartphone bringen kann und dass man.
Eine neue Form der Filmproduktion hat denn bislang war ja Filmproduktionen entweder für den Fernseher oder für das Kino und auch die Streaming-Dienste haben das eigentlich nicht gross verändert.
Wenn man jetzt aber sagt Das Smartphone hat ein eigenes Format und dadurch muss auch eine Perspektive anders sein muss eine Kamera anders arbeiten.
Entwickelt sich hier eigentlich so ein neues eine neue Gattung vielleicht Kurzfilme,
sind ja eher so etwas was man auf Festivals mal sehen kann oder was irgendwo nachts mal bei Arte versendet wird aber eigentlich ist der Kurzfilm etwas womit,
sich vielleicht anfangs die Sporen verdient aber niemand ist sehr daran interessiert hier ist man jetzt,
so dass man sagt das Smartphone haben die Leute immer dabei und sie haben vielleicht nur sieben oder acht oder zwölf Minuten Zeit sich etwas anzusehen und das tun sie dann auf dem Smartphone warum nicht auch für diesen Inhalt direkt etwas,
produzieren wo ich mich aber gleich gefragt habe.
Ich beobachte ja gerade Serien die ja sehr sehr lang sind auf dem Smartphone oder dem Tablet schauen wenn sie unterwegs sind und überhaupt gar kein Problem damit haben nach acht Stunden Serie in ganz kleinen Häppchen zuzuführen,
braucht es das überhaupt. Was würdest du sagen.
Ja ich habe auch ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht weil die einen meiner Lieblingssport Kaste Wörz Kaste immer sich sehr darüber lustig machen dass die wie die auftreten mit diesem Versprechen Kreibich Quick Bait irgendwie Krick wird der schnelle Happen aber auch die schnelle Datenübertragung.
So ich hab mir dann nochmal deren Website angeguckt also dieses Versprechen hochkant und Porträt.
Und wenn es funktioniert ist es bestimmt sensationell. Auf der anderen Seite Man hat dann immer Frank Rieger schreibt gerade an seinem Buch das nicht nur eine Handlung hat sondern wo man als Leser so mitentscheidet wann biegt man irgendwo ab dann überspringt man fünf Seiten oder Sohne.
Ich habe damit immer Probleme. Ich mag es gern linear.
Besser finde ich diese Herangehensweise so sieben Minuten Content zu machen.
Meistens ist mir aufgefallen wenn ich wissen will was in dem Film vorkam oder so könnte ich nochmal gucken oder ich gehe zu YouTube und gucke mir den Trailer dazu an wo ich so ein bisschen Mehrwert bekomme.
Und diese fünf sechs Minuten können sehr lustig gestaltet sein.
Das ist tatsächlich ein und ausgebeutet das Format die technische Spielerei mit diesem Porträt und Landscape finde ich eine Seite die online ist.
So wie das Spiel drehen kann und das Video muss da schon immer neu laden und alles.
Es ist eine Spielerei die man ein paar Mal macht aber die sich ganz schnell abnutzt.
Wichtige Punkte. Neben dieser kulturellen Komponente diese Technik mitliefern wollen.
Aber da müssen sie wie gesagt liefern. Die Webseite verspricht noch nicht besonders viel.
Wenn das funktionieren würde haben wir auch wieder den Fall dass sie alles schon mitliefern das alles aus einer Hand kommt worauf jetzt die anderen Studios so langsam kommen.
Mit Disney Plus werden wir jetzt auch wenn es das in den USA schon gibt ja auch hier in unseren 20er Jahren jetzt sehr bald erleben und da ist auch die überlegung wenn wir direkt Content machen und eine eigene Plattform haben und der Content,
stattfindet dann verdienen wir besonders gut daran.
Es war.
An
Freien Tagen.
Kerstan.
Was hier gesagt wird ist ja dass die immer noch auf Fernseh denke drin sind.
Ich bin mir da ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sicher denn wenn ich mir bei Netflix gerade die Farbgebung ansehe von Serien dann ist es gerade darauf ausgelegt dass sich das überall auch am helllichten Tage irgendwo mit dem Smartphone in der Hand mir angucken kann oder mit dem Tablet.
Ob das so stimmt bin ich unschlüssig.
Bekam den,
Vornahmen.
Auf.
Facebook.
Die.
Investment,
Handels Börsen.
Na ja ich weiß nicht so recht.
Ich habe da meine Zweifel. Das würde ja bedeuten dass man eine Marktlücke gefunden hat die Qualität heißt,
dass sich Millionen danach sehnen endlich kurze Videos in einer hohen Qualität mit einem guten Regisseur im Hintergrund und tollen Schauspielern zu sehen.
Meine Erfahrung Wenn ich mir YouTube Kanäle die erfolgreich sind oder Instagram-Profil oder tipptopp Profile ansehe.
Die meisten Leute überhaupt keinen Qualitätsanspruch an diese Dinge haben sondern ihnen alles recht ist solange.
Die Auflösung okay ist. Aber es geht ja gerade dann nicht darum High Quality Inhalte zu präsentieren man sieht es ja auch bei diesen wirklich erfolgreichen Youtubern ja ohne weiteres,
eine Qualität liefern dass sie fast Hollywood gleichkäme oder zumindest dem ZDF alle Ehre machen könnte.
Und dennoch lassen sie bei dem improvisierten Stil Sie tun ja weiterhin so als würden sie sich alleine nur mit dem Selfie-Stick aufzeichnen und würden das am Ende händisch zusammenschneiden.
Man kennt ja auch Leute die für solche Kanäle arbeiten und da sind im Hintergrund dann fünf Leute die so tun als sei dieses neue lustig gedrehte sieben Minuten Video zwischen zwei Freunden entstanden.
Eine solche Sehnsucht nach Qualität. Ich habe eher den Eindruck dass Qualität für viele fast abschreckend.
Jetzt muss ich mich darauf einlassen während sie mir erzählt wie sie unter der Dusche steht und das Wasser abstellte um Wasser zu sparen.
Leichter verdaulich ist und vielleicht auch eben diese Art des Konsums viel gerechter wird.
Es ist super schwierig zum einen die Frage Mit wem konkurrieren die eigentlich.
Es gibt ja von Reed Hastings dem Netflix Chef dieses berühmte Zitat mit dem konkurrierte eigentlich mit dem Schlaf. Dann kam er mit,
Hollywood immer aggressiv provokanten Bogen gemacht was es angeht und räumte jetzt diese ganzen Preise ab.
Die Frage ist ja hier wie Wen ist klar Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie heißt zehn Stunden am Tag kann man davon ausgehen dass Menschen auf Displays gucken wo kriegt man noch die sieben Minuten her die man da für sich beansprucht.
Die Frage ist ja hier wie ist klar Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie heißt zehn Stunden am Tag kann man davon ausgehen dass Menschen auf das Blechkuchen wo kriegt man noch die sieben Minuten her die man da für sich beansprucht.
Du bist ja ein großer Verfechter von einer Zukunft. Tick tack Ich sehe das ja eher selbst wenn es eine Zukunft dafür gibt vermarkten lässt sie sich schwer.
Du bist ja ein großer Verfechter von der Zukunft. Ich sehe das ja eher die Zukunft dafür gibt vermarkten lässt sie sich schwer.
Instagram versucht ja nun jedes dritte Bild z.B. mit Werbung zu füllen.
Instagram versucht jedes dritte Bild zum Beispiel mit Werbung zu füllen funktioniert so ein bisschen bei mir ganz gut.
Funktioniert so ein bisschen bei mir ganz gut. Ich lasse mir einfach mal die an diese entspringt sofort der Algorithmus auf dem zeigt mir nur noch das kann man da sehr gut spielen da wo ich nie auf den Gedanken käme mir irgendwas davon zu kaufen.
Ich gehe immer interessant finde und entsprechend sofort der Algorithmus und zeigt mir nur noch dass,
wo ich nie auf die Gedankengänge tiptop gibt's ja schon so Möglichkeiten das Live Streams wo man dem Tiki-Taka dann Geld überweisen kann.
Ja ja gut da kriegt man so ein bisschen Marsha ab oder so.. Ich habe jedenfalls festgestellt dieses Experiment können alle mal machen.
Ja ja da kriegt.
Man will ja ein bisschen die Hoheit haben. Man geht durch die Story durch bei YouTube Snapchat Instagram wo auch immer das gleiche Prinzip In dem Moment wo du ja tippt gehts weiter.
Lange tippen heißt Du kannst ruhig nochmal kurz auf das Bild schauen oder Klick weiter und weiter klicken ist das Eigentliche.
Joshua Polski wird gleich ein Clip von ihm der hat jetzt eine neue Seite Input merkt ihm ruft man auf seinem Handy auf und man versteht es erst gar nicht weil man anfängt zu scrollen.
Man muss immer klicken um den Artikel zum nächsten zur nächsten Etappe des gleichen Artikels zu kommen sondern ist total verrückt.
Und wenn man jetzt mal von sich selbst einen Bildschirm Aufnahme macht wie man Storys schaut kriegt man gar nicht mit.
In dem Moment wie das tatsächlich für einen wirkt wenn man nämlich die gleiche Story Geschichte nochmal sich dann als Video anschaut findet man nicht eingreifen kann wenn man da sieht wie das dadurch flackert denkt man sich.
Das hab ich mir gerade so angeguckt Bin ich bescheuert. Also in dem Moment da wo man sich mal als Akteur rausnimmt aber sich dasselbe anguckt versteht man wie irre das ist so und die wollen jetzt Leuten die das genauso machen.
Also sieben Minuten lang irgendwie da durch flippen an der Kasse stehen oder was weiß ich wo die denn jetzt eine Einbahnstraße vorlegen bei der sie noch entscheiden können hochkant oder Querformat.
Aber wo dieses Klicken wegfällt und die Hoheit über den Bildschirm und so weiter.
Und da sehe ich absolut gar keine Chance. Da ist einfach null Chance den Leuten das zu verklickern dass sie jetzt sieben Minuten lang nur stillhalten und zuschauen müssen.
So High Quality kann sieben Minuten Content gar nicht sein.
Einen schönen Aufsatz Der ist Jahrzehnte alt von Marcel Reich-Ranicki.
Da geht es um die Frage warum die Menschen keine Kurzgeschichten mehr lesen.
Sie haben zu wenig Zeit. Was er damit meint ist Romane kann man den Roman.
Nicht verstanden zu haben. Bei einer Kurzgeschichte muss man Wort für Wort lesen.
Und genau das tut man nicht wenn man in einer U-Bahn sitzt tut man nicht wenn man gerade im Wartezimmer sitzt und diese Kurzfilme wie sie gebaut werden gebaut sein werden.
Die sind auch eher solche die man sehr konzentriert sich angucken muss,
so erfolgreich ist weil er doch von einem abverlangt zehn Minuten sich auf eine Geschichte die abgeschlossen ist zu konzentrieren Kurzfilmfestival zu besuchen sind extrem anstrengend.
Und was erwartet wird ist in meinen Augen totaler Blödsinn nämlich viel konzentrierter als wenn sie eine Netflix Serie sich anschauen.
Ja ich bin sehr gespannt. Sie müssen ja jetzt starten Sie kommen nicht mehr drum herum. Irgendwas müssen sie da.
Ich sehe da auch auf der anderen Seite vielleicht konkurrieren sie tatsächlich mit diesen. Das erlebe ich an mir auch Abenden wo man nicht so genau weiß bei Netflix was kriegt man denn nun.
Es dauert noch zwei Monate bis Westwall PKI Ja da kommt die nächste Folge erst in einer Woche und was guckt man denn nun ja.
Der Angesprochene Joshua to Polski hat in seinem eigenen Podcast eine interessante Beobachtung an sich selbst vorgenommen.
Es ist.
Ein.
Signal.
Des Machtkartell.
Ja selber genervt vom bin ich Watson nach zehn Folgen nähern.
Die Frage hab ich damals auch bei Breaking Bad gemacht. Ich habe das so geguckt angefangen als alle geguckt haben und dann ging es so wie ich und ich dachte Wann passiert wann geht's los ungefähr wie beim Joker.
Zwei Stunden Filme geht ja jetzt los und es ist immer nur ständig diese Psychologisieren Reihe also irgendwie.
Es gibt da doch wenig so wie bei Westwall wo ich sage wenn die neue Folge kommt gucke ich die alte nochmal und dann die neue Version.
Irgendwie ist das Angebot doch schmal was das Eigeninteresse angeht.
Ich glaube es liegt nicht nur am eigenen Interesse Ich glaube dass wir zu jeder Zeit das so haben dass wir ein paar gute Werke haben und manchmal gibt es eine Hochphase.
Die 70er Jahre waren für Hollywood sicherlich so dass da überdurchschnittlich viel Gutes produziert wurde.
Aber rückblickend kann man immer sagen bleibt relativ wenig.
Aber.
Und gerade für jemand der dann schon viel gesehen hat der kann schneller aussieben und für den Esters vielleicht etwas deutlicher dann aber wir werden den Start von GWB auf jeden Fall erleben.
Dies.
Es ist aber auch gut möglich dass wir auch den Untergang,
erleben und vielleicht auch noch dieses Jahr. Wir sind jetzt schon so so spät.
Vielleicht.
Ja wir sind wir sind super dann wahrscheinlich wir vertagen alle Themen auf Februar die jetzt noch offen sind wir gehen. Wir gehen jetzt in den Salon.
Wahrscheinlich müssen wir schielen,
und wir würden dann einen Salon eröffnen oder wir gehen jetzt in den Salon erklären doch mal was das ist oder erklären wir es lesen wir uns gegenseitig die Texte vor die uns beeindruckt haben.
Im Salon lesen wir uns gegenseitig Wolfgang und ich die Texte vor die uns beeindruckt haben in diesem Monat.
Wir empfehlen sie Wir lesen sie nicht ganz. Ich empfehle zum Beispiel ein Buch und wer denn jetzt ein Buch vorlesen keine Sorge.
Wir empfehlen sie aber ein paar Auszüge.
Aber so Sachen die zum Monat passen aus dem Monat kommen keine Ahnung Bezug zum Monat haben.
Dass wir eine Woche später erscheinen.
Das Koppeln wir aber extra ab und es wird auch immer eine Woche später erscheinen als diese Monats folge.
Und die wird es dann spätestens ab März auch mit einer harten harten harten Paywall geben denn das Medium Podcast ist soweit man kann auch einfach Quebecs mäßig Salon verkaufen.
Und spätestens ab März auch mit einer Paywall geben,
auch einfach.
Verkaufen. Wir finanzieren uns damit dass es unsere Idee.
Und wir bieten dann mehr Inhalt an der auch dafür sorgt dass man sich jetzt auch mit vielen Dingen die wir angesprochen haben oder die sonst uns auch bewegt haben in den vergangenen Monaten mit denen man sich dann beschäftigen kann.
Denn das ist etwas was ich feststelle.
Es gibt so fünf sechs Texte die so durchs Netz und die hat irgendwie jeder wahrgenommen.
Aber es gibt doch sehr viel was man da noch nicht wahrgenommen hat was man erst dann findet wenn man mit jemand anders spricht der sagte Ich lese immer diese eine Wirtschaftszeitung weil sie das liest.
Und das finde ich eigentlich sehr schön dass wir uns jetzt gegenseitig Dinge empfehlen können. Man weiß.
Genau. Oder man. Man weiß dass es ein Text gibt aber man kennt nur die überschrift weil man mal wieder doch zu faul war zu lesen.
Ja was eigentlich drin. Und wir haben auch beide so den Anspruch ein bisschen originell zu sein.
Da kann man hier ein bisschen nachholen was eigentlich drin stand in den Briefen.
Wir wollen wir wollen auch beide originell sein und deswegen haben wir jetzt nicht einfach die letzte Spiegel Online Kolumne dabei schließen wir diese große Monatsausgaben.
Das prüfen wir gleich mal das prüfen wir gleich.
Nee nee nee nee. Dann schließen wir diese große Monatsausgaben heute indem wir jetzt zehn Minuten um eine Klammer zu machen Fratzscher gegen Mertz zum Ausklang hören.
Im
März zum Ausklang und die Fragestellung ist einfach nur sich selber beantworten.
Die Fragestellung ist einfach nur die kann man sich selber beantworten.
Redet hier tatsächlich ein ökonom darüber dass wir ein politisches Primat wieder brauchen.
Redet hier tatsächlich ein ökonom.
Darüber dass wir ein politisches Primat wieder brauchen. Gegen einen Politiker der ein ökonomisches Primat einfordert. Ist es wirklich so irre.
Gegen einen Politiker der ein ökonomisches Primat einfordert ist es wirklich so.. Vielleicht ja.
Anschließen wir in der nächsten Folge an diese Frage die ist hochinteressant.
Und daran schließen wir dann genau in der nächsten Folge an wie der Bogen geschlagen wird.
Üblicherweise kommen wir ja immer am letzten Tag oder am letzten Freitag des Monats der am nächsten am Monatsende liegt heraus da allerdings im Februar mal Berlinale sein wird liegt die Februar-Ausgabe ein bisschen früher und wir hoffen einfach mal,
dass die nächsten zwei Wochen nicht allzu viel passiert wie in diesem Januar,
sodass wir den Januar nacharbeiten können im Februar ohne gleich wieder vom Februar überwältigt zu werden.
Es ist unglaublich viel Bewegung aber wir nehmen mal an Trump ist noch Präsident Mitte Februar und wir können noch mal die restliche dass die Reste des Januars zusammenkehren.
Und irgendwie bin ich auch der Hoffnung dass das Jahr danach ein bisschen entspannter wird aber es war unglaublich viel los im Januar.
Es sind noch ein paar Themen offenes werdet ihr denn wie gesagt im Februar hören,
würde ich sagen zehn Minuten Auto Fratzscher gegen März Das war eine Phoenix im Dialog oder so heißt das folge oder Konfrontation keine Ahnung ich habs zusammengeschnitten auf runde zehn Minuten.
Dann hören wir uns dann als nächstes in einer Woche im Salon und dann schon eine Woche später wieder in der Februar-Ausgabe in der wir auf den Januar blicken und so entwickeln dass wir Schritt für Schritt vorwärts macht es gut.
Ich freue mich sehr auf meine beiden Gäste bei uns Friedrich Merz Vizepräsident des Wirtschaftsrats der CDU und bei uns Professor Marcel Fratzscher Präsident des Deutschen Instituts für Wirtschaftsforschung.
Herr Merz CSU-Chef Söder hat ja das politische Jahr direkt mit einer Forderung nach Kabinettsumbildung begonnen.
Wollen wir das Kabinett retten oder wollen wir über Geld reden. Drei und zehn komma fünf Milliarden Euro überschuss. Das ist ja doch ordentlich.
Nichts desto trotz fordern ökonomen wie sie und auch Teile der SPD die beiden Vorsitzenden dass Deutschland wieder richtig Schulden macht. Deutschland soll keine Schulden machen Wir leben in wirtschaftlich guten Zeiten.
Nur was mir in der Diskussion zu kurz kommt das viel zu viel auf die Schulden fokussiert wird was muss der Staat den Bürgern zurückzahlen was ist an Verschuldung.
Und was wir ignorieren ist das was an Vermögen da ist.
In den letzten 15 Jahren sind die Vermögenswerte des Staates die Wert von Brücken von Straßen von Schul Einrichtungen von öffentlichem Vermögen die wir haben schneller gesunken als die Schulden.
Dieses Denken Man muss bloß keinen Euro ausgeben und alles auf die hohe Kante legen.
Das ist wirklich die schlechteste Wirtschaftspolitik sondern muss sich fragen Was muss in die Zukunft investiert werden.
Und dann sind wir ganz schnell dort was wir sagen da haben wir ein riesiges Problem und die Politik.
Um diese Probleme zu beheben. Sie und einige Ihrer Kollegen machen ja gerade den Vorschlag jetzt Schulden zu machen und es ist ein absurder Vorschlag.
Wir haben nicht ein Problem mit zu wenig Geld wir kriegen dieses Geld nicht verbaut.
Aber woran liegt das. Darüber müssen wir reden weil der Staat viel zu lange gespart hat.
Bauämter ausgedünnt hat Leute nicht neu eingestellt. Es fehlen die Kapazitäten.
Diese schwarze Null ist kein kein Popanz kein Fetisch an dem man festhalten muss aber wir haben Wachstum.
Wir haben hohe Steuereinnahmen die sogar höher sind als das Wachstum jetzt überschreiten bei 800 Milliarden Euro Steuereinnahmen in diesem Jahr im Jahr 2023 überschreiten 900 Milliarden Euro Steuereinnahmen pro Jahr.
Also ein Land mit 80 Millionen Einwohnern muss doch mit 800 Milliarden Euro Steuereinnahmen auskommen ohne neue Schulden zu machen.
Im übrigen meine Kinder und ihre müssen die Schulden irgendwann bezahlen.
Wir reden mit die Kinder Wir reden über Generationengerechtigkeit. Was ist im Interesse der künftigen Generationen.
Keine Schulden zu haben die im Augenblick übrigens dem Staat null Prozent Zinsen kosten.
Also eine der wichtigsten Gründe für die gute Lage im Haushalt ist dass der Staat immer weniger Zinsen zahlen muss auf die Schulden mittlerweile negativ für eine zehnjährige Staatsanleihen.
Was ist wichtiger keine Schulden keine Steuern um Schulden zu bedienen zahlen zu müssen oder gute Jobs zu haben in wettbewerbsfähigen Unternehmen die im globalen Wettbewerb bestehen können.
Da muss eine Priorität gesetzt haben dass neue Schulden im Gegensatz zu früher sogar gerade Generationen gerecht sind.
Wenn man an die großen Herausforderungen denkt absolut Generationen gerecht wenn man über gerade über Klimaschutz redet.
Wir sehen doch schon was. Was die Naturkatastrophen und der Klimawandel an massiven Kosten verursacht.
Wir werden nicht beides realisieren können schwarze Null überschüsse machen und gleichzeitig die großen Zukunftsinvestitionen zu tätigen.
Eine ehrliche Ansage ist das können sie nicht. Man muss sich wirklich entscheiden Was ist wichtiger.
Wir haben zu wenig Lehrer wir haben zu wenig Fachpersonal Wir haben zu wenig Pflegekräfte.
Wir haben zu wenig baut Kapazitäten Planungs Kapazitäten gerade bei den Kommunen über die Hälfte aller Investitionen werden von den Kommunen getätigt im öffentlichen Bereich.
30 Prozent der Kommunen sind überschuldet können das gar nicht.
Die können gar nicht die Leute einstellen um das zu bewältigen.
Ich bin bei Ihnen Herr Merz dass wir ein großes Problem mit der Bürokratie haben das ist eine große Herausforderung dass Bürokratie abgebaut werden muss Genehmigungsverfahren schneller stattfinden müssen.
Aber die Kommunen müssen auch wieder mehr Geld haben um Personal aufzubauen.
Wir brauchen einen langfristigen Investitionsprogramm eine Vision.
Wenn sie den Kommunen oder Unternehmen sagen Wir gehen jetzt 20 Milliarden mehr Geld aus für ein oder zwei Jahre da wird ja keiner Kapazitäten aufbauen.
Als Unternehmer werden Sie ja nur dann neue Menschen einstellen neue Maschinen kaufen wenn sie wissen Das wird für zehn oder 15 Jahre weitergehen.
Großer Konsens bei uns Wirtschaftswissenschaftlern zu sagen Wir brauchen eigentlich über einen über 10 15 Jahre angelegtes Investitionsprogramm in Deutschland wo Verlässlichkeit drin ist wo die Unternehmen aber auch die Kommunen wissen.
Da kommt Geld das steht zur Verfügung wir können wirklich langfristig planen. Das ist eigentlich die Essenz. Um dieses Problem zu lösen.
Vollkommen unberücksichtigt bleibt in dieser Diskussion Wir sind Vertragspartner eines Stabilitäts und Wachstumspakts der Europäischen Union und des Maastricht-Vertrages.
Und in diesem Maastricht-Vertrag hat sich Deutschland wie viele andere Staaten auch verpflichtet in guten Zeiten keine Schulden zu machen sondern ausgeglichene Haushalte zu haben oder überschüsse.
Das machen wir im Augenblick Wir verhalten uns vertragstreu das was die Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute teilweise vorschlagen.
Eklatanter Bruch des Maastricht-Vertrages Die Schuldenbremse ist aus zwei Gründen eigentlich ökonomisch vielleicht nicht politisch aber ökonomisch unsinnig.
Was eigentlich zählt sind die zwei Milliarden Euro die Schulden des Staates relativ zur Wirtschaftsleistung das ist was zählt da ist Deutschland komplett mit den europäischen Regeln unter 60 Prozent.
Wenn man in Deutschland jedes Jahr 3,5 Prozent Neuverschuldung hat dann würde dieser Schuldenstand Quote stabil bleiben das ist ein erster Kritik und der vielleicht wichtigere Kritikpunkt ist die Schuldenbremse,
erlaubt es dem Staat in guten Zeiten zu expansiv zu sein aber in schlechten Zeiten erlaubt es ihnen nicht.
Stabilisierend genug zu wirken.
Deshalb ist das was ich als sinnvoll erachte die Schuldenbremse zu ergänzen mit einer Investitions Regel allein.
Bund Länder und Kommunen zu sagen Ja ihr müsst euch an die Schuldenbremse halten.
Aber die Investitionen ins Bildungssystem in eine gute Infrastruktur darf darunter nicht leiden die Arbeitsmärkte sind in allen Ländern dort wo die Schulden niedrig ist,
in einer guten Verfassung überall da wo die Schulden hoch sind sind auch die Arbeitsmärkten in einer schlechten Verfassung. Teilen Sie die Analyse.
Nein wir haben in Deutschland eine riesige demografischen Wandel vor uns.
Wir haben eine Alterung die jetzt schon eingetreten ist. Die Beschäftigtenzahlen werden irgendwann sinken wenn wir nicht eine massive Zuwanderung haben.
Heißt die Sozialausgaben in der gesetzlichen Rentenversicherung im Gesundheitsbereich in allen Bereichen werden ansteigen.
Zu sagen Wir haben jetzt diese schönen überschüsse lass uns doch mal die Steuern senken halte ich auch für nicht ehrlich weil man in drei vier Jahren realisiert.
Diese Einnahmen gehen ja runter weil immer mehr Menschen in Rente gehen immer weniger Arbeitnehmerinnen Arbeitnehmer trifft.
Wir brauchen auch da wieder diese langfristige Perspektive zu realisieren wir haben eine riesige Herausforderung mit der demographischen Wende mit unserem Sozialsystem.
Das neue Führungsduo der SPD setzt sich ja auch für höhere Steuern ein mit Vermögenssteuer Erbschaftsteuerreform Anhebung des Spitzensteuersatzes.
Drehen Sie damit an der Steuerschraube was auch zur Wahrheit dazugehört ist nicht nur dass Unternehmen relativ hohe Steuern zahlen müssen sondern dass es kein anderes Land in der Welt gibt wo Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer mehr Steuern zahlen müssen,
und wo Vermögen und Einkommen auf Vermögen geringer besteuert wird als in Deutschland. Wir haben hier eine große Unwucht.
Welchen Bereich wären Sie denn für höhere Steuern.
Ich wäre für eine stärkere Belastung von passiven Vermögen.
Nehmen Sie das Thema Erbschaftssteuer Wir haben Menschen die weniger als erstes haben wir weniger als die Hälfte der Deutschen die überhaupt etwas erben.
Die Menschen die zwischen 250000 500 Euro erben zahlen Durchschnitt 12 Prozent Erbschaftssteuer.
Die die mehr als 20 Millionen Euro erben zahlen im Durchschnitt weniger als zwei Prozent Erbschaftssteuer.
Da geht es eigentlich um Steuergerechtigkeit. Wären Sie da dabei.
Das ist nicht so. Das sind Zahlen die hier in den Raum geworfen werden. Und deswegen habe ich dazwischen gerufen.
Das sind zum ganz großen Teil Unternehmen die das Geld in den Unternehmen.
Die gehören dann der nächsten Generation. Wenn Sie die mit 25 Prozent Erbschaftssteuer belasten machen die Unternehmen zu.
Wenn sie mit fünf oder zehn Prozent belasten können tun sie es nicht. Ich bin nun in drei Erbschaftsteuerreform dabeigewesen.
Ich habe dieses eine endlose Geschichte in Deutschland die letzte Erbschaftsteuerreform ist so gemacht worden dass insbesondere die mittelständischen Eigentümer geführten Unternehmen verschont werden wenn sie die Arbeitsplätze erhalten und nur dann wenn sie die Arbeitsplätze erhalten haben Sie diese Verschonung.
Das ist also wirklich das ist jetzt ein Griff in die Mottenkiste mit den 100 000 und den 20Millionen Das ist kein Barvermögen was die Leute Cash ausgezahlt bekommen sondern es liegt in den Betrieben.
Wenn Sie diese Unternehmenslandschaft in Deutschland beschädigen wollen oder wirklich dann nachhaltig zerschlagen wollen dann müssen sie mit der Erbschaftsteuer den Weg gegen den Sieg gehen den sie gerade vorschlagen.
Dann haben wir den Mittelstand in Deutschland nicht mehr.
Nein das ist ein Droese nahe wo wir genau wissen dass das nicht passieren wird.
Wir haben doch alle gehabt. Aber man kann eine Erbschaftssteuer genau so gestalten dass sie fair ist dass alle gleich belastet werden dass man eine Substanzbesteuerung also das was sie waren dass Unternehmen Probleme kommen vermeiden kann.
Aber das gehört zu einer Erbschaftssteuer dazu zu einer klugen Steuerreform dazu genauso wie Reform von Grund und Boden.
Also gerade Grunt Steuer muss jetzt eine meiner Ansicht nach fauler Kompromiss war der hier gefunden wurde.
Wo Grund und Boden relativ schwach besteuert werden. Hier geht es darum die Frage Wie kann der Staat die Aufgaben die er hat finanzieren.
Und zur Wahrheit gehört dazu dass Menschen gerade mit mittleren und geringen Einkommen ungewöhnlich stark besteuert werden.
Und dazu gehört es was einer ökonomischen Sicht Man kann über Gerechtigkeit streiten aber aus einer ökonomischen Sicht macht es viel Sinn Menschen mit mittlerem geringen Einkommen zu entlasten damit sich Arbeit mehr lohnt dass Menschen auch wieder mehr arbeiten können.
Das wäre eine wirtschaftlich sinnvollere. Wir haben die obersten fünf Prozent in Deutschland zahlen 50 Prozent der Einkommenssteuer Herr Merz.
Zur Wahrheit führt auch dazu dass in den letzten 20 Jahren 30 Prozent der bester Besserverdiener in Deutschland steuerlich entlastet wurden Sie zahlen einen geringeren Anteil ihres Einkommens monatlich an Steuern die unteren 70 Prozent stärker belastet. Das gilt auch für die Zahlen.
Das sind offizielle Zahlen. Wo kommen die her. Da rechnen Sie dann aber alles zusammen.
Mit Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen Gesetzen Mehrwert also nicht Steuern sondern Abgaben Steuern Mehrwertsteuer gehört auch dazu also Mehrwertsteuer ist auch eine Steuer.
Was ist gerade was mit geringen Einkommen zu einem viel höheren Teil zahlen als Einkommenssteuer. Letzte Frage Wie lange wird Olaf Scholz noch Finanzminister sein was glauben Sie.
Man kann es für diese Koalition eigentlich nur hoffen. Aber die Sozialdemokraten müssen uns am Ende des Tages entscheiden.
Ich glaube er ist ein Stabilitätsfaktor für diese Koalition aber diese Koalition hat mittlerweile andere Kraftzentren andere Machtzentren.
Und das wird eine spannende Frage der nächsten Wochen und Monate.
Intro